♪
>> THIS IS THE MLB GAME OF THE
WEEK, PREGAME SHOW PRESENTED BY
TIME.
GUESS WHO'S IN THE LINEUP
TONIGHT?
THAT GUY.
>> IF THERE WAS EVER THE DUAL
THREAT, YOU ARE LOOKING AT IT.
NUMBER 17.
>> HE'S IN THE TWO SPOT FOR THE
ANGELS.
HE WILL BE ON THE MOUND.
HE'S A STRIKEOUT MACHINE.
THE ANGELS TEAM IS LOOKING TO
WIPE AWAY A THREE-GAME LOSING
SKID.
THEY FACE OFF AGAINST THE
DETROIT TIGERS.
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
PITCHING PAIRING IS MATT
MANNING.
THIS IS A BIG DEAL PROSPECT.
6'6".
HE HAS BIG-TIME STUFF.
>> HE CAN GET UP NEAR TRIPLE
DIGITS.
2019, A BIG YEAR IN DOUBLE-A
BALL.
SOME PEOPLE THOUGHT STUFF WISE,
HE MIGHT BE THEIR BEST PROSPECT
COMING UP IN THE MINOR LEAGUES.
>> EVEN BETTER THAN CASEY MIZE
OR?
>> BIG FASTBALL.
HE WILL HIT TRIPLE DIGITS ON
OCCASION.
>> DAN PLESAC AND SCOTT BRAUN
WITH YOU FOR THE NEXT 30
MINUTES.
THEN WE WILL GET YOU TO FIRST
PITCH WITH OHTANI AND THE MOUND
ON THIS ONE.
LET'S RECOPY ON HOW THESE TEAMS
DID YESTERDAY.
>> WILLI CASTRO STANDS IN WITH
THE RUNNER ON FIRST AND NOBODY
DOWN.
A DRIVE TO RIGHT CENTER FIELD.
DEAD BALL IS DEEP AND GONE.
WILLI CASTRO WITH A TWO RUN SHOT
TO TIE IT UP AT 3-3.
IT GETS BY GALLAGHER.
GROSSMAN WILL SCORE.
THE TIGERS TAKE THE LEAD.
SWUNG ON AND MISSED.
HE STRIKES OUT PEREZ ON THREE
PITCHES TO END IT.
>> HERE'S PENDER.
PENDER HEADING FOR BROWN.
THAT'S A LINE DRIVE BASE HIT
LEFT FIELD.
LOWERY WILL SCORE.
THE GAME IS TIED AT 4-4.
>> THE BASES WILL BE LOADED WITH
NOBODY OUT.
A THING OF BEAUTY.
GAVIN COMES.
>> HE'S LOOKING FOR CONTACT
WHICH WOULD LIKELY BE THEIR
SEVENTH RUN.
FLETCHER COMING HOME.
EVERYBODY IS SAFE.
IT IS 7-4.
SCOTT: THE A'S ARE REALLY GOOD.
THIS IS THEIR STARTING LINEUP
TONIGHT.
ROBBIE GROSSMAN, THEIR BEST
HITTER RECENTLY HAS BEEN
JONATHAN SCHOOP.
HE HIT BOMBS WITH MANNY MACHADO
IN BALTIMORE.
HE WAS A SECOND BASEMAN BACK
THEN.
MICKEY IS IN THERE.
ERIC HAASE HAS BEEN A BIG STORY
FOR THE TIGERS.
AKIL BADDOO.
DAZ CAMERON IS THE SON OF MIKE
CAMERON, A YOUNG PROSPECT WITH
THE TIGERS.
THE ANGELS FEATURE JUSTIN UPTON
AT THE TOP.
OFFENSE HAS BEEN BREAKING MORE
WITH HIM IN THE LEADOFF SPOT.
DAN: UNCONVENTIONAL GUY AT THE
TOP OF THE ORDER.
A LOT OF TEAMS HAVE GONE TO
THAT.
CUBS HAVE DONE THAT.
PUT THEN AT THE TOP.
SCOTT: SHOHEI OHTANI IS PITCHING
TONIGHT.
THERE IS NO DH.
THEY GO WITH OHTANI IN THE
LINEUP.
HE IS THE LEADING CANDIDATE FOR
DH TO REPRESENT THE AMERICAN
LEAGUE AT THE ALL-STAR GAME.
MORE ON THAT LATER.
SHOHEI OHTANI IS THE MOST UNIQUE
PLAYER MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL AT
THIS POINT.
DAN: HE IS HARD TO CALM.
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO COMP THIS
GUY.
WE'VE SEEN NOTHING LIKE THIS
WHEN HE CAME FROM JAPAN, THE
FIRST SPRING TRAINING WHEN HE
WAS IN TEMPE, HE WAS AWFUL
HITTING AND HE WAS ALSO
PITCHING.
THE WORD WAS, IS HE GOING TO
MAKE THE TEAM?
THERE'S MIKE TROUT GOING DOWN.
EVERYBODY THOUGHT THE ANGELS
SEASON WAS GOING DOWN THE DRAIN.
GUESS WHAT HAPPENED.
IT'S OHTANI LAND.
WATCH WHERE THIS BALL GOES.
THIS IS LIKE NEARLY 500 FEET.
THIS ONE IS AN ABSOLUTE MISSILE.
THAT'S OFF OF A GOOD FRIEND OF
MINE.
THAT WAS OFF OF MY NEPHEW ZACH.
WHAT COULD HE DO ON THE MOUND?
ELECTRIC.
HE'S AN ACE TOP OF THE ROTATION.
95-100.
101.
HE THROWS ABSOLUTE BULLETS.
YOU GET UP THERE AND YOU ARE
LOOKING FOR THAT 97-100.
YOU ARE LIKE, I WILL GET THIS
GUY.
HE MOVES THE BALL IN, OUT, UP,
DOWN.
THE DREADED EQUALIZER.
MOST PITCHERS CALL THAT THE
CHANGE UP YOUR GET WITH HIM, IT
IS THE SPLITFINGER.
ANYWHERE FROM 84 TO 90 MILES PER
HOUR.
HE HAS A GOOD SLIDER TO GO ALONG
WITH IT.
WE'VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THIS GUY.
HE'S IMPOSSIBLE FOR ME TO COMP
TWO.
NOBODY HITS LIKE THIS GUY DOES.
HOW COULD YOU EVEN WARM UP FOR A
GAME?
YOU ARE GETTING YOUR WARM-UPS.
YOU ARE ALSO HITTING SECOND.
WHAT ARE YOU THINKING ABOUT?
PITCHING, WHAT YOU WILL DO IN
THE BOTTOM OF THE INNING?
THIS GUY HAS A LOT OF DIFFERENT
THINGS GOING ON.
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT GRAPHIC.
THAT SAYS IT ALL.
THAT SCREAMS ALL-STAR.
HE HAS TO BE -- WHAT WOULD BE
THE COOLEST THING EVER WOULD BE
FOR HIM TO START THE ALL-STAR
GAME ON THE MOUND AND GET IN AT
BAT.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN BASEBALL WANT TO SEE.
THEY WANT TO SEE MORE OF OHTANI.
SCOTT: THE WORLD DESERVES IT
RIGHT NOW.
THAT'S A GREAT PLAN.
I DID NOT THINK ABOUT THAT.
SHOHEI OHTANI AT THE PLATE IS
PROBABLY MORE WORRIED ON A DAY
LIKE TODAY ABOUT HOW HIS
PITCHING PERFORMANCES GOING.
MAYBE THAT HELPS EVEN.
THERE'S NO NERVES.
DAN: THINK ABOUT ALL THE THINGS
I COULD GO WRONG.
YOU FOUL THE BALL OFF OF YOUR
FOOT.
HE'S DONE THIS BEFORE.
HE FOULED IT OFF OF HIS KNEE.
YOU HAVE TO BE CAREFUL IF YOU
ARE THE ANGELS.
YOU DON'T WANT TO SEND HIM OUT
HERE IF HE IS FAVORING THE KNEE
AND HE HURTS HIS SHOULDER.
THEY'VE USED HIM IN THE
OUTFIELD.
THESE IN CRIPPLE PLAYER.
SCOTT: YOU WILL SEE HIM ABOUT 20
MINUTES FROM NOW.
ON THE MOUND, AT THE PLATE.
YOU WILL GET A GREAT CALL ON
YOUTUBE COMING UP WHEN THEY GET
TO THEIR FOR FIRST PITCH.
THAT ALSO INCLUDES DURING THE
GAME, PULL QUESTIONS TO GET YOU
INVOLVED.
I KNOW YOU ARE WATCHING FROM
HOME.
ON YOUR MOBILE DEVICE.
YOU ARE GOING, I WANT TO
PARTICIPATE.
YOU CAN.
THAT'S WHAT YOUTUBE IS ALL
ABOUT.
TIGER SENT ANGELS.
NICE AND SIMPLE FOR THE PREGAME
SHOW.
WHO WILL WIN TONIGHT'S GAME?
THE TIGERS WITH MATT MANNING OR
SHOHEI OHTANI WITH THAT SHINY
E.R.A.
MUCH MORE TO GO ON THE PREGAME
SHOW.
THAT INCLUDES OHTANI, MIKE  GAME
IN THE THIRD INNING TONIGHT.
BIG DAY ON YOUTUBE.
♪
>> SANTANA LIFTS THAT ONE LEFT
FIELD.
JUSTIN HAS A LONG WAY TO GO.
STILL GLOWING.
UPTON WITH THE CATCH.
ATTABOY.
BACK TO THE WALL.
UP AGAINST IT.
LEAPS.
HELLO.
BACK INTO THE YARD.
>> THAT'S A HOMER.
>> THAT'S OVER THE YELLOW LINE.
>> BASE HIT, LEFT FIELD ON THE
FASTBALL HERE.
HERE COMES OHTANI.
TO THE PLATE.
NOT IN TIME.
1-0 HALOS.
>> NUMBER 600 OF HIS CAREER FOR
ANTHONY RENDON.
>> IGLESIAS SQUARES ONE UP.
THAT IS HIT WELL TO CENTER
FIELD.
HE CAN'T MAKE THE PLAY.
THE ANGELS HAVE TAKEN A ONE RUN
LEAD.
>> THIS IS WHAT THEY'VE GOT.
THEY'VE GOT THAT FIGHT.
>> THEY WERE UP TO DO AS MUCH
DAMAGE AS THEY COULD.
>> SHOHEI, SORRY AND ARE A.
WHERE DID THAT LAND?
2-0 ANGELS.
SHOHEI, GOODNESS.
♪
SCOTT: WELCOME BACK TO THE MLB
GAME OF THE WEEK PREGAME SHOW.
DAN: WHAT'S GOING ON IN HIS MIND
RIGHT NOW?
SCOTT: WE ARE PRESENTED BY
CHIME.
GETTING YOU UP TO FIRST PITCH.
HIGHEST CONTACT RATE IN MAJOR
LEAGUE BASEBALL BELONGS TO DAVID
FLETCHER.
NICK MADRIGAL OUT FOR THE REST
OF THE SEASON.
FLETCH HAS BEEN A DO IT ALL GUY
FOR THE ANGELS.
DAVID FLETCHER OF THE ANGELS
JOINS US RIGHT NOW.
THANKS FOR THE TIME.
LOOKS LIKE TERRIBLE WEATHER OUT
THERE, AS USUAL.
I KNEW YOU GREW UP IN THE AREA.
DO YOU EVER GO OUTSIDE, TAKE
YOUR TIME, LOOK AROUND AND GO,
THERE'S NEVER GOING TO BE A RAIN
DELAY HERE.
>> [LAUGHTER]
WE ARE REALLY LUCKY HERE, ALWAYS
GOOD WEATHER.
WE HAD ONE RAIN DELAY LAST YEAR
OR THE YEAR BEFORE.
MAYBE THE FIRST ONE EVER.
SCOTT: SUPER WEIRD WHEN THERE'S
RAIN.
IT'S VERY RARE.
WE TALK ABOUT IT WHEN WE SEE IT
OUT THERE.
IT IS SUCH A BEAUTIFUL DAY JUST
ABOUT EVERY DAY.
YOU CAN'T BEAT THIS JOB.
YOU GREW UP IN ORANGE COUNTY.
WHAT WAS IT LIKE PLAYING
BASEBALL IN THE AREA?
WHO DID YOU WATCH AND ROOT FOR?
GIVE US THE GOODS.
>> PLAYING AROUND HERE, I GOT TO
PLAY ALL YEAR LONG WITH THE
WEATHER.
NOT A LOT OF PEOPLE GET TO DO
THAT AROUND THE COUNTRY.
I THINK THAT REALLY HELPED ME
GROWING UP.
PLAYERS I'VE WATCHED GROWING UP,
DAVID ECKSTEIN, TRIA WAS A GOOD
ONE FOR ME.
ENJOYED THE WAY THEY PLAYED AND
MODELED MY GAME AFTER THEM.
SCOTT: HAVE YOU BEEN ABLE TO
CONNECT WITH THEM?
>> LUCKILY FOR ME, ECKSTEIN CAME
TO SPRING TRAINING A FEW TIMES.
I GOT TO TALK TO HIM AND PICK
HIS BRAIN.
THAT HAS BEEN GREAT FOR ME, TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE CONTACT WITH
HIM.
SCOTT: HOW MUCH DOES IT MEAN TO
YOU TO GET A COMP LIKE DAVID
ECKSTEIN BASED ON THE FACT THAT
HE WAS A CONTACT GAMER, DO
WHATEVER THE TEAM NEEDS?
HOW MUCH DOES IT MEAN TO YOU TO
WATCH HIM, HAVE HIM BE YOUR
FAVORITE PLAYER, IDOLIZE HIM
GROWING UP, AND TURN INTO A
GREAT VERSION OF HIM IN THE
MAJOR LEAGUES YOURSELF?
>> YEAH.
THAT'S THE BIGGEST COMP LAMENT I
CAN GET.
JUST PLAYING THE GAME THE RIGHT
WAY LIKE HE DID.
I MEAN, NOT TAKING ANYTHING FOR
GRANTED.
NOT GIVING AWAY AT-BATS.
SCOTT: A LOT OF PEOPLE WATCH YOU
AND SAY, I WANT TO DO WHAT DAVID
FLETCHER DOES.
I WANT TO BE THE GUY THAT MAKES
CONTACT AND HAS A GREAT I.
LET'S GO OVER EXACTLY THE LIFE
ON GAME DAY OF DAVID FLETCHER.
CAN YOU TAKE ME THROUGH YOUR
SCHEDULE AND LET ME KNOW IF IT'S
THE SAME THING EVERY DAY?
I WAKE UP FOR A GAME DAY LIKE
TODAY, WHAT TIME ARE YOU GETTING
TO THE PARK?
WHAT SPECIFIC THINGS ARE YOU
DOING?
WHEN ARE YOU LOOKING AT VIDEO
AND SCOUTING REPORTS?
GIVE ME THE SCHEDULE.
>> PRETTY SIMPLE GUY.
WAKE UP 10:00, SOMETIMES 11:00.
GET SOME BREAKFAST.
HEAD TO THE FIELD.
A GAME LIKE TODAY, GET HERE
AROUND 1:30 OR 2:00.
GET THE BODY LOOSE IN THE WEIGHT
ROOM.
MOVE AROUND A LITTLE BIT.
I HAVE A REAL SIMPLE CAGE
ROUTINE.
GET A COUPLE FLIPS.
GO OUT TO BP, TAKE GROUND BALLS.
GET SOME FOOD AND GET READY FOR
THE GAME.
SCOTT: WHAT ARE YOU EATING AND
DRINKING ON GAME DAY?
ANYTHING SPECIFIC?
>> A LOT OF WATER.
A LOT OF STUFF TO HYDRATE.
WHATEVER THEY'VE GOT IN THE FOOD
ROOM.
OCCASIONALLY, A PB&J.
SCOTT: POSTGAME CHILLING.
EVERYBODY DOES SOMETHING TO
UNWIND, TO RELAX.
I KNOW YOU LOVE TALKING THE
GAME.
AFTER YOU GET OUT OF THE
CLUBHOUSE COME YOU GET HOME OR
TO THE HOTEL ROOM.
WHAT IS THE GO TO FOR DAVID
FLETCHER TO SAY, LET ME WIND
DOWN AND GET SOME GOOD REST
TONIGHT?
>> WE'VE BEEN PLAYING A LOT OF
CARDS LATELY.
WE GOT SOME VIDEO GAMES ON THE
PHONE THAT WE PLAY WITH OHTANI
AND HIS TRANSLATOR.
OTHER THAN THAT, JUST HANGING
OUT AND HAVING FUN.
SCOTT: YOU MENTIONED OHTANI.
TAKE ME INSIDE THE LIFE OF
SHOHEI.
EVERYONE WANTS TO KNOW WHAT HE'S
LIKE.
WHAT'S IT LIKE PLAYING VIDEO
GAMES AGAINST HIM?
IS HE SUPER COMPETITIVE?
CAN HE DO EVERYTHING?
DOES HE PLAY AS TWO PLAYERS AT
ONCE?
>> [LAUGHTER]
HE'S REALLY COMPETITIVE.
HE'S GOOD AT ALMOST EVERYTHING
HE DOES.
IT'S FUN TO COMPETE WITH HIM.
HE'S PRETTY MUCH THE SAME GUY
ALL THE TIME.
IT'S FUN TO BE A RAMP -- AROUND.
SCOTT: HOW IS THE TEAM LOOKING
RIGHT NOW?
IF YOU COULD EVALUATE THE
ANGELS, ESPECIALLY OVER THE PAST
10 DAYS, WHAT IS IT LOOKING
LIKE?
>> WE'VE BEEN PLAYING GOOD.
WE ARE A LITTLE BANGED UP WITH
TROUT OUT, OBVIOUSLY.
RENDON HAS BEEN BANGED UP ALL
YEAR.
SEEMS LIKE WE ARE COMING
TOGETHER.
THE LAST COUPLE WEEKS HAVE BEEN
DEFINITELY TRENDING UPWARD.
SCOTT: YOU ARE FACING MATT
MANNING TONIGHT FOR THE TIGERS.
HE WENT TO LOYOLA MARYMOUNT --
NO SORRY.
YOU WENT THERE.
HE THOUGHT ABOUT GOING THERE.
INSTEAD, HE GOT DRAFTED.
HE WAS GOING TO PLAY BASKETBALL
AND BASEBALL.
WHAT DID HE MISS OUT ON AT
SCHOOL?
>> YEAH.
I HAD A GREAT TIME.
I WAS THERE FOR TWO YEARS AT
LMU.
A LOT OF GOOD EXPERIENCES.
GOOD DEVELOPMENT FOR ME AS A
BASEBALL PLAYER.
I REMEMBERED HEARING OF MANNING
WHEN HE WAS GOING TO GO THERE.
I THINK I WAS GONE ALREADY.
I HEARD A LOT OF GOOD THINGS
ABOUT HIM.
EXCITED TO FACE HIM TONIGHT.
SCOTT: BIG ATHLETIC KID.
LET'S FINISH WITH THIS.
KIDS WATCHING WOULD REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS.
YOU DO SOMETHING THAT ALMOST NO
OTHER BIG LEAGUER CAN DO AS WELL
AS YOU.
THERE ARE SOME OTHER NAMES THAT
COME TO MIND LIKE MICHAEL
BRANTLEY AND ADAM FRAZIER.
THE WAY THAT YOU ACTUALLY MAY
CONTACT, THE BAT TO BALL SKILLS.
HOW CAN YOU IMPROVE THAT FOR
KIDS WATCHING AT HOME?
HOW CAN THEY GET BETTER AT
MAKING CONTACT?
>> FOR ME, HAND-EYE
COORDINATION.
JUST HITTING A LOT AND PLAYING
PEPPER.
HITTING OFF OF THE MACHINE.
HAVING A SHORT SWING ALSO HELPS.
BEING ABLE TO GET THE BARREL TO
THE BALL.
SCOTT: THANKS FOR THE TIME.
ALWAYS GREAT TO CHAT.
GOOD LUCK.
>> APPRECIATE IT.
♪
SCOTT: LET'S CHECK OUT THE
LATEST GOOGLE ALL-STAR BALLOT
UPDATES FOR DESIGNATED HITTERS
IN THE AMERICAN LEAGUE.
LOOK WHO IS LEADING THE PACK.
PEOPLE WANT TO SEE SHOHEI.
DAN: HE'S LIKE THE MODERN-DAY
BABE RUTH.
HE THROWS HARDER AND HITS THE
BALL FURTHER.
SCOTT: EXIT VELOCITY PROVES
THAT.
WE DID NOT HAVE IT FOR BABE.
SHOHEI LEADING THE VOTE AND DH.
YOU CAN FILL OUT YOUR 2021
GOOGLE MLB ALL-STAR BALLOT NOW
AT MLB.COM/VOTE AND ON GOOGLE BY
SEARCHING FOR YOUR FAVORITE
PLAYER OR MLB VOTE.
SHOHEI OHTANI HAS A CHANCE AT
THE ALL-STAR GAME.
IF HE WANTS TO, TO BE IN THE
HOME RUN DERBY, TO BE IN THE DH,
AND MAYBE THROW AN INNING.
DAN: HE WELCOMED ALL OF THOSE
THINGS, THE MANAGER.
HE THOUGHT IT WOULD BE GREAT FOR
BASEBALL TO SEE A PITCHER HIT IN
THE GAME.
SCOTT: IF YOU HAD THAT CHANCE, I
KNOW YOU WOULD TAKE IT.
DAN: THE COOLEST THING WOULD BE
TO START ON THE MOUND, LET HIM
THROW THAT NASTY SPLIT, AND IN A
BE IN THE BOTTOM OF THE INNING.
SCOTT: YOU KNOW WHEN YOU ARE
COMING INTO THE GAME.
DAN: GIVE THE ANGELS ENOUGH TIME
TO SAY, WE WILL THROW HIM AN
INNING AND LET HIM HAVE AN AP.
SCOTT: MAYBE THE HOME RUN DERBY
TO.
MAYBE.
2021, GOOGLE MLB ALL-STAR BALLOT
RIGHT NOW.
YOU CAN FILL IT OUT.
SEARCH FOR YOUR FAVORITE PLAYER
ON GOOGLE.
OR GO TO MLB VOTE ON GOOGLE.
TIME FOR THE CREATOR SPOTLIGHT.
♪
DAN LOVES THAT MUSIC.
DAN: I DO.
IT IS LIKE SMOOTH JAZZ.
SCOTT: JUST LIKE AUSTIN KLESKO
ON YOUTUBE.
186,000 SUBSCRIBERS.
HE LOVES THE ANGELS.
HE IS BEEN PART OF DODGER FILMS.
HE IS OUR CREATOR SPOTLIGHT
RIGHT NOW.
GREAT TO TALK TO YOU IN PERSON.
I FEEL LIKE I'M CHATTING WITH
YOU IN THE LIVE CHAT, MENTIONING
YOU WHEN I'M DOING THE
PLAY-BY-PLAY FOR GANGS.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU HERE.
I APPRECIATE YOU ALWAYS CHARMING
AND QUESTIONS.
HOW ARE YOU TODAY?
>> I'M DOING GREAT.
FEELS GREAT TO BE HERE.
SCOTT: LET'S GET YOU TO CHIME IN
ON WHAT WE JUST TALKED ABOUT
WITH THE ALL-STAR BALLOT.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO SEE SHOHEI
OHTANI DO EVERYTHING THAT WE
JUST MENTIONED?
>> I WANT TO SEE HIM DO IT ALL.
I WANT TO SEE HIM IN THE
ALL-STAR GAME, THE HOME RUN
DERBY IN COLORADO.
THAT WOULD BE INSANE.
SCOTT: HAS HE LIVED UP TO
EXPECTATIONS TO WHAT YOU AND
MOST ANGEL FANS THOUGHT HE WAS
GOING TO BE WHEN HE CAME OVER
FROM JAPAN?
>> I WOULD SAY HE SUCCEEDED.
ESPECIALLY THIS SEASON.
[INAUDIBLE]
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE HIM RIDE
THIS TO THE END OF THE SEASON.
SCOTT: YOU ARE A BIG ANGELS FAN.
I WANT TO GET TO A BIG-TIME
VIDEO THAT YOU POSTED.
IT'S BEEN A MINUTE.
IT WAS HIGHLY TALKED ABOUT AND
VIEWED BACK IN THE DAY.
2016.
YOU GO TO WHEN ANGELS TRY OUT.
TAKE US THROUGH THAT EXPERIENCE
AND HOW YOU WERE ABLE TO
DOCUMENTED ON YOUTUBE.
>> THAT WAS FOR A GREAT CAUSE.
THE ANGELS DO IT EVERY YEAR
AROUND THANKSGIVING.
CAMP FOOD DRIVE.
YOU GO THERE AND TAKE SOME
SWINGS, THROW PITCHES.
YOU GET TO HAVE FUN AND FEEL
LIKE A BIG LEAGUER.
THAT'S THE COOLEST PART.
DAN: HAVE TO ASK YOU A QUESTION.
YOUR LIFELONG ANGELS FAN.
GIVE ME YOUR TOP ANGELS PLAYER
OF ALL TIME.
>> I'M GOING TO SAY VLADIMIR
GUERRERO.
I GREW UP WATCHING HIM.
THAT'S WHO WAS THE SUPERSTAR
WHEN I GOT INTO BASEBALL.
I WATCHED HIM FOR A MAJORITY OF
MY LIFE.
I WOULD SAY VLAD.
SCOTT: WHAT ABOUT A PERSONAL
FAVORITE MLB MOMENT?
AWAY YOU FELL IN LOVE WITH THE
GAME.
WHEN I SAY MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL, YOU THINK ABOUT IT
AUTOMATICALLY.
>> FOR ME, THAT WOULD BE THE
NO-HITTER WE THREW A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO.
IT WAS OUR FIRST HOME GAME AFTER
TYLER SKAGGS PASSED.
SO MANY PEOPLE HAD OTHER PLANS
THEY WERE INVITING ME TO.
I SAID, NO.
I'M NOT MISSING THIS GAME.
SO GLAD I DIDN'T.
SCOTT: THAT MOMENT, UNREAL IN
THE WAY THE GAME TURNED OUT.
I'M WITH YOU.
THAT'S ONE WE WILL NEVER FORGET.
WE ARE TALKING TO AUSTIN KLESKO,
OUR YOUTUBE CREATOR SPOTLIGHT.
LET THE WORLD KNOW WHAT YOUR
PAGE IS ALL ABOUT.
OVER 57 MILLION VIEWS SINCE YOU
JOINED AND STARTED UP YOUR OWN
CHANNEL IN 2014.
GIVE US THE LOWDOWN.
>> I WOULD SAY THE MAJORITY IS
ABOUT SPORTS.
IN THE END, IT'S ABOUT HAVING
FUN.
THAT'S WHAT I WANT TO PORTRAY IN
EVERY VIDEO.
THAT'S WHAT I WANT PEOPLE TO
COME THEREFORE.
HAPPINESS, THE THRILL OF THE
SPORT.
THAT'S WHAT IT'S ALL ABOUT.
SCOTT: IS THERE A SECRET TO HOW
YOU CREATE SO MUCH INTERACTION
AND ENTERTAINMENT FOR EVERYONE?
SAY THERE'S A KID WHO GOES, I
WANT TO BE LIKE AUSTIN.
I WANT PEOPLE TO SEE WHAT I'M
DOING AND I WANT TO MAKE PEOPLE
HAPPY.
WHAT IS THE KEY TO WHAT YOU DO?
>> CONSISTENCY.
AS LONG AS YOU ARE CONSISTENT
WITH IT, YOU HAVE TO THANK THE
FANS AS WELL.
THE ARE THE ONES WHO MAKE IT FOR
YOU.
I WOULD SAY CONSISTENCY AND
FANS.
SCOTT: WE LOVE THAT IN BASEBALL.
WE LOVE CONSISTENT PLAYERS.
YOU ARE A CONSISTENT CREATOR.
I APPRECIATE YOU.
EVERY SINGLE WEEK ON THE MLB
GAME OF THE WEEK.
IT'S GREAT TALKING TO YOU NOW IN
PERSON.
HAVE FUN WATCHING THIS ONE WITH
YOUR ANGELS.
GOOD LUCK TO YOUR SQUAD TONIGHT,
OK?
>> THANK YOU.
I WILL.
GO HALOS.
♪
SCOTT: YOU WILL SEE AUSTIN IN
THE LIVE CHAT, TALKING ABOUT
THIS GUY.
HIS CURRENT FAVORITE PLAYER,
SHOHEI OHTANI.
GET WARM.
WE NEED TO SEE YOU ON THE MOUND
AND AT THE PLATE TONIGHT.TIGERS.
WE ARE CLOSE TO FIRST PITCH.
♪
>> HE STRUCK HIM OUT.
SAVE THAT BASEBALL.
THAT'S HIS FIRST AT THE MAJOR
LEAGUE LEVEL.
GOOD FOR JASON FOLEY.
ONE AWAY.
>> HANIGER DRIVES ONE TO LEFT
FIELD.
BUT DO GIVES CHASE AND MAKES THE
GRAB.
>> GREAT CLOSING SPEED.
>> CABRERA LACES ONE DOWN THE
LEFT-FIELD LINE.
THAT'S INTO THE CORNER.
CABRERA WILL DIG FOR A SECOND.
HE'S GOT HIMSELF A ONE OUT
DOUBLE.
HIS 584TH OF HIS MAJOR LEAGUE
CAREER.
>> DEEP CENTER FIELD.
HE'LL GOING BACK.
THAT BALL IS CAUGHT.
HE TOOK IT OFF OF THE WALL.
DEREK HILL WITH A SPECTACULAR
PLAY AT CENTER FIELD.
WOW.
>> ONE STRIKE.
STEADY SWING.
DEEP RIGHT FIELD.
IT'S GONE.
HIS FIRST AS A MAJOR LEAGUER.
TIES IT AT 4-4.
YEAH BABY.
>> THAT'S WORTH STICKING AROUND
FOR, ISN'T IT?
>> I'M TELLING YOU.
YOU HAVE TO STAY.
THAT'S AWESOME.
>> 397 FEET.
♪
SCOTT: THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK
PREGAME SHOW IS PRESENTED BY
CHIME.
ALMOST TIME FOR THE GAME.
IT IS TIME FOR PICKS TO CLICK,
PRESENTED BY FANDUEL SPORTS
BOOK.
DAN PLESAC HANGING WITH US RIGHT
NOW.
THE FIRST ONE HAS TO DO WITH OUR
GOOD FRIEND -- I WISH HE WAS OUR
GOOD FRIEND.
SHOHEI OHTANI.
HE'S BUSY.
HE HAS SO MUCH TO DO.
HITTING, PITCHING.
IF HE HAS AN E.R.A. UNDER THREE
AND HE HAD 30 HOME RUNS THIS
YEAR, SHOULD HE WIN AL M.V.P.?
DAN: I'M GIVING TWO THUMBS UP
YES.
WHAT HE'S DOING, WE HAVE NEVER
SEEN IN THE HISTORY OF BASEBALL.
HE'S DOING BOTH AT A LEVEL THAT
I THINK WE ARE ALL IN ALL OF.
NOT ONLY HITTING BOMBS.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
HE'S A GRACE BASE RUNNER.
THERE ARE GUYS WHO THINK THE --
HE IS THE BEST ATHLETE.
THIS HAS BEEN AN INCREDIBLE
START TO THE 2021 SEASON.
I'M AMAZED AT NOT ONLY HAS HE
DONE BOTH, BUT HE HAS DONE BOTH
SO WELL.
SCOTT: WE ARE LOOKING AT M.V.P.
FAVORITES RIGHT NOW AND HE'S
NUMBER TWO.
DAN: HE MIGHT BE A SLAMDUNK.
THE BIGGIE WILL BE, DOES HE WEAR
IT DOWN BY DOING BOTH AFTER THE
ALL-STAR BREAK?
IF HE CONTINUES AT THIS PACE, HE
HAS A SHOT TO WIN.
SCOTT: HE IS SUCH A UNIQUE
CANDIDATE, THE WAY HE DOES BOTH
THINGS SO WELL.
LET'S MOVE TO THE NEXT ONE.
YOUR FAVORITE TO REPRESENT THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE IN THE WORLD
SERIES AT THIS VERY MOMENT.
DAN: RIGHT NOW, I WILL GO OFF
THE GRID.
I LIKE THE HOUSTON ASTROS.
ALEX BREGMAN WENT ON THE IL.
THEY WILL MISS HIM FOR A LITTLE
BIT OF TIME.
SOMETHING TELLS ME, I DON'T KNOW
WHY THE ASTROS MADE A DEEP RUN,
FORCED GAME SEVEN WITH THE RAYS
LAST YEAR.
THEY WERE ONE WIN AWAY FROM
GETTING TO THE WORLD SERIES.
I LIKE THE ASTROS.
THEY ARE MY SNEAKY PICK.
SCOTT: THAT'S A GOOD ONE.
SOME PEOPLE ARE GOING, OK.
I COULD DO SOME DAMAGE WITH
THAT.
LET'S SEE IF YOU STAY HOT.
IF JACOB DEGROM IS OUT FOR AN
EXTENDED TIME, OTHERWISE, WE
KNOW HE'S WINNING THE CY YOUNG.
IF HE'S OUT, AND HE HAS HAD SOME
INJURIES, WHO WOULD YOU PICK FOR
N.L. CY YOUNG?
DAN: DON'T LAUGH.
TAIJUAN WALKER.
SCOTT: WOW.
DAN: HE WAS SO GOOD THE OTHER
NIGHT AGAINST THE CUBS.
HE SPENT A LITTLE BIT OF TIME ON
THE INJURED LIST.
HE WOULD GIVE THEM THE BEST
1-2-3 COMBINATION IN THE SPORT
RIGHT NOW.
I MIGHT LEAN TOWARDS TAIJUAN
WALKER.
SCOTT: HE'S NOT EVEN ON THE
BOARD, AS YOU CAN SEE.
WOODRUFF AND BOURNS.
GOFFMAN HAS BEEN NASTY WITH HIS
SPLITTER.
DAN: THE GUY THAT DOESN'T HAVE
ENOUGH CREDIT IS ZACK WHEELER.
GUZMAN WAS REALLY GOOD, EIGHT
INNINGS OF TWO RUNS BASEBALL
THIS AFTERNOON.
HE PICKED UP HIS EIGHTH WIN.
I DON'T KNOW WHY.
I'VE SEEN TAIJUAN WALKER PITCH
LIKE THREE OR FOUR TIMES THIS
YEAR.
HE HAS FOUND RENEWED VIGOR.
HE'S PITCHING LIKE A DIFFERENT
GUY.
SCOTT: THROWING HARDER, NOT
GETTING A TON OF ATTENTION.
DAN: HE IS WEARING OUT
LEFT-HANDERS.
SCOTT: WHEELER LEADS MAJOR
LEAGUE BASEBALL IN INNINGS.
DAN: WE HAVE TO START VALUING
THAT.
SCOTT: THAT'S A BIG DEAL.
SAVING THE BULLPEN.
GIVING THE TEAM LENGTH.
HE'S FIRST IN THE NATIONAL
LEAGUE IN STRIKEOUTS.
ONE MORE TEST FOR YOU.
THE POLL QUESTION.
LET'S SEE HOW EVERYONE DID ON
YOUTUBE.
IT LOOKS LIKE ANGELS FANS ARE
WEIGHING AND BIG-TIME TONIGHT.
NICE AND SIMPLE.
YOU WILL SEE MORE QUESTIONS
DURING THE GAME.
YOU WILL HEAR FROM MIKE TROUT IN
THE DUGOUT DURING THE GAME.
LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT.
THE FANS HAVE SPOKEN.
THEY THINK THE ANGELS WIN THIS
ONE.
THAT MAKES SENSE.
IF WE ARE JUST LOOKING AT
PITCHING ALONE, YOU HAVE A GUY
MAKING HIS MLB BABY YOU -- DEBUT
GOING AGAINST OHTANI.
THE ANGELS TEAM IS SCORING WELL
LATELY.
THE TIGERS ARE GOING THROUGH A
BUILDING PROCESS.
THEY'VE BEEN 20-15 IN THE LAST
35.
PLAYING BETTER BASEBALL IN THE
LAST MONTH.
THE ANGELS SEEM TO BE THE
FAVORITE.
DAN: I'M FOLLOWING THE
UP-TO-THE-MINUTE DATA.
ANGELS SAYING, I'M ALL THINGS
HALOS TONIGHT.
SCOTT: WE ARE WITH YOU.
IT MAKES SENSE.
THERE IS SHOHEI.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS GOING
THROUGH HIS MIND ON A DAILY
BASIS?
THERE IS SO MUCH TO PREPARE FOR.
THINK ABOUT YOU WHEN YOU WERE
COMING OUT -- INTO THE GAME IS A
RELIEF PITCHER.
WHEN YOU SHUT UP THAT NIGHT,
EVERYTHING THAT YOU KEPT IN MIND
ON HOW TO KEEP YOURSELF FRESH
AND READY, AND THEN WHAT?
DAN: HE'S WARMING UP RIGHT NOW.
HE'S PROBABLY GOING THROUGH THE
TIGERS LINEUP.
WHAT HE WILL DO TO THE FIRST
THREE OR FOUR HITTERS THAT HE
SEES.
A LITTLE GAME PLANNING.
WHEN HE IS WALKING IN, HE IS
THINKING, I WANT TO SEE WHAT
THIS GUY HAS.
HE'S HITTING SECOND.
NOT ONLY DOES HE HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT WHAT HE WILL DO AT THE TOP
OF THE FIRST INNING, HE'S ALSO
WORRIED WHEN HE GETS TO THE
BOTTOM OF THE FIRST.
HE'S NOT LIKE THE OTHER GUYS.
THEY SIT DOWN AND PUT A TOWEL
ACROSS THEIR NECK.
HE HAS TO HAVE A BATTING HELMET.
HE WILL BE IN THE ON-DECK CIRCLE
WHEN THE GAME STARTS.
CRAZY.
SCOTT: THE TIGERS CHECKING IN AT
29-39 ON THE YEAR BUT THEY HAVE
WON THREE IN A ROW.
ANGEL STADIUM TONIGHT IS BACK TO
FULL CAPACITY FOR THE FIRST TIME
SINCE 2019.
WE'VE SEEN SOME BALLPARKS LATELY
THAT WENT TO FULL CAPACITY AND
THEY CALL IT OPENING DAY 2.0.
WHAT THE SCENE IS LIKE.
IT'S AWESOME.
IF YOU CAN'T BE THERE, IT IS FUN
TO WATCH.
DAN: CUBS AND CARDINALS AT
WRIGLEY FIELD.
THE ROOF WAS BLOWING OFF OF THAT
PLACE.
THIS IS SO WELL-TIMED BY THE
ANGELS PR DEPARTMENT.
SECOND OPENING NIGHT AND OHTANI
IS ON THE MOUND.
SCOTT: YOU CAN'T DRAW IT UP
BETTER THAN THAT, CAN YOU?
OHTANI AND ANGELS MATCHING UP
WITH THE TIGERS.
ONE MORE QUICK NOTE.
MIKE TROUT IS ACTUALLY GOING TO
CHAT WITH THE BROADCAST GROUP.
DAN: THIRD INNING.
SCOTT: MIKE TROUT, BEST PLAYER
IN THE GAME, WILL TRYING OUT --
CHIME IN.
DAN: WE USUALLY GET A MARQUEE
PLAYER.
MOST OF THE TIME, A PITCHER.
TOP GUEST FOR YOU.
SCOTT: TROUT IS ON THE I.L. JUST
WHY HE HAS TIME.
ENJOY THIS ONE THIS EVENING.
PREGE SHOW PRESENTED BY CHIME.
IT IS GAME TIME.
♪
>> THE HISTORY OF BASEBALL IS SO
EXTENSIVE THAT PLAYERS RARELY
ENTER UNCHARTED TERRAIN.
EACH GAME WHERE SHOHEI OHTANI
STEPS WHAT IN THE BATTER'S BOX,
WE ARE LEFT TO MARGINAL --
MARVEL AT THE UNPRECEDENTED
NATURE OF HIS SKILLS.
REACHING HEIGHTS AND
ACCOMPLISHMENT FEEDS THAT THE
BASEBALL WORLD HASN'T WITNESSED
THE CENTURY.
OHTANI IS FLOURISHING IN A
FASHION THAT WAS SEEMED
INCONCEIVABLE.
HE'S A HIGH DEATH, TWO-WAY
WONDER WHOSE VALUE IS IMPOSSIBLE
TO OVERSTATE.
AN ALL-STAR CALIBER STARTER, ONE
OF THE MOST FEARED SLUGGERS IN
THE LEAGUE, A SIX TOOL WHO
GENERATES EXCITEMENT BY BREAKING
THE MOLD.
EVERY EPISODE OF THE OHTANI SHOW
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO BE HISTORY
IN THE MAKING.
TONIGHT, MAN, MYTH, AND LEGEND
COLLIDE IN FRONT OF A GLOBAL
AUDIENCE, NEXT ON YOUTUBE.
♪
>> HERE'S THE PITCH.
>> DRIVES IT DEEP.
>> WHAT A PLAY.
♪
>> ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
ALL MY GOD!
♪
>> SUMMER WEATHER HAS ARRIVED
BEFORE SUMMER HAS ACTUALLY
GOTTEN HERE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
FROM THE BEACH TO ANAHEIM
STADIUM FOR THE SHOWTIME SHOW
TONIGHT.
WELCOME TO THE MLB GAME OF THE
WEEK COME ALIVE ON YOUTUBE,
PRESENTED BY CHIME.
FROM ANGEL STADIUM, THE LOS
ANGELES ANGELS PLAY HOST TO THE
DETROIT TIGERS.
♪
ONE TEAM TRYING TO SNAP OUT OF
IT THREE-GAME SLIDE.
ANOTHER TRYING TO KEEP A
THREE-GAME WINNING STREAK ALIVE
WITH 14 YOUR MAJOR LEAGUE
VETERAN AND MARKET WAS ON.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU WITH US ON
YOUTUBE TONIGHT.
THE ONLY PLACE YOU CAN WATCH THE
SHOHEI SHOW.
IN THIS CULTURE OF FIGURE,
FASTER, STRONGER, SHOHEI OHTANI
CHECKS EVERY BOX.
>> YEAH.
WHAT HE'S DOING SO FAR THIS
SEASON, I'M IN TOTAL SHOCK EVERY
SINGLE NIGHT.
THIS BE GOING DOWN THE LINE.
4.08 SECONDS GOING DOWN THE
FIRST-BASE.
THAT'S WITH VIRUS -- BYRON
BUXTON AT THE TOP.
HIS STRIDE IS SMOOTH AND EASY.
WHETHER HE IS BUNTING OR
STEALING OR GOING DOWN THERE.
HE IS FLYING DOWN THE LINE.
YOU TALK ABOUT BARREL
PERCENTAGE.
NO ONE BETTER, NOT EVEN FERNANDO
TATIS JUNIOR IS BETTER AS FAR AS
THE FADEAWAY.
470 FOOT HOME RUN ALREADY THE
SEASON.
THE BARREL AND DISTANCE FOR
SHOHEI OHTANI.
WHEN HE'S ON THE BUMP, ALREADY
WITH 28 PITCHES.
99 MILE PER HOUR PLUS.
HE'S IN HIS OWN WORLD AT THE TOP
OF THAT ONE.
HE CAN DOMINATE WITH HIS
FASTBALL.
HE POSSESSES ONE OF THE MOST
UNHITTABLE PITCHES, HIGHEST K
PERCENTAGE.
67.2% WITH HIS SPLITTER.
45 STRIKEOUTS WITH THE SPLITTER.
YOU CAN ALMOST BANK ON A
STRIKEOUT FOR SHOHEI OHTANI ON
THE MOUND.
MATT: BABE RUTH HAS BEEN THE
ONLY PLAYER IN MAJOR LEAGUE
HISTORY WITH A 100 PLUS R.B.I.
COUNT.
OVER 100 INNINGS OF WORK ON THE
MOUND.
THE R.B.I. DID NOT BECOME AN
OFFICIAL STAT UNTIL AFTER THAT
HISTORIC 1919 SEASON.
SHOHEI OHTANI IS ON PACE FOR THE
SAME KIND OF WORKLOAD WITH WAY
MORE HOMERS.
WITH THAT, WHO WILL FACE THIS
GUY ON THE MOUND FOR THE DETROIT
TIGERS?
A ROOKIE RIGHT-HANDER, A TOP
PROSPECT.
RAJAI: MATT MANNING IS A GUY
THAT IS COMING OFF HIS BEST
OUTING OF THE SEASON.
IT'S MIDSEASON NOW.
HE'S HAD EIGHT STRIKEOUTS.
HE HAS AN EXPLOSIVE FASTBALL.
HE WILL HAVE TO GET AHEAD OF THE
HITTERS SO WE CAN GET TO THE
CURVEBALL.
THAT'S GOING TO BE A PITCH THAT
IS GOING TO BE HIS PITCH TO GET
GUYS OUT WITH.
MATT: MATT MANNING MAKING HIS
MAJOR-LEAGUE DEBUT TONIGHT.
HAD A GREAT FINAL OUTING IN AAA.
NINTH OVERALL PICK IN 2016.
HE'S THE NUMBER 18 PROSPECT IN
ALL OF BASEBALL ACCORDING TO MLB
PIPELINE.COM.
HE HAS PITCHED IN CAN'T -- IN
FRONT OF BIG SHOWCASE AUDIENCES.
MATT MANNING HAS ARRIVED AS OF
TONIGHT.
GREAT INTRIGUE ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE SCORECARD IN TERMS OF THE
STARTING PITCHING.
THAT SPILLS OVER INTO THE
STANDS.
FOR THE FIRST TIME, FULL
CAPACITY AT ANGEL STADIUM.
ALEX CURRY IS ON THE FIELD.
SHE HAS MORE.
ALEX: TODAY IS AN EXCITING DAY
AT ANGEL STADIUM.
IT'S THE FIRST TIME SINCE 2019
THAT WE ARE AT FULL CAPACITY AND
WE ARE CALLING IT REOPENING DAY.
WHEN WE SPOKE TO THE ANGELS
MANAGER, HE SAID HE HOPES THIS
PLACE IS ROARING AND PACKED.
IT SHOULD BE.
ANY TIME AND ANGELS SUPERSTAR IS
ON THE MOUND, IT'S AN EVENT.
IT FEELS MORE LIKE A ROCK
CONCERT THAN A BASEBALL GAME.
THE MOMENT THE GATES OPENED, THE
ENERGY HAS BEEN ELECTRIC.
THAT ME GIVE YOU INSIGHT INTO
WHAT IT'S LIKE WITH SHOHEI
OHTANI.
THE MOMENT HE WALKS ON THE
FIELD, FANS ARE LINING THE FIELD
AND THEY ARE GOING OVER TO WATCH
HIS WARM UP.
THEY ARE LINING THE BULLPEN TO
GET A GLIMPSE, A SMILE OF SHOHEI
OHTANI.
IT DOESN'T STOP THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE GAME.
THEY ARE ON THEIR FEET, CHANTING
HIS NAME.
AS THEY SHOULD BE.
HE'S DOING THINGS WE HAVEN'T
SEEN IN OVER 100 YEARS.
IF YOU HAVE A CHANCE TO COME
WATCH SHOHEI OHTANI PIGEON
PERSON, DO IT.
IF YOU ARE AT HOME TONIGHT, SIT
BACK, GRAB A DRINK, AND ENJOY
THE ROCK SHOW.
♪
MATT: WE WOULD LOVE TO GRAB A
DRINK.
YOU CAN DRINK DURING A YOUTUBE
GAME, NO?
BASEBALL.
THIS WILL BE A BLAST TONIGHT.
TIGERS AND ANGELS.
40,000 FANS.
LINEUPS AND FIRST PITCH OUR
NEXT.
♪
>> RIPPED TO LEFT.
INTO THE CORNER.
GROSSMAN ABLE TO RESET.
CRUISING IN WITH A READ OFF
DOUBLE.
ROBBIE GROSSMAN.
>> PRETTY GOOD CHANGEUP.
THAT WILL DROP.
GROSSMAN DIGGING FOR SECOND.
HE'S IN THERE WITH A POP-UP
SLIDE.
>> 2-1.
DRIVES ONE TO DEEP LEFT FIELD.
THAT BALL IS HISTORY.
A TWO RUN BLAST BY ROBBIE
GROSSMAN.
THE TIGERS ARE KICKING UP THEIR
HEELS IN THEIR HALF OF THE 11.
>> ROBBIE CRUSHES THAT BALL.
>> GROSSMAN LIFTS WANT TO DEEP
LEFT FIELD.
FRALEY TRACKING IT.
THAT BALL IS GONE.
ANOTHER BOMB FOR ROBBIE
GROSSMAN.
THE TIGERS WITH TWO MORE.
>> ROBBIE GROSSMAN HAS BEEN IN A
GROOVE.
HE WAS FLAT A WEEK AGO.
A.J. GAVE HIM A DAY OFF IN
CHICAGO.
ANOTHER DAY OFF ON MONDAY.
HE HAD A COUPLE DAYS TO REST.
HE HAS COME BACK WITH A
VENGEANCE EVER SINCE.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
♪
MATT: WELCOME BACK.
PRESENTING THE TIGERS LINEUP FOR
THE SERIES OPENER, BROUGHT TO
YOU BY CHIME.
A LOT OF LEFT-HANDED PASSES AND
A LOT OF SWITCH HITTERS IN THE
LINEUP CARD.
CABRERA, CASTRO, AND HOSS.
AKIL BADDOO HAS BEEN A GREAT
STORY.
HE'S IN LEFT FIELD.
WILLI CASTRO AT SECOND BASE.
DAZ CAMERON, THE RICKY CENTER
FIELDER.
IT'S THE 26-YEAR-OLD TWO-WAY
WONDER SHOHEI OHTANI TO MAKE HIS
10TH STARTING ASSIGNMENT OF THE
YEAR.
MOST RECENTLY, FRIDAY IN THE
DESERT.
A FIVE INNING START AGAINST THE
DIAMONDBACKS IN WHICH HE STRUCK
OUT EIGHT.
DID NOT FACTOR INTO THE DECISION
OF A 6-5 ANGELS VICTORY.
OHTANI IS OUT THERE TO SNAP A
THREE-GAME LOSING STREAK AS WE
ARE UNDERWAY IN ANAHEIM.
MARK: FIRST PITCH AT 96 FOR
SHOHEI.
LAST TIME OUT THERE, IT WAS 95.
MAYBE THE VELOCITY WAS DOWN A
COUPLE STARTS AGO.
IT'S BACK UP THERE TO HIS NORMAL
95-99 RANGE.
RAJAI: HE'S READY TO HIT THIS
ONE.
MATT: FASTBALL MISSES.
TWO BALLS AND NO STRIKES TO
ROBBIE GROSSMAN.
GROSSMAN HAS HIT SAFELY IN THREE
IN A ROW.
HE HAS BEEN VERY HOT OF LATE.
MARK: A BIG PART OF THE TIGERS
THREE-GAME WINNING STREAK IS
THAT THEY GOT THROUGH
MANHANDLING THE KANSAS CITY
ROYALS.
MATT: WHO WATCHES THAT ONE INTO
THE RIGHT-FIELD CORNER.
WARD LOOKING UP.
IT'S JUST FOUL.
MARK: OVER HIS CAREER, GROSSMAN
HAS HIT THE ANGELS PITCHING VERY
WELL.
.290 BATTING AVERAGE.
NO MATTER WHAT UNIFORM HE HAS
ON, HE'S BEEN A PAIN FOR THE
HALOS PITCHERS.
RAJAI: IT DEFINITELY HELPS WHEN
YOU ARE 2-0 ON A PITCHER LIKE
THIS.
MATT:2-1 FROM OHTANI.
THE TIGERS COME HERE TO START
THIS FOUR-GAME SERIES HAVING NOT
WANT A SEASON SERIES AGAINST THE
ANGELS IN OVER A DECADE.
THE LAST TIME THEY CLAIMED THAT
WAS BACK IN 2010.
THEY ARE HOT RIGHT NOW, AS WE
MENTIONED, FINISHING OFF A THREE
GAME SWEEP OF KANSAS CITY
YESTERDAY.
THERE'S A FIRST PITCH WALK
ISSUED BY OHTANI.
HOW ABOUT SOME MORE INFORMATION
ON OHTANI?
THE CHIME BREAKDOWN OF TONIGHT'S
ANGEL STARTER.
MARK: HE'S HAD TO IMPROVE
FASTBALL COMMAND.
HE WILL THROW A CUT FASTBALL TO
GET IT BACK IN THE STRIKE ZONE,
DOMINATE WITH THE SPLITTER.
60% WITH PERCENTAGE.
LIMIT TO FREE PASSES.
26 WALKS OVER 36 AND A THIRD
INNINGS PITCHED FOR SHOHEI
OHTANI.
HE'S GOING BACK HERE WITH THAT
STRUGGLING THE FIRST INNING.
THE FIRST BATTER OF THE GAME
WITH A FREE PASS.
MATT: LEADOFF HITTER REPORT FOR
JONATHAN SCHOOP.
THE ANGELS HAVE SEEN THIS FROM
OHTANI TO BEGIN GAMES IN THE
PAST.
THE FACT THAT HIS COMMAND IS NOT
PERFECT AND THE FIRST INNING.
THE STRIKEOUT TOTALS COME FOR
HIM SOMETIMES, SECOND TIME
THROUGH THE ORDER WHEN HE STARTS
TO USE THE SPLIT FINGER FASTBALL
WHICH HAS BEEN UNHITTABLE THIS
YEAR.
MARK: HE TRIES TO GET BACK INTO
COUNTS AND THROW HIS SLIDER,
ESPECIALLY EARLY IN THE FIRST
INNING.
HIS FASTBALL IS RUNNING TOO MUCH
NOW.
MAYBE HE WILL START USING HIS
CUT FASTBALL.
HE'S TRYING TO SLOW DOWN HIS
DELIVERY.
SOMETIMES, IT WILL BE CAUGHT
BETWEEN THAT QUICK'S -- DELIVERY
AND BRINGING THAT LEG UP TO HAVE
BETTER BALANCE.
MATT: TWO BALLS AND NO STRIKES
TO JONATHAN SCHOOP.
OFF OF THE KNOB OF THE BAT.
FOULED.
2-1.
ODDS COURTESY OF FANDUEL.
THEY POSTED A STRIKEOUT TOTAL
FOR OHTANI TONIGHT OF 7.5.
TOTAL RUNNING ON THAT.
STRUCK OUT EIGHT HIS LAST TIME
AROUND ON FRIDAY AGAINST THE
DIAMONDBACKS.
TWO BALLS AND A STRIKE TO
JONATHAN SCHOOP.
IN ORDER TO PROCESS ALL THAT
STRIKEOUT INFORMATION, NO THIS.
THE TIGERS SWING AND MISS QUITE
A BIT.
RAJAI: PROBABLY NOT A GOOD IDEA
TO TRY TO STEAL BASES.
YOU MIGHT BE LOOKING AT A DOUBLE
PLAY HERE.
WITH OHTANI ON THE MOUND, IT
WILL BE VERY DIFFICULT TO TRY TO
STEAL BASES.
HE LOOKS VERY FAST.
VERY QUICK TO THE PLATE.
MATT: SCOPE LINES THAT ONE FOUL.
THE TIGERS LIKE TO RUN.
THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
A.J. HICKS TOLD US BEFORE THE
GAME THAT BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT A
BIG POWER HITTING TEAM, HE LIKES
TO SEND BASE RUNNERS AND PUSH AS
MANY BUTTONS AS HE CAN.
NOT NECESSARILY ALWAYS IN
STRAIGHT STEAL CONTEXTS BUT HE
TRIES TO MOVE PEOPLE.
HE WILL HIT-AND-RUN AND TRY TO
BE AGGRESSIVE TONIGHT.
RAJAI: I THINK THE RIGHT PITCH,
RIGHT COUNT MAKES A DIFFERENCE.
MATT: 2-2.
HAMMERED FOUL.
HE IS SPRAYING FOUL BALLS ALL
OVER THE BALLPARK.
MARK: EARLY ON, OHTANI HAVING A
TOUGH TIME WITH HIS SECONDARY
PITCHES.
THIS IS A TIME WHERE HE WILL TRY
TO SNEAK A FASTBALL ON THE
OUTSIDE PART OF THE PLATE AT THE
KNEES.
MATT: STILL TWO BALLS AND TWO
STRIKES TO JONATHAN SCHOOP.
FULL COUNT NOW.
RAJAI: HERE MIGHT BE A GOOD IDEA
TO MAYBE GET THE RUNNER GOING.
GET THAT BATTER MAKING CONTACT.
GET SOME ACTION GOING.
GET SOME INFIELDERS MOVING.
MAYBE OUT OF POSITION.
WHO KNOWS WHAT IT COULD LEAD TO?
MATT: GROSSMAN STAYS PUT.
IT'S A SWING AND A MISS.
PROBABLY A GOOD THING THEY DID
NOT STAND HIM THERE.
SCOPES STRIKES OUT.
TOO LONG PLATE APPEARANCES FOR
OHTANI.
ONE AWAY WITH THE RUNNER ON.
MARK: HE IS GOING WITH A
SPLITTER HERE.
IT DROPS OFF OF THE OUTSIDE
CORNER.
SWING AND MISS.
INTERESTING HOW HE HOLDS HIS
SPLITTERS COMPARED TO OTHER
PITCHERS.
HE'S RIGHT ON THE SEAMS WITH HIS
FINGERS AND ABLE TO DROP THAT
ONE DOWN AND OUT OF THE STRIKE
SOME.
MATT: YOUR POINT ON RUNNING
AGAINST OHTANI IS WELL TAKEN.
HE HAS ALLOWED ONLY THREE STOLEN
BASES IN HIS CAREER.
HE IS FASTER THE PLATE.
RAJAI: THOSE ARE THE ODDS YOU
DON'T WANT TO TAKE AS A BASE
STEALER.
YOU WILL SHUT IT DOWN.
YOU HAVE TO LOOK FOR OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES TO EITHER GET TO
THE NEXT BASE, NOW YOU ARE
LOOKING FOR THAT SPLITTER WHEN
HE GETS TO TWO STRIKES, TO RUN
AND ANTICIPATE THAT BALL IN THE
DIRT.
MATT: JEIMER CANDELARIO NOW.
HE HAS HIT SAFELY IN THREE IN A
ROW TO START THE GAME TONIGHT.
RAJAI: THERE'S OPPORTUNITIES
WHERE, WHEN THE CATCHER IS NOT
PAYING ATTENTION, HE'S GETTING
LAZY, WHERE YOU COULD ACTUALLY
DELAY IT STILL.
IF THE CATCHER IS NOT PAYING
ATTENTION.
THIS CATCHER IS GOING TO BAT.
HE SEEMS TO BE AWARE OF WHAT'S
GOING ON.
MATT: CANDELARIO RUNS IT FOUL.
♪
MARK: LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT OUR
STATCAST POWERED BY GOOGLE
CLOUD.
HIS SPLITTER HAS BEEN LOCATED,
LOOK AT HOW MANY SWINGS HAVE
BEEN BELOW THE STRIKE ZONE.
FOUR FOR 64.
A FEW OF THEM UPSTAIRS.
YOU TRACK IT UP THERE, IT STILL
HAS THAT ABILITY TO DROP IN.
A LOT OF THOSE SWING AND MISS IS
WELL BELOW THE STRIKE ZONE.
MATT: HE WILL THROW THAT SPLIT
TO BOTH SIDES OF THE PLATE.
HE DOES NOT DISCRIMINATE.
ONE BALL AND TWO STRIKES TO
CANDELARIO NOW.
RAJAI: YOU HAVE TO EXPECT THE
SPLITTER RIGHT HERE.
YOU HAVE TO LOOK FOR THE BALL UP
AGAINST OHTANI.
WITH ALL THOSE BALLS GOING DOWN,
YOU HAVE TO LOOK FOR THE BALL
UP.
MAKE SURE HE GETS IT UP.
MATT: LIKE THAT.
IT'S A BASE HIT INTO CENTER
FIELD.
CANDELARIO SUPPORT ON A TWO
STRIKE COUNT.
THE TIGERS HAVE SOMETHING
COOKING IN THE TOP OF THE FIRST.
MARK: THIS SPLITTER WITH
TUMBLING ACTION.
YOU USUALLY THINK OF IT GOING
STRAIGHT DOWN.
THAT ALMOST HAD A CIRCLE
CHANGEUP.
YOU HAVE TO LOOK FOR A PITCH
LIKE THAT, ELEVATED ENOUGH WHERE
YOU GET THE GOOD PART OF THE BAT
ON IT.
THAT'S WHAT KIND THE LORIA WAS
ABLE TO DO.
-- CANDELARIO WAS ABLE TO DO.
MATT: TWO RUNNERS ABOARD NOW FOR
THE FUTURE HALL OF FAMER MIGUEL
CABRERA.
ONE OF THE MOST DECORATED
HITTERS IN THE MODERN HISTORY OF
THE GAME.
TO TIME AL M.V.P..
FOUR-TIME BATTING CHAMP.
11 TIME ALL-STAR.
AT THE AGE OF 38, DIGGING IN FOR
THE FIRST TIME AGAIN SHOHEI
OHTANI.
FASTBALL FOR A STRIKE.
NUMBERS HAVE COME DOWN, OF
COURSE, IN HIS SENIOR STATEHOOD.
THERE IS NO DENYING THE FACT
THAT MIGUEL CABRERA IS ONE OF
THE MOST IMPACTFUL RIGHT-HANDED
BATTERS THAT THE GAME HAS SEEN
IN THE LAST 50 YEARS.
BOLLING TO STRIKE.
-- BALL AND A STRIKE.
RAJAI: WHAT A HIT THIS IS AND A
GREAT TEAMMATE.
MATT: IS HE THE ONLY GUY LEFT
FROM YOUR TWO YEARS AS A TIGER?
HE HAS TO BE.
RAJAI: HE'S THE ONE GUY THAT IS
LEFT.
WE WERE REALLY CLOSE LOCKER
MATES.
I REALLY GOT TO KNOW HIM IN THE
LOCKER ROOM.
HE'S A FUN GUY, FUN PERSONALITY.
HE ALWAYS COMES READY TO PLAY.
HE SEEMS LIKE HE WALKS UP, GETS
OUT OF BED, AND HE CAN HIT.
OBVIOUSLY WITH THE INJURIES, THE
ANKLE AND ALL THESE OTHER
INJURIES, THOSE AFFECT A PLAYER.
ESPECIALLY AS YOU GET OLDER.
MATT: I WOULD IMAGINE.
CABRERA HITTING JUST .216 THIS
YEAR.
THE WAY HE STARTED THE SEASON
WITH A HOMER AGAINST THE INDIANS
ON A SNOWING OPENING DAY
AFTERNOON, EVERYBODY THOUGHT,
THIS WILL BE OLD MIDDLE CABRERA.
THE RETURNS HAVE NOT BEEN QUITE
AS GOOD SINCE THAT OPENER.
THAT FASTBALL WENT RIGHT PAST
HIM.
CANNOT CATCH UP.
THREE FASTBALL STRIKEOUT, A GUY
THAT IS KNOWN AS ONE OF THE
BETTER FASTBALL HITTERS IN
BASEBALL.
MARK: IS THAT ONE OF THOSE CASES
WERE YOU ARE THINKING, SPLITTER
OR SLIDER?
YOU END UP GETTING A FASTBALL
DOWN THE HEART OF THE PLATE.
HE LOOKED LIKE HE WAS LOOKING
FOR SOMETHING OFFSPEED.
RAJAI: ABSOLUTELY.
PROBABLY THE BALL UP.
HIS BAT MIGHT HAVE SLOWED DOWN
OVER THE YEARS.
HE MIGHT WANT TO START LOOKING
FOR THAT HARD STUFF.
PITCHES THAT HE CAN GET TO.
A LOT OF TIMES, HITTERS WILL
LOOK IN FOR THE INSIDE FASTBALL
TO GET THEM READY FOR ANYTHING
ELSE.
IF THEY CAN GET READY AND GEAR
UP FOR THE HARD STUFF, IT MAKES
IT A LITTLE BIT EASIER TO HIT
THE OFFSPEED STUFF.
MATT: TWO OUT, TWO ON FOR HAROLD
CASTRO NOW.
AJAY HANKS TOLD US BEFORE THE
GAME THAT MIGUEL CABRERA IS
SWINGING A SLIGHTLY LIGHTER BAT.
TRYING TO MAKE THOSE ADJUSTMENTS
THAT YOU TALK ABOUT.
THERE GUY NOW, CAN'T GET AROUND
ON THE HEATER AT HIT -- LIKE HE
USED TO.
A BALL INTO STRIKE TO CASTRO.
HAROLD CASTRO SENDS A HIGH FLY
BALL OUT TO RIGHT FOR TAYLOR
WARD.
TO LEFT STRANDED FOR THE FIRST.
TADIUM, NO
SCORE.
♪
>> RENDON, BASE HIT LEFT FIELD
ON A FASTBALL.
HERE COMES OHTANI.
BENINTENDI TO THE PLATE.
NOT IN TIME.
1-0 HALOS.
>> ANOTHER R.B.I., NUMBER 600 OF
HIS CAREER FOR RENDON.
>> LEVEL SWING.
DRIVES -- DRIVES THE BALL
TOWARDS RIGHT.
IT IS DOWN OFF OF THE BASE OF
THE WALL.
ANTHONY RENDON WITH A COUPLE OF
BASES.
>> FLEXING THAT LEG.
RAN DOWN HITS IT HARD INTO
CENTER FIELD.
SHOHEI MAKES THE TURN.
COME ON DOWN.
THE ANGELS ADD ANOTHER.
>> RENDON.
SWING AND A DRIVE TO LEFT FIELD.
THAT ONE IS GONE.
RENDON'S FOURTH OF THE YEAR GETS
THE ANGELS ON THE BOARD IN THE
FOURTH INNING TODAY.
>> HE SAID, YOU WANT TO TRY
AGAIN?
THIS TIME YOU WILL PAY THE PRICE
FOR IT.
FOR RUNDOWN, THAT HAS BEEN A
LONG TIME COMING.
>> FIRST PITCH INTO THE RIGHT
CENTER FIELD GAP.
THAT WILL SCORE BOTH.
UPTON RIGHT BEHIND IT.
IT'S A ONE RUN BALLGAME.
THAT DID NOT TAKE LONG.
♪
MATT: WELCOME BACK.
HERE'S HOW JOE MADDON ALIGNS THE
HOME SIDE.
JUSTIN UPTON, SHOHEI OHTANI,
TAYLOR WARD.
GREAT NUMBERS FOR SHOHEI OHTANI
AS A HITTER ON NIGHTS WHEN HE'S
DOING DOUBLE DUTY.
NO ANTHONY RENDON, STILL NURSING
A TRICEP INJURY.
JOSE IGLESIAS GETTING A
SCHEDULED NIGHT OFF TONIGHT.
MIKE TROUT, WE HOPE TO HEAR FROM
HIM LATER ON.
STILL WORKING HIS WAY BACK TO
FULL HEALTH.
HERE'S THE OTHER PART OF THE BIG
STORY TONIGHT.
MATT MANNING MAKING HIS
MAJOR-LEAGUE DEBUT TONIGHT.
EXCITING STUFF.
RAJAI: YES.
OUT OF SACRAMENTO.
HE HAS HIS FAMILY, FRIENDS.
THEY ARE ALL FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THEY ARE GOING TO BE IN
ATTENDANCE.
THIS HAS TO BE SOME KIND OF
NERVES GOING THROUGH HIS BODY.
MATT: MATT MANNING'S FIRST PITCH
OF THE BIG LEAGUES MISSES SIDE
TO JUSTIN UPTON.
RAJAI: IT'S NOT LIKE YOU CAN
HIDE AS A STARTING PITCHER.
RIGHT?
YOU GET CALLED UP AS A POSITION
PLAYER, YOU HAVE AT-BATS, YOU
CAN HIDE, YOU CAN GET AWAY FROM
THE CROWD.
WHEN YOU ARE COMING IN AS A
STARTING PITCHER, YOU HAVE THE
BALL IN YOUR HAND.
THOSE NERVES ARE GOING.
YOUR PALMS ARE SWEATING.
WHATEVER YOU DO.
IT'S A SCARY MOMENT.
IT'S AN EXCITING MOMENT AT THE
SAME TIME.
MATT: ALL EYES ON YOU.
RAJAI: ALL EYES ON YOU.
MATT: TWO BALLS AND A STRIKE TO
JUSTIN UPTON.
MANNING RATED AS THE NUMBER 18
OVERALL PROSPECT IN MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL.
RANKED AS DETROIT'S NUMBER THREE
PROSPECT BEHIND SPENCER
TORKELSON AND RILEY GREENE, TWO
BASIC HOUSEHOLD NAMES IN THE
PROSPECTS STRATOSPHERE.
THREE BALLS AND A STRIKE TO
UPTON NOW.
MACKENZIE GORE ME, WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT SOME OF THE BLUE
CHIP PROSPECTS IN OUR SPORT.
UPTON CHOPS IT TO THIRD FOR
CANDELARIO.
MANNING COMES BACK AFTER FALLING
BEHIND 3-1 TO GET HIS FIRST OUT.
THE CHIME BREAKDOWN ON THE
ROOKIE RIGHT-HANDER.
MARK: MID 90'S FASTBALL.
USE THAT MOVEMENT.
CHASE IS ON HIS BREAKING STUFF,
ESPECIALLY HIS KNUCKLE CURVE
BALL.
YOU HAVE TO SLOW THINGS DOWN AND
BREATHE AND RELAX.
LET THE MUSCLES RELAX,
ESPECIALLY WITH HIS FASTBALL.
MATT: A.J. HINCH TELLING US THAT
HIS ROOKIE RIGHT-HANDER WILL NOT
BE AFRAID TONIGHT.
HERE IS SHOHEI OHTANI.
19 HOMERS.
GETTING TO THAT FIGURE WITH
HOMERS IN BACK-TO-BACK GAMES
TUESDAY AND WEDNESDAY IN
OAKLAND.
RAJAI: TO ADD TO THAT POINT OF
NOT BEING AFRAID, 3-1 TO JUSTIN
UPTON.
A POWER GUY.
GOES RIGHT AFTER THEM.
HE GOT THAT OUT.
THAT'S A BIG RELIEF AS A ROOKIE
COMING UP, JUST TO GET THAT
FIRST OUT.
MATT: TWO BALLS AND A STRIKE TO
OHTANI.
19 HOMERS, 47 RUNS BATTED IN.
ONE OF THE TOP SLUGGING
PERCENTAGE IS IN THE GAME.
A SLAM FOR THE ALL-STAR GAME.
ALL-STAR BALLOTING IS OPEN AND
WE WILL TALK ABOUT IT THROUGHOUT
OUR TELECAST ON YOUTUBE TONIGHT.
IT COULD NOT BE ANY EASIER TO
VOTE FOR YOUR FAVORITE PLAYERS
THIS YEAR.
MANNING BEHIND OHTANI AS HE WAS
UPTON.
THIS TIME, THE 3-1 PITCH MISSES
AND OHTANI IS ABOARD.
MARK: IT'S AMAZING HOW PATIENT
OHTANI HAS BEEN OVER HIS LAST 15
GAMES OR SO.
EARLY IN THE SEASON, HE WAS
HACKING.
A CHANGEUP FOR A YOUNG PITCHER
MAKING THEIR DEBUT IS THE
HARDEST PITCH.
EVERYTHING IS AMPED UP AND
TRYING TO RUSH AT HOME.
A CHANGEUP IS ONE OF THOSE
PITCHES, IT AFFECTED THE NEST
PITCH.
RAJAI: MANY WILL HAVE TO WORK ON
THAT COMMAND AS THESE GUYS WILL
MAKE HIM PAY IF HE KEEPS GETTING
BEHIND IN THE COUNT.
MATT: TAYLOR WARD IS UP THERE
SWINGING.
A FIRST PITCH FLY BALL OUT TO
RIGHT.
ROBBIE GROSSMAN HAS TIME UNDER
IT FOR OUT NUMBER TWO.
RAJAI: IT'S GOOD TO SEE THE
YOUNG --
MARK: OHTANI SAID HE WANTS TO
TRY TO STEAL A BASE ON A DAY
HE'S PITCHING.
JOE MADDON SAYS, HE DOESN'T WANT
HIM TO WASTE ENERGY.
SHOHEI, YOU NEVER KNOW WITH HIM.
ALWAYS EXPECT THE UNEXPECTED.
ALREADY WITH 10 STOLEN BASES
THIS YEAR.
MATT: IT HAS TO BE TEMPTING.
YOU HAVE A GUY MAKING HIS MAJOR
LEAGUE DEBUT ON THE MOUND.
A ROOKIE CATCHER BEHIND THE
PLATE.
OHTANI IS ONE OF THE FASTEST
GUYS IN THE MAJORS.
RAJAI: LOOKS LIKE SOME PRETTY
QUICK FEET BY THE PITCHER
MANNING RIGHT THERE.
THAT MIGHT KEEP HIM A LITTLE BIT
CLOSER TO THE BASE.
THAT'S ONE THING AS A BASE
STEALER THAT YOU LOOK FOR, THOSE
QUICK FEET, THOSE ATHLETIC
PITCHERS.
MATT: WALSH SHORTENS UP AND
WAVES THROUGH A BUNT.
0-1 TO JARED WALSH WHO HAS BIG
POWER NUMBERS THIS YEAR.
46 R.B.I.S.
THE ANGELS ARE THE ONLY TEAM IN
BASEBALL WITH MULTIPLE PLAYERS
THAT BOTH HAVE AT LEAST 15
HOMERS AND 46 DRIVEN IN.
WALSH AND OHTANI.
1-1.
MARK: AS MUCH AS YOU LOVE TO SEE
WALSH USING THAT BUNT, YOU HAVE
KURT SUZUKI ON DECK.
YOU WANT HIM SWINGING AWAY, TRY
TO GO EXTRA BASE.
ESPECIALLY ON OFF-SPEED PITCHES
THIS YEAR.
HE IS SLUGGING .841 AND REALLY
GOOD AT HOME ALSO.
MATT: NOT A BAD DEVICE FOR
MANNING, JUST TO GET HIM AGAIN,
A LITTLE USED INTO THE GAME
TONIGHT.
HE HAS
THE ANGELS ARE THE ONLY TEAM IN
BASEBALL TO HAVE 15 HOMERS AND
46 DRIVEN IN.
WALSH AND OHTAN
RAJAI: YOU HAVE KURT SUZUKI ON
DECK AND THE POWER THAT WALSH
HAS, YOU WANT HIM SWINGING AWAY
GOING EXTRA BASE ESPECIALLY ON
OFF-SPEED PITCHES THIS YEAR.
HE'S SLUGGING .841 AND REALLY
GOOD AT HOME ALSO.
MATT: NOT A BAD DEVICE FOR
MANNING TO GET HIM A LITTLE
EASED INTO THE GAME TONIGHT.
13 PITCHES.
HE'S A DEAD-RED FASTBALL HITTER.
LIKE THAT.
RIGHT ON THE BUTTON.
BUT RIGHT AT BADDOO TO RETIRE
THE SIDE.
NOTHING COMES OF THE ONE-OUT
WALK.
A ZERO POSTED BY MATT MANNING IN
HIS MAJOR LEAGUE DEBUT.
>> SMOKED A LINE DRIVE TO LEFT
FIELD HIS FIRST TIME UP OFF OF
ASDRUBAL.
NOW, SALVY HITS IT HIGH AND DEEP
TO LEFT FIELD.
GROSSMANN IS BACK.
GONE FOR A TWO-RUN HOME RUN!
>> LEAVE IT TO SALVADOR PEREZ TO
GET THAT BACK.
>> WILLY CASTRO STANDS IN WITH A
RUNNER ON FIRST.
A DRIVE TO RIGHT CENTER FIELD
THAT BALL IS DEEP THAT BALL IS
GONE!
WILLY CASTRO WITH A TWO-RUN SHOT
TO TIE IT UP AT 3-3.
OH.
AND IT GETS BY GALLAGHER AND
GROSSMANN IS GOING TO SCORE.
THE TIGERS TAKE THE LEAD.
ANOTHER 1-1.
THAT ONE IS A SHOT JUST PASSED A
DIVING ALBERTO.
TAYLOR CUTS IT OFF BUT NOT IN
TIME TO GET CANDELARIO WHO
SCAMPERS HOME.
MAZARA HAS AN R.B.I. SINGLE.
AND IT'S A 6-3 TIGERS LEAD.
AS MANY STRIKEOUTS AS HITS.
THERE HE GOES.
HERE'S THE 0-2.
SWUNG ON AND MISSED.
AND HE STRIKES OUT PEREZ ON
THREE PITCHES TO END IT.
AND THE TIGERS SWEEP THE ROYALS.
>> WELCOME BACK, TOP OF THE
SECOND WITH ANGELS' TWO-SAY SOUP
STAR SHOHEI OHTANI IN HIS LAST
START HE TOOK A FOUL BALL OFF OF
HUSBAND LEG AFTER GETTING
CHECKED OUT BY THE ANGELS'
MEDICAL STAFF.
HE SHOOK IT OFF AND WENT IN TO
HIT A DOUBLE.
BUT THE BIG QUESTION IS IF HE
WOULD RETURN TO THE MOUND
FOLLOWING THAT MINOR INJURY.
AND YOU BET HE DID SHOWING THAT
GRIT.
NOW, SHOHEI IS NOT ONLY
DOMINATING THE STAT SHEET ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE BALL.
BUT WHAT YOU DON'T SEE IN THE
BOX SCORE IS THAT COMPETITIVE
EDGE AND JUST HOW TOUGH HE IS.
AND THE BEST PART IS WE'RE
SEEING HIM SHOW EMOTION THIS
SEASON.
AND HE'S REALLY JUST HAVING A
GREAT TIME OUT THERE ON THE
FIELD.
MATT: IT'S A GREAT POINT, ALEX.
AND IT'S BEEN A RANGE OF
EMOTIONS FROM COMPETITIVE TO
DISAPPOINTED TO EVEN APOLOGETIC.
HAVE YOU EVER SEEN A GUY
APOLOGIZE TO AN OPPONENT FOR
ROBBING THEM OF A BASE HIT AS
THIS GUY DID WHEN HE TOOK ONE
AWAY FROM AUSTIN MEADOWS AT THIS
BALLPARK LAST WEEK?
HE APOLOGIZED TO HIM.
RAJAI: PERHAPS THAT'S PART OF
THE CULTURE.
MATT: YOU'RE PROBABLY RIGHT.
I JUST THINK HE'S A GREAT
SPORTSMAN.
HE COMPETES THE PROPER WAY AND
IS HAVING A GREAT TIME DOING IT.
BACK TO WORK.
STARTS ERIC HAWES FOR A BREAKING
BALL FOR A STRIKE.
>> HAASE GETTING AN OPPORTUNITY
TO PLAY NOW.
IT'S EXCITING.
I GOT TO PLAY WITH HIM WITH THE
INDIANS.
AND HE DIDN'T GET TO PLAY THAT
MUCH.
BUT YOU COULD SEE THE POWER.
MATT: CHOPPER.
GOING TO BE A TOUGH PLAY FOR
RENGIFO.
HEY, HAASE CAN RUN.
>> YOU GOING TO SAY IT AGAIN
ABOUT THE PATCHER BEING ABLE TO
RUN.
MATT: RUNS WELL FOR A CATCHER.
THERE YOU GO.
RAJAI: RENGIFO MADE A NICE CALL
ON THAT ONE.
MATT: YEAH, THE ANGELS MAKING A
ROSTER MOVE TODAY.
BRINGING RENGIFO UP FROM
TRIPLE-A SALT LAKE.
OPTIONING RIGHT-HANDED RELIEVER
AARON SLEGR'S BACK TO THE FORM.
THE ANGELS ARE HOPING TO HAVE
ANTHONY RENDON BACK TOMORROW.
THERE WAS A CHANCE THAT HE WOULD
HAVE BEEN OUT THERE TONIGHT.
FIRST BALL SWINGING IS BADDOO.
THAT WENT INTO RIGHT FIELD.
BADDOO SHOWING THAT FLAG.
HE'S ON HIS WAY TO SECOND AND ON
HIS WAY TO THIRD!
THROW THERE IS IN TIME!
RAJI: I LIKE THE AGGRESSIVENESS.
FROM OUR ANGLE HERE THAT IS
ABOUT AS TEXTBOOK AS YOU CAN DO
AS FAR AS GETTING TO THE
RELAYMAN.
YOU'VE GOT TO PRESS THE ISSUE.
WHEN YOU'RE FACING SOMEONE LIKE
SHOHEI OHTANI YOU HAVE TO TAKE
THE EXTRA-BASE HIT.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE AGGRESSIVE.
THAT'S A SLIDER OUT OVER THE
PLATE.
TAYLOR WARD, A FIRST ROUND PICK
AS A CATCHER
RENGIFO.
GREAT TAG.
RIGHT ON THE BACK, THE THROW
GETS HIM AT THIRD BASE!
YOU CAN'T PLAY THAT ANY BETTER
AS FAR AS HITTING YOUR RELAYMAN.
>> THAT'S THE RIGHT TIME TO
ACTUALLY GO EXTEND AND TRY TO
GET A TRIPLE ON THAT WITH
BADDOO.
I MEAN, WITH ONE OUT.
YOU WANT A MAN ON THIRD WITH
LESS THAN TWO OUTS.
MATT: TWO GONE, BASES EMPTY FOR
THE SWITCH HITTER WILLY CASTRO.
MAN THAT IS ABOUT A BEAUTIFUL A
PLAY AT A BASE AS YOU'RE GOING
SEE.
>> EXACTLY.
THAT WAS A GREAT, STRONG THROW
BY THE SECOND BASEMAN RILTE
RIGHT ON THE MONEY.
JUST GETTING CALLED UP AND MAKE
A PLAY LIKE THAT.
THAT'S GOING TO IMPRESS YOUR
MANAGER.
MATT: AND BADDOO CAN RUN.
LET'S MAKE NO MISTAKE.
HE'S VERY FAST.
ON THE GROUND TO THE INFIELD.
OHTANI COVERING.
COUPLE OF GOOD PLAYS.
ONE YOU CAN REALLY PUT A STAR
ON.
NOTHING IN THE TIGER'S HALF OF
THE SECOND.
♪
MATT: WELCOME BACK TO THE GAME
OF THE WEEK ON YOUTUBE PRESENTED
BY CHIME.
THE TIGERS HAVE WON THREE IN A
ROW.
AND YESTERDAY IT WAS ROOKIE
SOUTHPAW TEREK, SIX INNINGS INTO
THE AFTERNOON.
OUTSTANDING START.
SCATTERED SIX HITS AND STRUCK
OUT SEVENTH FOR HIS FOURTH
WINNER OF THE YEAR.
HE'S A BIG PART OF WHY THERE'S
SO MUCH OPTIMISM AGAINST YOUNG
TIGER'S STAFF.
HEY, LEFT-HANDER, HOW ARE YOU
DOING?
>> GOOD, HOW ARE YOU?
>> I'M USED TO ONLY HEARING THE
VOICE THROUGH "MLB THE VOICE."
MATT: THANKS FOR TAKING THE
TIME.
WE'VE GOT A REALLY FAST FIRST
PITCH OUT.
FIRST OF ALL, TELL US ABOUT YOU.
HERE WE ARE IN MID JUNE.
GIVE US THE STATUS UPDATE.
>> THE ONLY THING I'M FOCUSED ON
AND WORRIED IS TO BE HEALTHY.
AND I'M HEALTHY AND STRONG RIGHT
NOW.
I REALLY LIKE WHERE I'M AT.
I CAN WORK ON THINGS AND GET
BETTER AT THE GAME.
THAT'S ALL I CAN ASK FOR.
MATT: ONE GONE.
THAT WILL BRING IN WONG.
THIS YOUNG STAFF THAT THE TYING
VERSE PUT TOGETHER, TEREK WITH
THE NAMES THAT YOU GUYS HAVE PUT
TOGETHER AND PROSPECTSES ALL OF
YOU, ARE YOU -- ARE YOU GUYS
LIKE TIGHT AS A UNIT.
DOES EVERYBODY KIND OF EBB AND
FLOW THEIR OWN WAY.
GIVE US A SENSE FOR YOUR GROUP.
>> YEAH, I THINK WE'RE ALL
PRETTY CLOSE.
WHEN WE WERE TOGETHER IN
DOUBLE-A WE GOT PRETTY CLOSE BY
THE END OF THE YEAR, JUST
ROLLING IN AND COMPETING WITH
EACH OTHER.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS A TON OF FUN
AND NOW HAVING MATT TO MAKE HIS
DEBUT TONIGHT, IT'S A TON OF
FUN.
I THINK I'M MORE NERVOUS
WATCHING HIM PITCH.
IT'S A TON OF FUN TO HAVE THESE
GUYS AROUND HERE.
>> YEAH, TEREK, I WAS WONDERING
AS A PITCHER WATCHING THIS
TODAY, WERE YOU ABLE TO TALK TO
HIM BEFORE THE GAME OR EVEN LAST
NIGHT SAYING WILL BE, IT IS WHAT
YOU'VE -- SAYING LISTEN, THIS IS
WHAT YOU'VE GOT EXPECT YOUR
FIRST TIME OUT THERE?
>> I TOLD HIM TO ENJOY IT AND
HAVE FUN.
YOU ONLY DEBUT ONCE.
JUST ENJOY IT AND HAVE FUN.
>> KEYON WONG WITH A BASE HIT
BACK UP THE MIDDLE THAT HE TURNS
INTO TWO.
THAT LOOKED LIKE NOTHING MORE
THAN A SINGLE.
AND WONG ENDS UP AT SECOND BASE.
RAJAI: HE'S TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
AN OUTFIELDER THAT PUT HIS HEAD
DOWN AND WAS NOT CHARGING THE
BALL HARD THAT'S WHEN THE
OUTFIELDERS GET LAZY.
AND THEY CHARGE THE BALL.
THEY GET LAZY.
AND THEN THEY FIND OUT, OH, HE'S
THERE.
THAT'S THE KIND OF BASE RUNNING
THAT IS AGGRESSIVE.
THAT FORCES ERRORS.
THAT MAKES -- FORCES THE DEFENSE
TO MAKE PLAYS.
MATT: SO WONG AT SECOND BASE
WITH ONE GONE FOR JUAN LAGARES
WHO FIRST HOMER AS AN ANGEL
TCHAME WEEK.
YOU'RE A NORTHERN CALIFORNIA GUY
A'S OR GIANTS GROWING UP.
>> A'S.
ERIC CHAVEZ, BARRY ZITO.
MATT: NOW, WE'RE TALKING, THE
LEFT-HANDER'S FRATERNITY WITH
ZITO.
HAVE YOU EVER MET THE FORMER CY
YOUNG AWARD WINNER?
>> I HAVE NOT.
BUT I WOULD LOVE TO.
I WOULD LOVE TO MEET HIM AND
TALK ABOUT ANYTHING.
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE ABLE
BASEBALL.
ATTA BOY.
MATT: YOU TALK ABOUT PLAYING A
GUITAR.
HE'S GOT A MUSICAL BACKGROUND.
HE'S KIND OF A RENAISSANCE MAN.
>> OOH, MAN, THAT WOULD BE A TON
OF FUN.
SMOITH THERE ANYBODY --
MATT: WHO YOU DO MODEL YOUR GAME
AFTER?
IS THERE ANYBODY OUT THERE?
>> IN COLLEGE, I WATCHED PAXSON.
AND WATCHING HIM HOW HE WOULD
ATTACK GUYS.
I TRIED TO MODEL AFTER HIM A
LITTLE BIT.
BE AT THE SAME POINT JUST TRY TO
BE YOURSELF A LITTLE BIT.
AND WHATEVER FEELS LIKE YOURSELF
BE YOURSELF.
I LIKE WATCHING ALL GUYS.
DOESN'T MATTER IF YOU'RE
LEFT-HANDED OR RIGHT-HANDED.
IT'S A TON OF FUN TO WATCH.
MATT: HERE'S LUIS RENGIFO WITH A
RUNNER AT SECOND.
RENGIFO HAS SHINED TOP DEFENSIVE
SIDE OF THE SCORECARD TONIGHT
WITH A GREAT RELAY TO NAIL
BADDOO TRYING TO STRETCH AN
EXTRA BASE.
JUST 1-14 AT THE BIG LEAGUE
LEVEL BUT GOOD TRIPLE-A NUMBERS.
30 GAYS A .331 BATTING AVERAGE
AND FIVE DINGERS -- 30 GAMES AND
A .331 BATTING AVERAGE AND FIVE
DINGERS.
RAJAI: WHEN YOU SIT THERE IN THE
DUGOUT, DO YOU EVER FIND
YOURSELF BEING A FAN OF WHAT
YOU'RE SEEING FROM SHOHEI OHTANI
BUT ON THE MOUND BUT SWINGING
THE BAT TOO?
>> I WAS TALKING TO SOME GUYS.
HE'S A GREAT ARM.
BUT I THINK I WAS MORE EXCITED
TO WATCH HIM HIT FOR SOME
REASON.
JUST WHAT HE'S DOING FOR THE
GAME IS INCREDIBLE.
WATCHING HIM COVER FIRST BASE,
HE'S BIG HUMAN BEING.
A VERY ATHLETIC HUMAN BEING TOO.
IT'S INCREDIBLE TO WATCH HIM DO
WHAT HE DOES ON A DAILY BASIS.
MATT: IS THERE ANYBODY THAT YOU
FACED THIS YEAR, TARIK, THAT YOU
SAY WOW, I'M FACING THIS DUDE.
I GREW UP WATCHING HIM?
>> YEAH, I THINK LAST YEAR
NELSON CRUZ AND PAUL GOLDSCHMIDT
WERE PROBABLY ONE OF THE TWO
GUYS THAT I WAS LIKE, WOW, THESE
ARE THE GUYS THAT I FEEL LIKE
I'VE LOOKED UP TO FOREVER.
AND GOLDSCHMIDT BEING FROM
ARIZONA WHEN HE WAS IN ARIZONA,
I IDOLIZED HIM.
I THINK THOSE TWO GUYS, WOW,
STEP OFF A LITTLE BIT, TAKE
ANOTHER DEEPLE BREATH AND TRY TO
FOCUS BACK OUT.
RAJAI: TARIK, I'VE BEEN
IMPRESSED WATCHING THAT
EXPLOSIVE FASTBALL THAT YOU'VE
BEEN THROWING TO SOME OF THESE
RIGHT-HANDED PITCHERS --
HITTERS.
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT YOU PRIDE
YOURSELF ON IS BEING ABLE TO
DEMAND FASTBALL?
YOU ESTABLISH THAT INSIDE --
WHAT -- WHAT IS THAT FOR YOU
THAT YOU HAVE A FASTBALL?
>> I THINK IT'S EVERYTHING.
GETTING GUYS UNCOMFORTABLE UP
AND IN.
STANDING GUYS UP.
BREAKS POSTURE BECAUSE IT OPENS
UP THE REST OF THE PLATE.
YOU KNOW, THE LAST THING YOU
WANT IS HITTERS TO BE ABLE TO --
WANT IS HITTERS TO BE
COMFORTABLE.
MATT: BASE HIT THROUGH THE HOLE.
WONG COMING AROUND TO SCORE.
THROW GETS AWAY FROM HAASE AT
THE PLATE.
IT'S AN EXTRA 90 FEET FOR
RENGIFO AND THE ANGELS ARE THE
FIRST TO SCORE TONIGHT.
RAJAI: I DON'T THINK HE WANTED
TO THROW THAT FASTBALL THERE
WITH A LATERAL MOVEMENT.
HE STEAED THERE TO PUNCH OUT THE
LEFT FIELD.
OTHERWISE THAT NASTY FASTBALL HE
HAS WOULD GET HIM OFF THE END OF
THE BAT WHERE HE'S ABLE TO GET
THE BARREL OUT AND GET A BASE
HIT.
THAT ES A BALL WHERE THE
OUTFIELDER COMING IN ON THAT
BALL HAS TO GET THAT BALL DOWN.
HE HAS TO HIT THE CUT-OFF MAN.
THAT BALL HAS TO BE DOWN.
NOW, YOU'RE GIVING GUYS EXTRA
BASES.
THIS IS WHAT LOSES BALLGAMES.
THIS IS WHAT COSTS GUYS TEAMS
LOSSES.
MATT: DAVID FLETCHER HITS THE
HOLE ON THE RIGHT SIDE THAT
SCORES RENGIFO.
2-0 ANDREWS.
AND IT FEELS LIKE THE ANGELS'
LINEUP IS SITTING ON A HEATER
HERE BECAUSE MANNING HAS THROWN
28 PITCHES NOW.
23 OF THEM FASTBALLS, AND
FLETCHER WENT UP THERE LOOKING
FOR IT.
>> THOSE EYES WIDE OPEN WITH
RUNNERS IN SCORING POSITION.
HE'S PROBABLY THE BEST HITTER.
YOU THINK OF ALL THE POWER GUYS.
UPTON.
YOU'VE GOT OHTANI.
RENDON.
DAVID FLETCHER WITH RUNNERS IN
SCORING POSITION.
MATT: CHRIS FEDERER IS OUT TO
CHAT WITH MATT MANNING HERE.
HAS FIRST BIT OF ADVERSITY IN
HIS FIRST MAJOR LEAGUE DEBUT.
RAJAI: YOU SEE THIS AGGRESSIVE
PLAY THAT HAS LED TO THESE
COUPLE OF RUNS SCORING WITH THE
JUST THE HUSTLE DOUBLE.
AND THEN YOU HAVE THE -- THE
OVERTHROW WHERE HE GOES ALL THE
WAY AROUND TO SECOND.
OVERTHROW.
AND NOW NORTHEAST THE POSITION
TO GO TO THIRD.
AND THAT JUST LEADS TO BIGGER
INNINGS.
NOW, YOU HAVE THE BIGGER BOYS
COMING UP TO BAT.
AND THAT'S JUST DANGEROUS.
MATT: DANGEROUS, INDEED, IS
JUSTIN UPTON.
HERE WITH GO WITH FLETCHER AT
FIRST BASE.
TARIK, THANKS FOR JOINING US.
GOOD LUCK ON TUESDAY AGAINST THE
CARDINALSFULS THANK FOR VITSING
-- CARDINALS.
THANKS FOR VISITING US.
>> THANKS, MAN.
MATT: UNFORTUNATELY, IT COMES IN
AN INING WHERE THE ANGELS ARE
TREATING HIS BUDDY PRETTY POORLY
HERE.
AND JUSTIN UPTON IS BEHIND 0-1.
YOU KNOW, THE NUMBERS FOR
MANNING WERE NOT TER RESCUE --
WERE NOT TERRIFIC IN TRIPLE-A.
AND A.J. SAID WE'RE NOT JUST
LOOKING AT NUMBERS.
THIS IS A LIVE ARM, A TOP
PROSPECT.
HE'S HERE BECAUSE OF TWO THINGS.
NEED AND THE FACT THAT HE'S EAR
OPPORTUNITY.
THAT LAST START YOU TALKED ABOUT
IT EARLIER, RAJAI WAS HIS BEST
AT TRIPLE-A AND THEY FELT LIKE
THE TIME WAS RIGHT.
>> YES, THAT'S THE KIND OF START
YOU WANT THE BE ABLE TO BUILD
OFF.
HE CAN REMEMBER THE -- THE GOOD
THINGS HE DID IN THAT -- IN THAT
START.
YOU'RE HOPING THAT HE WOULD TAKE
THAT INTO HIS NEXT START
MATT: 1-1.
BREAKING BALL.
UPTON FOULS IT AWAY.
I'M GOING GUESS HERE, GUBIE,
THAT THE CONVERSATION MAY HAVE
TCHOOD WITH USING THE SECONDARY
PITCHES, NOW SECOND TIME THROUGH
THE ORDER.
>> OH, YES, AND THAT'S THE PITCH
AS THAT I MENTIONED THE
SECONDARY PITCHES WHEN COW HAVE
THAT ADRENALINE TO HAVE THAT
FEEL.
YOU WANT TO GET THAT FASTBALL BY
ANYBODY.
BUT THE SECONDARY PRITCHES THE
ONES THAT WILL SET UP THE
FASTBALL.
IT'S A GOOD IDEA TO USE IT.
MATT: HE SLIPPED A HEATER RIGHT
UP UPTON WHO WAS NOT LOOKING
FASTBALL.
TWO IN THE ANGELS' SECOND
HOWEVER TO THE THIRD INNING IN
ANAHEIM .
THE-0 FOR THE HOME SIPED.
-- SIDE.
MATT: IMPRESSIVE STARTS AROUND
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL IN
ADDITION TO SHOHEI OHTANI'S
OPENING.
VLADIMIR GUERRERO JR. LEADING
THE LEAGUE IN HOMERS.
FERNANDO TATIS JR. AND HOW ABOUT
JACOB DEGROM.
MIKE CAMERON, MAJOR LEAGUE
VETERAN.
GOLD GLOVER.
AND A GUY I CAN -- I'M CONVINCED
YOU HAD TO WATCH EVERY DAY TO
REALLY APPRECIATE HOW GOOD MIKE
CAMERON WAS.
MAN, HE WAS A GREAT PLAYER.
>> OH, YEAH, FOUR HOME RUN GAME.
RAJAI: THAT'S WHAT I THINK ABOUT
WHEN I THINK ABOUT OLD DAD RIGHT
THERE.
MATT: ONE GONE NOW FOR THE TOP
OF THE ORDER.
ROBBIE GROSSMAN WHO TAKES A
STRIKE.
ROBBIE GROSSMAN'S BEEN HOT.
HE'S RECORDED A MULTIPLE HIT
GAME IN 5-9 STARTS.
AFTER A ROCKY START TO THE YEAR.
CAME ABOARD ON A TWO-YEAR DEAL
AFTER SOME GOOD SEASONS IN
OAKLAND.
AND HE WAS A GUY THAT REALLY
CONNECTED THE OAKLAND LINEUP.
NOT THE MOST TALKED ABOUT PLAYER
THERE.
BUT A GUY WHO WAS REALLY
IMPORTANT, AND A GUY WHO WAS IN
OAKLAND A AND HAD GOOD NIGHTS
AGAINST THE ANGELS.
>> HE WAS THE ONE GUY YOU WANTED
KNOCKED UP AT THE PLATE AGAINST
THE ANGELS.
PATIENT ON-BASE PERCENTAGE, .360
THIS YEAR.
RAJAI: HE'S GOING TO MAKE YOU
THROW SOME STRIKES.
>> ALWAYS WORKING COUNTS.
YEP.
MATT: HE'S ONE OF A NUMBER OF
PLAYERS THIS YEAR WHO DOESN'T
REALLY STRIKE YOU AS YOUR
TYPICAL LEADOFF GUY.
BUT HE GETS ON BASE.
HE'S COMFORTABLE AT THE TOP OF
THE LINEUP.
SO LEADOFF HITTERS DON'T LOOK
LIKE THEY USED TO.
THEY'RE NOT ALL LITTLE GUYS THAT
RUN.
RAJAI: EXACTLY.
THERE ARE SOME GUYS THAT CAN GET
ON BASE THE BIG BOPPERS.
MATT: HE'S REALLY FAVORING THE
RIGHT SIDE OF THE INFIELD.
AND IT'S 3-2 TO ROBBIE GROSSMAN.
RAJAI: I BET HE WANTS THAT PITCH
BACK.
3-1.
YOU KNOW WHAT'S COMING.
HE'S GOING TO CHALLENGE WITH A
FASTBALL.
AND HE'S LATE.
>> 97 LOWER THIRD.
I IMAGINE HE COMES WITH A SPLIT
DOWN IN THAT LOWER THIRD.
RAJAI: THIS IS WHEREAS A HITTER
YOUR THINKING YOU WANT TO BE
AGGRESSIVE OR NOT AGGRESSIVE?
IS HE GOING TO GO FOR THE
STRIKEOUT OR IS HE NOT?
MATT: 3-2 PITCH.
GOT HIM!
THAT LOOKED LIKE GROSSMANN GOT
CAUGHT IN BETWEEN THERE.
RAJAI: HE WASN'T SURE IF HE WAS
GOING TO THROW IN THE DIRT.
YOU LOOK FOR THE BALL UP.
AND IF IT'S UP, BANG, YOU GO
FIR.
>> HE LOOKED LIKE HE WAS GOING
BACK DOOR SLIDER.
HE WAS ANTICIPATING A SPLIT.
AND STAYED IN THAT KIND OF THAT
UPPER PLANE AND THAT LATE BREAK
ON THE BACK SIDE OF THE PLATE.
GETS A SWING AND MISS AT 83.
82.
RAJAI: THAT'S UNFAIR.
97 IN AND I'M GOING GO CHANGEUP
AWAY.
MATT: SO HERE'S JONATHAN SCHOOP,
A STRIKEOUT VICTIM IN HIS FIRST
TRY.
THE THING WITH OHTANI IN A
TWO-STRIKE COUNT, RAJAI, YOU
START TO GUESS A LITTLE BIT, YOU
MIGHT THINK YOU CAN ELIMINATE
SOMETHING YOU REALLY CAN'T IN
TWO-STRIKE COUNTS, OPPONENTS
WERE 7-96 AGAINST HIM.
RAJAI: YEAH, THAT'S --
MATT: HERE'S A TWO-STRIKE COUNT
TO SCOPE -- SCHOOP.
>> YOU'RE SEEING A LOT OF
OFF-SPEED PITCHES.
FIRST PITCH AGAINST OHTANI.
DO YOU POSSIBLY SIT OFF-SPEED
FIRST PITCH AGAINST HIM?
RAJAI: I THINK WITH HIM YOU
ALWAYS HAVE TO LOOK FOR THAT
HEATER BECAUSE YOU KNOW IT'S
GOING COME EVENTUALLY.
AND YOU HAVE TO -- YOU HAVE TO
-- I MEAN, BECAUSE THAT'S --
THAT'S REALLY HIS -- HIS BEST
PITCH IS HIS FASTBALL.
AND OFF THAT FASTBALL HE'S ABLE
TO PITCH EFFECTIVELY WITH
OFF-SPEED.
MATT: A BALL AND TWO STRIKES TO
JONATHAN SCHOOP TRYING TO PICK
UP A HIT HERE.
3-2.
RAJAI: BUT SOME GUYS HAVING SAID
THAT, THEY MIGHT SEE -- BE
WATCHING THE GAME AND SEE THAT
AND SAY, OH, I'M GOING TO TAKE
THIS ONE SHOT.
AND I'M GOING TO -- I'M GOING TO
SIT ON AN OFF-SPEED THIS ONE
PITCH.
OR THAT'S WHAT SOME HITTERS DO.
MATT: GOT HIM TO CHASE.
THREW HIM A SLIDER THERE IN A
TWO-STRIKE COUNT.
FOUR PUNCHOUT FIRST SHOHEI
OHTANI THROUGH THREE.
MATT: TO THE BOTTOM OF THE
THIRD.
AND IT'S 2-0 FOR THE SHOHEI
SHOW.
>> STILL GOING!
SLIDES UPTON WITH THE CATCH!
ATTA BOY, J-UP!
WONG!
HELLO!
PULLING IT BACK INTO THE YARD!
>> WONG, WHAT A PLAY!
>> THAT'S OVER THAT YELLOW LINE.
>> RENDON, BASE HIT LEFT FIELD
ON A FASTBALL.
HERE COMES OHTANI.
BENINTENDI UNCORKS IT TO THE
PLATE.
NOT IN TIME.
1-0, HALOS.
>> NUMBER.600 OF HIS CAREER FOR
ANTHONY RENDON.
MATT: IGLESIAS SQUARES ONE UP.
THAT'S IT TO CENTER FIELD.
MARTE CAN'T MAKE THE PLAY.
HERE'S STASSI BEING WAVED
AROUND.
AND THE ANGELS TAKE THAT ONE-RUN
LEAD!
>> THEY'VE GOT THAT FIGHT.
>> THERE'S THE DAMAGE RIGHT
THERE.
SHOHEI WAY, WAY, SAYONARA!
WHERE DID THAT LAND?
JUST LIKE THAT.
>> COUPLE OF ROWS AT THE TOP.
2-0, ANGELS.
SHOHEI, GOODNESS.
MATT: WELCOME BACK, A 2-O LEAD
FOR THE ANGELS.
AND IT'S REALLY OUR PLEASURE TO
HAVE MIKE TROUT ON WITH US TO
TAKE SOME TIME.
HEY, MIKE, HOW WE FEELING?
HOW YOU DOING TODAY, MAN?
>> FEELING GOOD.
FEELING GOOD.
ABOUT TO WATCH THIS OHTANI HOMER
RIGHT HERE.
MATT: LET ME ASK YOU THIS ABOUT
OHTANI, MAN, BECAUSE WE MARVEL
AT THIS GUY AS I KNOW YOU DO.
WHAT WAS THE FIRST MOMENT WHEN
YOU REALIZED HOW FAST HE WAS?
MIKE: HOW FAST HE WAS?
ANY BALL IN THE GAP, YOU KNOW,
HE'S GETTING A TRIPLE.
ANYTHING DOWN THE LINE.
I THINK THE MOST IMPRESSIVE
THINK IS THE BALL IS AT -- UP
THE MID THAT HE'S BEATH OUT
REGULARLY, ROUTINE GROUND BALLS.
IT'S FUN TO WATCH.
I GOT ASKED TODAY IF I COULD WIN
IN A RACE AGAINST HIM.
I DON'T THINK SO.
I THINK HE'S GONE.
RAJAI: MIKE TROUT, THIS IS RAJAI
DAVIS.
IT'S BEEN A PLEASURE WATCHING
YOU, THOUGH.
MIKE: WHAT'S UP, MAN?
RAJAI: ONE THING I HAVE FOR YOU,
MAN, IT'S -- IT'S, YOU, NO -- I
JUST LOST MY TRAIN OF THOUGHT.
MATT: IT HAPPENS EVERY ONCE IN A
WHILE.
HEY, BY THE WAY, RAJ IS MAKING
HIS DEBUT TODAY.
MIKE: OH, YEAH.
ARE -- RAJAI: EXCEPT FOR THAT
ONE.
NO, IT'S ALL GOOD.
>> HEY, WHAT EXCITES YOU MORE
WATCHING TROUTY OR SHOHEI AT THE
PLATE?
MIKE: I ENJOY WATCHING HIM HIT,
MAN.
IT'S PRETTY IMPRESSIVE.
>> I KNOW WHAT IT IS NOW.
I'M BACK
I'M BACK.
HEY MAN, TALKING ABOUT OHTANI,
HOW IS HE IN THE CLUBHOUSE?
DOES HE SPEAK ENGLISH?
DO YOU GUYS COMMUNICATE LIKE
THAT ON THAT LEVEL?
MIKE: YEAH, HE'S STARTING TO GET
BETTER.
IT'S KIND OF LIKE, YOU HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH HIM AND
HE'LL'KNOW WHAT YOURE SAYING --
AND HE'LL -- AND HE'LL KNOW WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING.
I THINK HE KNOWS MORE ENGLISH
THAN PEOPLE THINK.
HE'S A GREAT DUDE IN THE
CLUBHOUSE, DOES HIS WORK.
YOU DON'T REALLY HEAR MUCH FROM
HIM, JUST SITS IN THE CORNER.
LIKE I SAID, HE'S A GREAT
TEAMMATE.
>> I REMEMBER WHEN JARED WALSH
WAS COMING UP, HE WAS GOING TO
HIT A HOME RUN.
I'M GOING TO PUT YOU IN A SPOT
HERE.
ARE YOU STILL CALLING A BIG FLY
FROM JARED WALSH AGAIN ON THE
FASTBALL?
MIKE: I WAS 0-1 WITH OHTANI
RIGHT THERE.
THE WAY WALSHY HAS BEEN THIS
YEAR, HE'S BEEN UNBELIEVABLE,
TOO.
I WATCH HIM GET BETTER EVERY
DAY.
THIS GUY GOT A HIT THE OTHER DAY
WITH MY BAT AND HE WON'T STOP
TALKING ABOUT IT.
WALSHY, MAN, WALSHY'S BEEN GREAT
FOR THIS TEAM.
MATT: WHAT'S IT BEEN LIKE HAVING
FANS BACK IN THE BALLPARK?
IS IT LIKE IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE
OR WAS IT WEIRD AT FIRST?
MIKE: NAH, IT'S HOW IT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE.
OBVIOUSLY, NO FANS WAS TOUGH.
WE FEED OFF THAT, ESPECIALLY
LATER IN THE SUMMER, YOU'RE
FEEDING OFF THE ENERGY IN THE
CROWD.
IT'S PRETTY ELECTRIC TONIGHT.
>> HOW ARE YOU DOING AS FAR AS
RECOVERING FROM YOUR CALF
INJURY, THE UPDATE AS FAR AS
WHEN WE'RE GOING TO SEE YOU BACK
ON THE FIELD?
MIKE: IT'S GOING GOOD.
I FEEL GREAT.
I'VE GOT TO BE SMART.
I TALKED TO SOME DOCTORS.
THEY'RE TELLING ME WHAT TO DO.
I GOT SOMEBODY TALKING IN MY
YEAR RIGHT NOW.
I JUST GOT TO LISTEN TO THE
DOCTORS.
I'M GOING TO LISTEN TO THEM.
I FEEL GREAT, HOPEFULLY START
SOME BASEBALL ACTIVITY THE NEXT
FEW DAYS AND GO FROM THERE.
RAJAI: I HAVE TO BRING BACK TO
YOUR MEMORY, WHEN I WAS IN
TORONTO -- I THINK YOU WERE A
ROOKIE -- YOU HAD, LIKE --
WEAVER AND NECK IN STOLEN -- WE
WERE LIKE AND NECK IN STOLEN
BASES.
I MENTIONED SOMETHING TO YOU
ABOUT STOLEN BASES THAT DAY.
YOU WENT OUT AND STOLE TWO OF
THEM JUST TO TAKE THAT LEAD AND
MADE SURE YOU WERE GOING TO WIN.
MIKE: WHEN I FIRST CAME UP, WHEN
I GOT ON FIRST BASE I WAS GOING
NO MATTER WHAT.
OBVIOUSLY, LATER IN MY CAREER,
WANTING TO CONTROL MY HEALTH,
DIVING SO MUCH.
BUT IT DEFINITELY WAS A GOOD
BATTLE BACK THEN FOR SURE.
MATT: BECAUSE WE'RE ON YOUTUBE
TONIGHT, BIG GLOBAL AUDIENCE,
IT'S ABOUT NOON IN JAPAN AND
THERE ARE A LOT OF FOLKS
WATCHING SHOHEI TONIGHT.
I'M CURIOUS IF YOU GUYS HAVE
EVER HAD LIKE A CROSS CULTURAL
FOOD EXCHANGE WHERE HE IS
INTRODUCED YOU TO SOME REALLY
EXOTIC JAPANESE DINING, LIKE
SOME WEIRD SUSHI.
AND MAYBE YOU'VE HANDED HIM LIKE
A TAYLOR HAM, EGG, AND CHEESE
SANDWICH.
MIKE: NOTHING CRAZY, BUT I JUST
NOTICED WE HAVE JAPANESE
JELLYBEANS IN HERE IN THE
DUGOUT.
THAT'S THE FIRST I EVER NOTICE
THEM, AND THEY'RE EXIT PRETTY
GOOD.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
CALLED.
BUT I WALKED OUT AND GOT SOME
JAPANESE CANDY.
NO, I'M A BIG SUSHI GUY, BUT
NOTHING CRAZY, THOUGH.
HE'S A QUIET DUDE, JUST DOES HIS
OWN THING, PREPARES EVERY OTHER
DAY, AND IT'S GOOD.
I SEE HIM EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE,
HE COMES IN THE HOTEL ROOM AND
PLAYS CARDS.
MATT: YOU GET HIM ON THE JERSEY
DIET.
HE'LL NEVER BE THE SAME.
WALSH WINDS OUT AND THAT RETIRES
THE SIDE AS CASTRO MAKES THE
PLAY.
THANKS FOR THE VISIT TODAY,
SPEEDY RECOVERY.
EVERYBODY WANTS TO SEE ROLE.
MIKE: THANK YOU, APPRECIATE YOU
HAVING ME ON.
MATT: THANKS MIKE.
>> HE JUST SMOKES IT.
>> FORGET ABOUT IT!
>> MY GOODNESS.
>> GREAT BASEBALL RIGHT THERE.
>> AND THAT ONE'S GOING TO GO!
>> THE BALL WAS CRUSHED.
>> AND THIS IS GOING TO DO IT!
>> OH, MY!
>> STRIKE THREE.
>> THAT IS A GREAT PLATE.
-- PLAY.
>> TALKED ABOUT HIS FIELDING
SKILLS, THAT WAS REMARKABLE.
♪
>> SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS WHAT
THEY CAME FOR.
MATT: THIS COPYRIGHTED TELECAST
IS PRESENTED BY AUTHORITY OF THE
OFFICE OF THE COMMISSIONER AND
MAY NOT BE REPRODUCED OR
RETRANSMITTED IN ANY FORM, AND
ACCOUNTS AND DESCRIPTIONS OF
THIS GAME MAY NOT BE
DISSEMINATED WITHOUT THE EXPRESS
WRITTEN CONSENT OF THE --
WITHOUT EXPRESS WRITTEN CONSENT.
MLB GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE ON
YOUTUBE, TIGERS AND ANGELS.
AND A SELECT GROUP OF YOUTUBE
CREATORS, IN-DEPTH THOUGHTS
PROVIDING VIEWERS A UNIQUE
EXPERIENCE.
WATCH US ON YOUR MOBILE DEVICE,
COMPUTER, SMART DEVICE, OR
WHEREVER YOU HAPPEN TO BE
WATCHING US RIGHT NOW.
WE GIVE YOU A POLL EARLIER AND A
NO WRONG ANSWERS QUESTION.
WHO HAS BEEN THE MOST IMPRESSIVE
PLAYER TO START THE YEAR?
AND SHOHEI OHTANI WINS THIS ONE
IN A LANDSLIDE, GUBI.
MARK: YEAH, WHAT HE'S DOING AT
THE PLATE, ON THE BASES, ON THE
MOUND, IT'S TOUGH TO ARGUE THAT.
MATT: JEIMER CANDELARIO BUNS.
OHTANI FALLS AS HE FIELDS.
RAJAI: DID YOU SEE THE ATHLETIC
PLAY FROM OHTANI?
DIVING OFF THE MOUND, GETTING UP
QUICK AND MAKING THAT THROW.
THAT'S A DIFFICULT PLAY RIGHT
THERE.
RAJAI: HE GETS TO THE BASEBALL,
DIVES, AND GETS THERE QUICKLY.
HE GOT THERE THAT QUICK AND THAT
STRONG OVERTHROW, JUST KIND OF
SAILED ON HIM AT THE END.
WHAT A PLAY THAT WAS MY SHOHEI.
-- WAS BY SHOHEI.
MATT: BOTH TIGERS HITS TONIGHT
COURTESY OF JEIMER CANDELARIO.
A BUNT SINGLE HERE IN THE
FOURTH, LEADOFF HITTER ABOARD
FOR THE SECOND TIME FOR THE
TIGERS, AND HERE'S MIGUEL
CABRERA.
RAJAI: GOT TO SEE HIM ONE TIME
ALREADY, GOT THAT ANGLE.
MATT: REMEMBER THE STRIKEOUTS OF
CABRERA BACK IN THE FIRST, IT
WAS THREE FASTBALLS.
RAJAI: SOME HITTERS, THEY JUST
USE THAT FIRST AT BAT TO SEE
WHERE THE RELEASE ANGLE IS, GET
A VIEW OF THAT RELEASE POINT.
MATT: ALEX CURRY HAS MORE ON
MIGUEL CABRERA.
ALEX: YEAH, THE GREAT VETERAN
THAT MIKIE IS, AFTER HE STRUCK
OUT, HE WAS HOLDING COURT IN THE
DUGOUT AND SHARING WHAT HE SAW
FROM OHTANI WITH HIS TEAMMATES
AND THE ADJUSTMENTS HE NEEDS TO
MAKE IN HIS NEXT AT BAT.
AND THEN WE SAW MIGGY HAVING
SOME FUN WITH OHTANI WHEN HE WAS
ON FIRST BASE, UGYS.
MATT: I THINK EVERYBODY THAT'S
PLAYED WITH OR AGAINST MIGUEL
CABRERA LOVES THE GUY.
HE STILL HAS FUN.
HERE'S A GUY THAT'S 38 YEARS
OLD, RAJAI, WE TALKED ABOUT A
GUY WHO IS AN ALL-STAR, AND HE
PLAYS LIKE A KID.
RAJAI: AND HE'S STILL HAVING
FUN.
THAT'S KIND OF HARD TO TEACH
BECAUSE YOU'VE GOT TO LOVE WHAT
YOU DO.
YOU'VE GOT TO LOVE COMING TO THE
BALLPARK.
YOU'VE GOT TO BE REALLY UPSET
WITH THE GAME OF BASEBALL.
AND IT'S HARD TO TRANSFER THAT
INTO ALL THE PLAYERS.
THAT'S WHY HE'S BEEN SO GOOD FOR
SO LONG.
MATT: WELL, HE'S GOT A COUPLE
MORE YEARS LEFT ON HIS MASSIVE
CONTRACT AND -- OH, MAN, THAT
GOT HIM IN THE HELMET.
IT JUST GOT AWAY FROM OHTANI.
RAJAI: THAT'S ALWAYS SCARY,
GOING UP AND IN INTO THE
BATTER'S HEAD AND SHOULDER AND
NECK AREA.
THOSE ARE SCARY, SCARY MOMENTS
FOR BATTERS.
LOOKS LIKE A SPLITTER THERE GOT
AWAY.
MARK: HE GOT UNDERNEATH ON THE
SPLITTER.
MATT: YOU'RE RIGHT.
IT GOT HIM IN THE ARM,
MERCIFULLY.
CABRERA'S OK, RUNNERS AT FIRST
AND SECOND WITH NOBODY OUT NOW
FOR THE LEFT-HANDED HITTING
SHORTSTOP, HAROLD CASTRO.
RAJAI: THAT'S A BIT OF A RELIEF.
MARK: HE'S REALLY, REALLY GOOD
ON THE FIRST PITCH.
MATT: AND ON THE FIRST PITCH, HE
SENDS A FLY BALL TO UPTON TO
LEFT FOR THE FIRST OUT.
RAJAI: THAT'S A BIT OF A RELIEF
FOR MIGGY.
OHTANI CAN PUT YOU AWAY EASY
WITH THE FASTBALL AND SPLITTER,
GETS A LOT OF SWING AND MISS HIS
OWN.
FOR HIM TO HIT HIM RIGHT THERE
IS OBVIOUSLY, WITH THE LACK OF
SUCCESS WITH TWO STRIKES AGAINST
OHTANI, THAT'S A GIFT.
MATT: TWO STRIKE COUNTS AND
RUNNERS IN SCORING POSITION IS
WHEN OHTANI IS AT HIS ABSOLUTE
MEANEST.
WITH RUNNERS IN SCORING POSITION
LIKE THERE ARE NOW, OPPONENTS
ARE 3-29 WITH 18 STRIKEOUTS.
HE JUST DOES NOT GIVE IT UP.
RAJAI: IT SEEMS LIKE SOME
PICTURES, WHEN THEY GET TO THAT
MOMENT -- PITCHERS, WHEN THEY
GET TO THAT MOMENT, THEY
CONCENTRATE MORE ON WHAT THEY'RE
DOING.
MATT: ERIC HAASE WITH A BOUNCER
UP THE MIDDLE.
IT'S GOING TO TURN INTO AN
INNING ENDING DOUBLE PLAY.
THE ANGELS WERE IN THE PERFECT
SPOT, FIRST AND SECOND NOBODY
OUT, AND DETROIT IS TURNED AWAY
IN THE FOURTH.
RAJAI: THERE WAS A TIME WHERE A
BALL HIT LIKE THAT UP THE MIDDLE
IS A BASE HIT.
>> DANIEL NORRIS'S FIRST LOVE IS
BASEBALL, SO HE SPENDS MOST OF
HIS TIME PAINTING QUARTERS --
CORNERS.
>> THAT'S WHAT I WANT TO BE AS
AN ARTIST, I WANT TO EXECUTE MY
ART.
>> BUT HIS SECOND LOVE IS
PHOTOGRAPHY.
>> ART'S A BIG PART OF MY
FAMILY.
MY DAD WAS, HE'S ALWAYS BEEN
REALLY TALENTED WITH THAT.
HE BUILDS BIKES.
>> WHAT NORRIS IS BUILDING IS AN
IMPRESSIVE PORTFOLIO OF
PORTRAITS, AUTHENTIC PHOTOS OF
PEOPLE.
EACH ONE TELLING A STORY.
>> I WANT TO TRY TO TELL THE
STORY THROUGH THEIR EYES,
HOPEFULLY PEOPLE THAT HAVE NEVER
SEEN THAT PERSON BEFORE, NEVER
MET THEM, THEY CAN HAVE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF WHO THAT PERSON
IS AS A HUMAN THROUGH THAT TRIP.
>> FORMER TEAMMATE IAN KINSLER,
THE LATE AL KALINE, AND OLD BOSS
, A TOTAL STRANGER.
NORRIS IS A SELF-DESCRIBED
ADVENTUROUS SOUL, AND EVERY STOP
IS A PHOTO OP.
>> HOBBIES ARE THERE TO GIVE YOU
AN OUTLET OF JUST SOMETHING ELSE
.
THAT'S MINE.
MATT: 2-0 ANGELS.
WE'VE GOT ANOTHER POLL QUESTION,
BO JACKSON EIGHT SEASONS IN THE
BIG LEAGUES, FOUR SEASONS IN THE
NFL.
DEION SANDERS, NINE SEASONS IN
THE BIG LEAGUES, 14 SEASONS IN
THE NFL.
TO CONTINUE CELEBRATE SHOHEI
OHTANI, HOW ABOUT A TWO SPORT
STAR?
TAKE YOUR FAVORITE PICK.
NO WRONG ANSWERS AGAIN.
WERE YOU A BO JACKSON GUY OR
DEION SANDERS GUY?
RAJAI: I WAS ACTUALLY BOTH.
BO KNOWS BASEBALL AND BO KNOWS
FOOTBALL, AND I WAS PLAYING ALL
OF THOSE.
BUT DEION SANDERS WAS THE MAN.
WHO DID THAT DANCE?
HE DID THAT DANCE ALL THE WAY TO
THE END ZONE, THAT IS.
MATT: GUBI, I'M CURIOUS YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THIS ONE.
MARK: YEAH, I'M SITTING IN THE
BOOTH RIGHT HERE, STANDING UP
HERE THINKING VIN SCULLY AND
PRESIDENT REAGAN WERE SITTING IN
THIS EXACT SAME BOOTH IN THE
EIGHTH 89 ALL-STAR GAME, TRYING
TO SAY SOMETHING ABOUT BO
JACKSON AND HE IMMEDIATELY HIT A
HOME RUN ABOUT A MILE.
BO WAS THE MOST UNBELIEVABLE
ATHLETE I'VE EVER SEEN.
BUT SHOHEI'S PUSHING THAT A
LITTLE BIT, WHAT HE'S DOING ON
THE BASEBALL DIAMOND.
I ALWAYS SAY GOD DROPPED THE
PERFECT HUMAN BEING ON THE
GROUND AND THAT WAS BO JACKSON,
BECAUSE HE COULD DO EVERYTHING
SO INCREDIBLY WELL AND NOT EVEN
STRESS ABOUT IT.
MATT: IF I MAY GIVE IT A TRY
HERE, THAT HOMER IN THE 89 --
1989 ALL-STAR GAME SOUNDED
SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
"AND BO JACKSON SAYS HELLO!"
[LAUGHTER]
RAJAI: YEP.
MATT: HERE'S WONG WITH ONE GONE.
HE TURNED A SINGLE INTO A DOUBLE
BY HUSTLING INTO SECOND BASE AS
DAZ CAMERON TOOK A LITTLE TIME
TOGETHER THAT BALL IN.
KEAN'S ALREADY PLAYED A ROLE
TONIGHT.
THAT BASE HIT SNAPPED HIM OUT OF
AN 0-10.
2-0 FROM THE ROOKIE
RIGHT-HANDER, MATT MANNING.
RAJAI: THAT AGGRESSIVE PLAY GOT
THEM ON THE BOARD.
MATT: OH, GATHERED IN BY CASTRO.
WHAT A FINE PLAY BY CASTRO AT
SHORTSTOP!
RAJAI: THAT WAS A NICE PLAY.
WASN'T SURE HE WOULD COME UP
WITH IT.
MARK: SO FAR IN THIS GAME, THE
TIGERS PLAYING SOME PRETTY
IMPRESSIVE DEFENSE, ESPECIALLY
IN THE INFIELD.
RAJAI: THAT'S WHAT YOU CALL HOPS
RIGHT HERE.
MATT: HERE'S JUAN LAGARES NOW
WITH TWO GONE.
ANY BALL HIT UP THE MIDDLE, YOU
JUST SAY IT TO CASTRO BECAUSE
HAROLD CASTRO AND WILLI CASTRO
MAKE UP A VERY UNUSUAL
COMBINATION.
IN FACT, IT'S THE FIRST TIME TWO
DUDES WITH THE SAME LAST NAME
HAVE PLAYED SHORTSTOP AND SECOND
IN THE SAME GAME SINCE ORLANDO
AND ASDRUBAL CABRERA DID IT THE
2011 INDIANS.
THESE GUYS PLAYED SECOND AND
SHORT ONCE BEFORE THIS YEAR.
HERE'S A BASE HIT.
MARK: TELL YOU WHAT, JUST
WATCHING FROM THIS ANGLE,
MANNY'S REALLY STARTING TO
SETTLE DOWN.
YOU ARE SEEING GREAT LIFE, 95
WITH THE FASTBALL.
HE IS RELAXED NOW, STARTING TO
USE HIS SECONDARY PITCHES,
FOURTH INNING WITH TWO OUTS,
TOTAL OF 56 PITCHES.
YOU ARE SEEING WHY THE TIGERS
ARE SO HIGH ON HIM AS FAR AS THE
FUTURE OF THIS ROTATION.
MATT: HE'S BEEN FOUR-SEAM HEAVY
TO START THE GAME TONIGHT, FIRST
PITCH STRIKE TO LUIS RENGIFO.
WE WERE TOLD HE ADDED A SLIDER
IN THE OFF-SEASON.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN A LOT OF THAT SO
FAR TONIGHT.
HE'S THROWN THAT PITCH ONLY FOUR
TIMES.
AND RENGIFO BEHIND, 0-2.
RAJAI: ATTACKING THE ZONE,
ATTACKING THE STRIKE ZONE RIGHT
HERE.
THAT'S GOING TO BE EFFECTIVE.
NOW HE'S GOT THE HITTER RIGHT
WHERE HE WANTS HIM.
HE CAN GO UPSTAIRS OR HE CAN
BOUNCE SOMETHING IN THE DIRT.
SEE IF HE'LL CHASE.
MARK: I'M THINKING THAT KNUCKLE
CURVE MAY BE COMING.
MATT: BACK TO MANNING, WHO MAKES
A VERY ATHLETIC PLAY AND GETS
THROUGH THE SIDE DESPITE THE
TWO-OUT SINGLE.
NUMBER FIVE, STILL
2-0 ANGELS.
>> SO MANY PEOPLE ARE SO EXCITED
TO SEE THIS YOUNG MAN AT 19
YEARS OLD.
>> WE LANDED IN L.A. AT 6:30,
7:00.
WE TAKE A CAB TO ANAHEIM, WHICH
IS AN HOUR AWAY
--
>> A CAB.
>> HERE HE IS, CENTER FIELDER
MIKE TROUT, HIS MAJOR-LEAGUE
DEBUT TONIGHT.
>> WE HAD TRAFFIC TO ANAHEIM.
WE DID NOT GET TO THE STADIUM
UNTIL THE SIXTH OR SEVENTH
INNING.
SO LISTEN, HERE'S THE KILLER.
MOM SAYS MIKE, NOW LEAVE US
FOR TICKETS AND WE'LL BE THERE.
POOR KID, HE DOESN'T LEAVE US
TICKETS.
WE'RE LIKE, OK, WE'LL BUY
>> WE FINALLY GET INTO THE
STADIUM, IT'S LIKE THE TOP OF
THE EIGHTH INNING, AND A BALL IS
HIT TO CENTER.
AND WE HAD JUST SET DOWN.
>>.
BY TROUT ------ ONE RUN BY
TROUT, HE RUNS IT DOWN!
WHAT A PLAY BY THE KID!
♪
MATT: SHOHEI OHTANI HAS BEEN THE
ANGELS' MOST POTENT HITTER AND
THEIR BEST STARTING PITCHER,
NINE ASSIGNMENTS, E.R.A. OF
2.85.
THE REST OF THE GROUP, A 5.43
E.R.A. COLLECTIVELY.
AND OHTANI SHOWING US THOSE
FLASHES TONIGHT IN FOUR SHUTOUT
INNINGS SO FAR AGAINST THE
TIGERS.
HE'LL FACE THE BOTTOM OF THE
ORDER HERE IN THE TOP OF THE
FIFTH INNING, SCATTERED THE
THREE SINGLES SO FAR IN THIS
GAME, TWO SINGLES AND ONE
EXTRA-BASE HIT, BADDOO'S DOUBLE.
HERE IS AKIL FOR THE SECOND TIME
TONIGHT.
WHAT AN UNBELIEVABLE FIRST WEEK
IN MAJOR-LEAGUE BASEBALL AKIL
BADDOO HAD THIS YEAR.
RAJAI: YES.
THAT WAS SOME KIND OF START TO
YOUR MAJOR-LEAGUE CAREER.
I MEAN, TO GO OPPO TACO ON THE
FIRST PITCH -- WAS AT THE FIRST
PITCH HE SAW?
MATT: FIRST PITCH HE SAW.
EASY, RIGHT?
I'M GOING TO HIT 70.
RAJAI: WAS THAT OFF THE BENCH?
MATT: I THINK HE WAS A STARTER
THAT DAY.
NETS HIM A LEADOFF SINGLE.
HE'S 2-2 AGAINST OHTANI TONIGHT.
AFTER A HOMER ON THE FIRST PITCH
HE SAW, THE NEXT NIGHT HE HIT A
GRAND SLAM.
THE NEXT NIGHT HE HAD A WALKOFF
SINGLE.
AND THE NIGHT AFTER THAT, A
TRIPLE AGAINST A GUY THAT
FINISHED RUNNER-UP IN THE CY
YOUNG VOTING LAST YEAR.
HE JUST DOMINATED.
RAJAI: WHEN YOU COME UP AND DO
THAT KIND OF THING, MAN, THIS
GAME IS EASY.
MATT: RIGHT.
HERE'S WILLI CASTRO WITH BADDOO
ABOARD.
HE'S STOLEN SEVEN OF EIGHT.
MARK: I THINK HE'S GOT TO GO
HERE.
OHTANI IS QUICK TO THE PLATE.
SUZUKI HAS STRUGGLED THROWING
OUT BASE STEALERS.
I THINK YOU'VE GOT TO PRESS THE
ISSUE IF YOU ARE THE TIGERS.
RAJAI: TOUGH TO GET A GOOD LEAD
ON OHTANI BECAUSE HE'S GOT QUICK
FEET, ATHLETIC PITCHER AND HE
GETS THAT BALL TO FIRST BASE
REALLY QUICK.
SO YOU REALLY CAN'T BE OFF THAT
BAG TOO MUCH.
SO GETTING A GOOD JUMP IS GOING
TO BE DIFFICULT.
BUT PICKING THE RIGHT PITCH IS
GOING TO BE THE KEY.
MATT: KURT SUZUKI JUST 17% AS
FAR AS CAUGHT STEALING THIS
YEAR, DOWN FROM HIS CAREER
AVERAGE.
HE'S BEEN OHTANI'S GUY.
THAT HAS BEEN HIS PERSONAL
CATCHER THIS YEAR FOR ALL THE
ONE START.
SUZUKI HAS BEEN BACK THERE, THE
15 YEAR VETERAN.
RAJAI: SUZUKI HAS BEEN JUST
AMAZING, JUST BEING A TEAMMATE
WITH HIM IN OAKLAND AND WATCHING
THE DAILY GRIND THAT HE WOULD DO
EVERY SINGLE GAME BECAUSE HE WAS
CATCHING ALL THE GAMES.
AND AFTER THE GAME, HE WAS
GETTING INTO ICE TUBS AND
SOAKING THAT BODY EVERY SINGLE
GAME, SO HE IS ONE OF THOSE GUYS
JUST TAKING CARE OF THE --
TAKING CARE OF HIS BODY.
THAT'S WHY HE'S STILL PLAYING
TODAY.
MATT: ON THE GROUND AND
TAILOR-MADE FOR TWO.
HE DIDN'T HAVE A LOT ON IT AND
CASTRO RUNS WELL ENOUGH TO BEAT
IT OUT.
MARK: SO FAR THIS YEAR, SHOHEI
OHTANI HAS COME INTO THIS GAME
ONLY HAD ONE DOUBLE PLAY TURNED
BEHIND HIM.
LOOKS LIKE THAT WAS GOING TO BE
HIS SECOND OF THE GAME.
REN HE FOLK, THE WAY THE DEFENSE
WAS SET UP, UNABLE TO TURN IT,
CASTRO THINKING HE HAD A DOUBLE
PLAY.
RAJAI: CASTRO BUSTING HARD DOWN
THE LINE, PETE ROSE JUST GOING
TO WORK HARD AND HUSTLE DOWN THE
LINE.
THOSE ARE WHAT MANAGERS LOOK
FOR.
THOSE WILL KEEP YOU IN INNINGS.
MATT: HERE IS DAZ CAMERON WITH
ONE OUT AND ONE ON.
GETTING BACK HERE COMMENTS ABOUT
KURT SUZUKI TAKING CARE OF HIS
BODY.
YOU SAID THAT LIKE A GUY WHO DID
NOT TAKE CARE OF HIS BODY.
I'VE HEARD THE STORIES OF YOU
TAKING CARE OF YOUR TOES.
I'VE HEARD THOSE STORIES.
RAJAI: YES, SIR.
I HAD TO TAKE CARE OF THEM FEET
BECAUSE THEM FEET TOOK CARE OF
ME.
I KNEW THAT FROM THE BEGINNING.
MATT: ANOTHER BOUNCE, ANOTHER
CHANCE FOR TWO.
FLETCHER GETS ONE, AND THE
SECOND!
FINE PLAY BY DAVID FLETCHER,
FILLING IN FOR JOSÉ IGLESIAS AT
SHORTSTOP.
SPEAKS ITALIAN, HITS PITCHES
THROWN ABOVE HIS HEAD FOR
DOUBLES.
♪
>> MAX SCHERZER IS ON THE MOUND
FOR THE TIGERS TONIGHT AND HE IS
LOOKING TO BECOME THE FIRST
TIGERS PITCHER SINCE AT LEAST
1916 TO HAVE A 10-0 RECORD.
>> AND A SWING AND A MISS AND
MACHADO IS RETIRED.
>> SWING AND A MISS, GOT HIM
WITH THE BREAKING BALL.
AND THE 2-2 PITCH.
SWING AND A MISS.
AND HE GOT HIM.
THAT WILL BE THE FOURTH
STRIKEOUT SCHERZER HAS, TWO IN A
ROW.
NOW MAX READY WITH THE 1-2.
SWING AND A MISS, STRUCK HIM
OUT.
DICKERSON GOES DOWN SWINGING FOR
THE SECOND TIME.
THE RUNNERS WILL BE ON THE MOVE
HERE.
SWING AND A MISS!
HE STRUCK HIM OUT AT 97.
SWING AND A MISS, HE STRUCK HIM
OUT.
MAX SCHERZER, ANOTHER QUALITY
START FOR THE TIGERS.
SO MAX SCHERZER IS NOW 10-0 TO
START THE SEASON, THE SECOND
TIME IN TIGERS HISTORY THAT'S
BEEN DONE.
WHAT A START FOR MAX AND WHAT A
GAME TONIGHT.
TIGERS WIN IT, 5-1.
♪
MATT: EACH WEEK THIS SEASON, WE
WILL FOCUS ON THE YOUTUBE
CONTENT CREATOR.
TODAY, OUR SPOTLIGHT SHINES ON
AUSTIN.
YOU CAN WATCH THIS ANGELS FAN
SHARE HIS LOVE OF BASEBALL WITH
EVERYONE.
AND AS AN ANGELS FAN, I'M SURE A
FAN OF DAVID FLETCHER LEADING
THINGS OFF.
ALL RIGHT, GUBI, YOUR MAN, BO.
YOUR KANSAS CITY PAL WON THE
POLL TONIGHT.
MARK: ONE OF THE GREATEST
STORIES, THE GAME WITH BO
JACKSON AND YANKEE STADIUM, HIT
THREE HOME RUNS IN A GAME, DOVE
FOR A LINE DRIVE DEION SANDERS
HIT.
THAT'S WHY HE DISLOCATED HIS
SHOULDER.
HE GOT AN INSIDE THE PARK HOME
RUN IN THE SAME GAME.
YOU SAW THE ATHLETICISM ON
DISPLAY.
THAT WAS EQUAL TO SEE.
MATT: ONE GONE.
RAJAI: PRETTY FUN WATCHING
MANNING SETTLE IN AND GET
COMFORTABLE AND ATTACK THE ZONE.
HE'S STARTING TO GET A LITTLE
DEEP IN THIS GAME NOW.
MATT: ONE OUT NOW IN THE FIFTH.
HE'LL FACE JUSTIN UPTON FOR
THIRD TIME.
UPTON HAS GROUNDED OUT AND
STRUCK OUT TONIGHT.
WHEN WE TALKED WITH A.J. HINCH
BEFORE THE GAME, AND HE TALKED
ABOUT MANNING AND GAVE US WHAT
TO EXPECT, HE SAID HE'S THE KIND
OF GUY IF HE'S ON YOUR SIDE, YOU
LOVE HIM, BUT IF HE'S ON THE
OTHER SIDE, HE'S GOING TO BUG
YOU.
THINK THAT IS A GOOD COMPLEMENT
TO PAY A PLAYER.
RAJAI: A PLAYER LIKE THAT IS
GOING TO GO OUT AND COMPETE NO
MATTER WHO IS IN THE BOX HE IS
FACING.
HE'S GOING TO GO OUT THERE AND
CHALLENGE HIM, SEE WHAT HE CAN
DO WITH HIS STUFF.
MATT: HE'S FROZEN JUSTIN UPTON
ON FASTBALLS A COUPLE OF TIMES
TONIGHT.
THAT WAS WELL LOCATED.
RAJAI: HE CHALLENGED HIM THE
EARLY, 3-1 COUNT.
JUSTIN GROUNDED THAT BALL TO THE
THIRD BASEMAN.
MATT: STRUCK HIM OUT FOR THE
SECOND TIME ON A LIVELY 95 MILE
PER HOUR HEATER.
HE'S FEELING IT NOW.
MARK: HIS FASTBALL VELOCITY HAS
PICKED UP, AND HIS COMFORT WITH
HIS FASTBALL -- JUSTIN UPTON IS
CRUSHING BREAKING BALLS THIS
YEAR.
HE'S HAD A TOUGHER TIME WITH
FASTBALLS.
HERE'S A LOOK AT OUR STATCAST
POWERED BY GOOGLE CLOUD.
43 FASTBALLS.
FIVE CHANGEUPS.
THESE CHALLENGE QUITE A BIT WITH
44 FOUR-SEAM FASTBALLS.
RAJAI: IT LOOKS LIKE THE HITTERS
ARE NOT PICKING IT UP THAT WELL
OR AT LEAST NOT UPTON.
IT DIDN'T LOOK LIKE HE WAS
PICKING THE BALL UP THAT WELL.
MATT: A BALL AND NO STRIKES, THE
COUNT TO SHOHEI OHTANI.
A RARE CHANGEUP THAT TIME FROM
MANNING, AND IT'S 2-0.
MARK: WATCH OUT FOR THE SWING.
[LAUGHTER]
MATT: HE WAS DIALED UP FOR IT.
MARK: UPSTAIRS WITH THE
FASTBALL, FOUR-SEAMER, BUT
SHOHEI CAN HIT A HIGH FASTBALL
VERY, VERY WELL.
RAJAI: IT LOOKS LIKE HIS
FASTBALL IS PLAYING UP A TICK
WITH THE DECEPTION HE'S GETTING
ON IT, WITH THE WAY THE HITTERS
ARE REACTING TO HIS FASTBALL.
MATT: HE LOSES OHTANI FOR THE
SECOND TIME.
IF A ROOKIE RIGHT-HANDER MAKING
HIS MAJOR-LEAGUE DEBUT IS A
LITTLE RELUCTANT TO GIVE IN ON A
STRIKE, THIS MIGHT BE PART OF
THE REASON WHY.
TUESDAY IN OAKLAND, THAT BALL
WAS CLOBBERED, AND THEN
YESTERDAY AFTERNOON, YOUR OLD
STOMPING GROUNDS.
RAJAI: STAYING AWAY FROM THAT
HOT BAT, PROBABLY NOT ALWAYS A
BAD IDEA, AND GETTING THOSE GUYS
THAT YOU KNOW YOU HAVE A BETTER
SHOT AT.
MATT: NOW IT'S TAYLOR WARD WHO
IS BATTING THIRD, BY THE WAY, AS
HIGH AS HE'S HIT IN THE ANGELS
ORDER TONIGHT.
ANTHONY RENDON, STILL NURSING A
TRICEPS INJURY.
JOSE IGLESIAS WITH A SCHEDULED
DAY OFF.
MIKE TROUT, STILL MENDING THE
CALF INJURY.
>> EVERY TIME I LOOK UP, IT
SEEMS LIKE IT IS TO OUTS WHEN
MANNING IS ON THE MOUND.
MARK:MARK: SHOHEI WAS ON THE
MOVE.
HE WASN'T EVEN LOOKING IN.
JOE MADDON, DID HE JUST TRIED TO
STEAL A BASE AS A PITCHER?
RAJAI: LOOK AT THOSE GLOVES HE
HAS ON.
I KIND OF WISH I HAD THOSE WHEN
I WAS STEALING.
MATT: WHY DIDN'T YOU WEAR THOSE?
RAJAI: I DON'T THINK WE HAD
THOSE.
THOSE MIGHT BE A DIFFERENT
MARKET FOR OHTANI.
MATT: TWO BALLS AND A STRIKE.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN --
WHAT HAPPENED WHEN SHOHEI GOT TO
FIRST BASE WITH MIGUEL CABRERA.
RAJAI:RAJAI: THAT IS MIGUEL
CABRERA ALL THE TIME.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHO IT IS.
THAT IS HIM ALL DAY.
MARK: THOSE GLOVES LOOK LIKE
SOMETHING YOU COULD TAKE INTO AN
MMA FIGHT.
RAJAI: YOU'VE GOT TO BE CAREFUL
SOMETIMES SLIDING IN HEADFIRST
WITH THE TAG.
WE HAD ONE PLAYER GOING
HEADFIRST, HANDS FIRST, AND
BROKE HIS HAND WITH JUST THE
SWIPE OF A TAG.
THAT IS DEFINITELY GOING TO HELP
OUT WITH THE PROTECTION.
MATT: FOR ME, THOSE GLOVES LOOK
LIKE THE GLOVES THE CHARACTERS
WHERE AT DISNEYLAND ACROSS THE
STREET.
YOU'VE GOT MICKEY AND M
INNIE, AND THEY'VE GOT THE HUGE
HANDS THEY ARE WAVING.
RAJAI: WE KNOW ALL ABOUT THAT IN
THE DAVIS HOUSEHOLD.
MATT: TWO BALLS AND TWO STRIKES,
THE COUNT TO TAYLOR WARD.
COMING AT HIM WITH HIGH
FASTBALLS, AND OHTANI WAS
RUNNING AGAIN.
MARK: THAT'S A 2-2 COUNT.
THAT'S TWICE NOW HE'S GONE
ALREADY IN THIS AT BAT.
REMEMBER, HE'S GOING TO TAKE THE
MOUND IN THE SIXTH INNING.
HE'S OUT THERE SMILING.
MATT: THERE HE GOES AGAIN, AND
WARD IS LOCKED UP ON A 95 MILE
PER HOUR HEATER.
ALL THAT FOR NOTHING, AND NOW
HE'S GOT TO GO BACK OUT THERE
2-0, ANGELS.
>> HE'S DONE IT!
SPENCER TURNBULL HAS THROWN THE
EIGHTH NO-HITTER IN TIGERS
HISTORY.
>> LOOK AT THE LOVE THE TEAM IS
SHOWING HIM.
WE ARE ALL HAPPY FOR HIM.
EVERYONE IN THE STADIUM IS HAPPY
FOR HIM.
>> HERE'S THE PAYOFF.
FLY BALL, LEFT FIELD.
FRAZIER GOING BACK, MEASURING
IT.
THAT BALL IS GONE!
WE ARE GOING HOME ON A TWO-RUN
GAME-WINNER.
>> THIS IS BEAUTIFUL.
>> DEEP RIGHT FIELD.
GET UP, IT'S GONE!
HIS FIRST AS A MAJOR LEAGUER.
TIES IT AT 4-4.
YEAH, BABY.
>> THAT'S WORTH STICKING AROUND
FOR, ISN'T IT?
>> YOU'VE GOT TO SAY IT.
THAT'S AWESOME.
♪
MATT: COME ON OUT TO THE BIG A
ON JUNE 22 OF THE ANGELS FACE
THE GIANTS.
THE FIRST 14,000 FANS RECEIVE A
RALLY MUG.
FOR MORE INFO, VISIT
ANGELS.COM/PROMOTIONS.
MARK: SHOHEI OHTANI SO FAR ON
THE NIGHT, FIVE SHUTOUT INNINGS.
HE'S BEEN HELPED BY THE GROUND
BALL.
WE ALWAYS THINK OF STRIKEOUTS,
HE HAS FOUR, BUT TWO DOUBLE
PLAYS TURNED.
YOU JUST HOPE HE DOESN'T GET A
LINE OUT.
SO FAR, SO GOOD, SHOHEI OHTANI
PITCHING INTO CONTACT.
MATT: OHTANI HAS GONE PAST FIVE
INNINGS ONLY THREE TIMES THIS
YEAR, THREE OF HIS NINE STARTS.
HIS LONGEST, A SEVEN-INNING
START IN MID-MAY.
OUT THERE FOR THE SIXTH AFTER A
LOT OF RUNNING IN THE FIFTH.
MARK: THIS IS GOING TO BE A REAL
BIG INNING FOR SHOHEI OHTANI.
HERE HE IS GOING INTO THE SIXTH
INNING TO KEEP TRYING TO KEEP
THOSE LEGS STRONG, AND IS AT THE
TOP OF THE ORDER.
ESPECIALLY A GUY WE'VE MENTIONED
BEFORE, ROBBIE GROSSMAN, WHO'S
HAD A LOT OF SUCCESS.
HE'S UP THERE SWINGING FIRST
PITCH.
THIS MIGHT BE THE AT-BAT WHERE
HE'S READY TO SWING EARLY
AGAINST OHTANI.
RAJAI: MAYBE HE WILL GET A BALL
HE LIKES AND DRIVE IT.
MATT: A BALL AND NO STRIKES TO
GROSSMAN.
A COUPLE OF MICRO RALLIES.
TWO RUNNERS ABOARD WITH NOBODY
OUT IN THE FOURTH, THEIR BEST
OPPORTUNITY TO SCORE, BUT THEN A
FLY BALL AND A DOUBLE PLAY
FINISHED THEM OFF RATHER
QUICKLY.
TWO BALLS AND NO STRIKES.
WE TALK ABOUT THIS OFTEN, RAJAI,
THE FACT THAT PITCHERS ARE NOT
ALLOWED THE CHANCE TO GO DEEP
INTO LINEUPS AND DEEP INTO GAMES
ANYMORE, AND HOW THIRD TIME
THROUGH THE RESULTS GET WORSE
FOR PITCHERS.
FOR OHTANI, WHEN FACING THE
LINEUP FOR THE THIRD TIME,
OPPONENTS ARE ONLY 4-27 THIS
YEAR.
THAT'S PRETTY IMPRESSIVE.
AS YOU GET TO SEE A PICTURE'S
RELEASE POINT FOR THE THIRD TIME
IN A BALLGAME, THAT IS WHERE YOU
START TO FEEL REAL COMFORTABLE,
ESPECIALLY IF YOU HAVE A KNOCK
ALREADY.
YOU ARE LOOKING FOR TWO OR THREE
KNOCKS THAT TIME.
MATT: ANGELS BULLPEN, YET TO GET
BUSY BEHIND OHTANI.
3-1 TO GROSSMAN.
RAJAI: THAT'S JUST A GOOD PITCH,
3-1, BACKDOOR CURVEBALL, NOT
REALLY LOOKING FOR THAT.
THAT'S NOT THE PITCH YOU WANT.
IT'S NOT THE PITCH YOU WILL BE
LOOKING TO DRIVE.
HE'S ALSO LOOKING TO GET ON
BASE.
MATT: GROSSMAN TAKES A THREE-TO
PITCH INTO RIGHT, AND THAT IS
OHTANI'S FIRST OUT OF THE
INNING.
YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME.
FANS WATCHING ON MOBILE DEVICES
AND COMPUTERS CAN VOTE FOR WHICH
PLAYER WILL RECEIVE THE TROPHY
DURING THE POST SHOW.
STAY TUNED FOR THE PLAYER OF THE
GAME PULLING OPTIONS COMING UP
LATER TONIGHT.
I HEREBY SUBMIT SHOHEI OHTANI AS
AN OFFICIAL CANDIDATE.
MATT:MATT: HE'S BEEN PRETTY
GOOD.
ONE GONE FOR JONATHAN SCHOOP WHO
STRUCK OUT TWICE IN THE GAME
TONIGHT.
FOR FOLKS WATCHING THE ANGELS
FOR THE FIRST TIME TONIGHT, THE
FACT THAT OHTANI'S PRESENCE HAS
ACTUALLY CHANGED POLICY AND THAT
THEY USE A SIX-MAN ROTATION, IT
SPEAKS VOLUMES ABOUT HOW
IMPORTANT HE IS WHEN THE OTHER
FIVE GUYS HAVE TO ADJUST TO
DIFFERENT DAYS OFF TO
ACCOMMODATE ONE MAN A.
IT TELLS YOU HOW IMPORTANT THAT
ONE MAN IS.
MARK: THEY'VE ALL EXCEPTED THAT,
ALSO.
EVERY TIME I TALK TO ANY STARTER
-- USUALLY, WE ARE ALL ABOUT
STARTING PITCHERS.
WE GET TO GO AN EXTRA DAY.
WE GET TO POTENTIALLY GET DEEPER
IN THE GAME AND THROW MORE
PITCHES WITH SHOHEI OHTANI'S
PRESENCE, BECAUSE HE'S BEEN THE
ACE OF THE STAFF WHEN HE'S BEEN
OUT THERE ON THE MOUND.
MATT: 2-1.
WELL HIT INTO LEFT FIELD.
THAT ONE IS GONE.
A HANGER THAT JONATHAN SCHOOP
CRUSHES TO MAKE A ONE-RUN GAME.
RAJAI: JONATHAN HAS BEEN ON A
TEAR LATELY.
THAT IS WHAT HE DOES WITH
MISTAKES.
MARK: SO FAR IN THIS INNING,
HE'S TRIED TO GET BACK INTO
COUNTS.
THIS IS A BACKUP TYPE SLIDER
THAT STAYS OVER THE MIDDLE OF
THE PLATE.
YOU DON'T MISS THOSE PITCHES.
THAT IS ONE OF THOSE CEMENT
MIXERS.
RAJAI: THOSE ARE THE PITCHES
WHERE YOU ARE LICKING YOUR
CHOPS.
I CAN'T WAIT UNTIL THIS THING
COMES DOWN.
MATT: JONATHAN SCHOOP'S SEVENTH
HOMER IN HIS LAST 14 GAMES.
HE IS ON AN ABSOLUTE TEAR.
NOW IT IS JEIMER CANDELARIO.
I WOULD IMAGINE THAT WOULD GET
THE ANGELS BULLPEN BUSY HERE IN
THE SIXTH INNING.
>> SO FAR, NO MOVEMENT IN THE
BULLPEN.
THAT'S THE FIRST HOME RUN SHOHEI
HAS ALLOWED THIS YEAR.
ALL FOUR HAVE BEEN ON A
FASTBALL, BUT THAT ONE ON A
SLIDER.
MARK: THEY COULD BE PAYING
ATTENTION, WATCHING THE GAME,
SEEING HOW MANY CURVEBALLS HE'S
BEEN THROWING LATELY.
HAD SOME SUCCESS.
YOU MIGHT THINK, OK, I CAN TRY
IT AGAIN.
RAJAI: THE ONE THING TO KEEP AN
EYE ON.
HE HAS NOT THROWN A LOT OF
SPLITTERS AS OF LATE.
THAT WAS A 98 MILE AN HOUR
FASTBALL.
USUALLY WITH TWO STRIKES, HE
GOES TO A SPLITTER.
MATT: HE'S THROWN A TOTAL OF
JUST NINE SPLITTERS.
DANCE MOVES.
MARK: NOW HE CAN DANCE.
WE TALK ABOUT SHOHEI.
HE CAN DO EVERYTHING, AND TROUT
WAS JOKING ABOUT THAT BEFORE.
GETS THAT BALL AND STILL STEPS
ON THE BASE.
LARRY WAS ABLE TO GET TO THE
BAG.
MATT: YOU JUST CANNOT TAKE YOUR
EYES OFF THE SKY.
EVERYTHING HE DOES IS BETTER AND
MORE FUN TO WATCH THAN WITH
ANYBODY ELSE IN THE LEAGUE.
RAJAI: AND HE'S GOT THE TWO
DANCE GOING ON.
MATT: TWO GONE FOR MIGUEL
CABRERA.
WINNING WITHOUT HIS SPLIT, I'M
JUST GOING TO GUESS AND ASK OUR
STATISTICIAN ON YOUTUBE, THE
GREAT MATT BAKER.
THIS HAS TO BE HIS LOWEST
SPLIT-FINGER FASTBALL COUNT IN
ANY START THIS YEAR.
MARK: EVERY GAME I'VE SEEN HIM,
THAT IS THE PITCH HE GOES TO.
HE'S ABOUT 22%, 23%.
THERE HE STARTS CABRERA ON A
SLIDER.
THERE HE THREW HIM A CURVEBALL.
MATT: TWO BALLS AND A STRIKE,
THE COUNT TO CABRERA.
RAJAI: HE'S ALREADY HIT ONE
BATTER WITH HIS SPLITTER.
MAYBE HE'S NOT FEELING AS
COMFORTABLE WITH THE SPLITTER.
IN FACT, I THINK MIGGY WAS THE
GUY HE HIT WITH HIS SPLITTER
EARLIER IN THE GAME.
MARK:MARK: IT MIGHT'VE BEEN THE
LAST ONE I'VE SEEN FROM HIM, THE
ONE HE ACTUALLY THREW.
WILL HE GO RIGHT BACK WITH THE
SLIDER, OR TRY TO CHALLENGE AWA
Y.
MATT: GOT HIM.
IT IS A, SLIDER.
HOWEVER.
IT'S A 2-1 GAME ENTERING THE
BOTTOM OF THE SIXTH INNING
TONIGHT.
>> INTO DEEP RIGHT FIELD,
OHTANI.
SHOHEI GIVES THE HALOS THE LEAD.
>> SHOHEI THE MONEY.
>> MY GOODNESS, SHOHEI OHTANI,
WHAT CAN'T HE DO?
>> SHOWTIME ALL THE TIME.
THAT'S A 95 MILE AN HOUR
FASTBALL.
>> THEY WERE UP THERE TRYING TO
DO AS MUCH DAMAGE AS THEY COULD.
>> SHOHEI, WAY, WAY.
SAYONARA.
WHERE DID THAT LAND?
>> JUST FELL INTO HIS BAT RIGHT
THERE.
>> WELCOME BACK.
AFTER MATT MANNING GOT HIS FIRST
CAREER STRIKEOUT IN THE SECOND
TO END THE INNING, MIGUEL
CABRERA ACCIDENTALLY THREW THE
BALL TO A FAN IN THE CROWD, NOT
REALIZING THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
THAT BALL, BUT THE WHOLE TEAM
ENDED UP COMING OUT OF THE
DUGOUT.
THEY WERE ABLE TO GET A NEW
BASEBALL WITH THAT FAN.
MIGGY GAVE ME THAT SMILE, BUT
ALL IS GOOD IN THE WORLD NOW.
MATT: PROBLEM AVOIDED.
I'M GLAD THAT THE GUYS ALL
CHAMPIONED HIS CAUSE, AND I'M
GLAD THAT THE KIND FAN
UNDERSTOOD THAT WAS SOMETHING
IMPORTANT.
RAJAI: ABSOLUTELY.
THAT IS WHAT YOU'D CALL A ROOKIE
KIND OF MISTAKE, BUT THOSE ARE
THE KINDS OF THINGS YOUR
TEAMMATES, THEY ARE RECOGNIZING,
PAYING ATTENTION.
THEY WANT THAT BALL.
THAT IS SOMETHING YOU ARE GOING
TO CHERISH AND KEEP WITH YOU.
MATT: LEFT-HANDER TYLER
ALEXANDER TAKES OVER, AND HE
WILL FACE JARED WALSH, SUZUKI.
HE'S MADE SOME STARTS THIS YEAR.
MARK: A PRETTY GOOD FASTBALL.
RAJAI: WAS THAT A MISTAKE?
MATT: 0-2 TO WALSH.
RAJAI: WELSH IS PUTTING TOGETHER
A NICE LITTLE SEASON.
MATT: HE IS A LEGITIMATE
ALL-STAR CANDIDATE THIS YEAR.
THEY ARE IN THE SHIFT, AND THE
TIGERS HAVE HIM PLAYED
PERFECTLY.
WE ARE GOING TO GET YOU INTO
ANOTHER QUESTION, A FUTURE HALL
OF FAMER ACTIVE IN A NEW UNIFORM
IN MIGUEL CABRERA.
EIGHT M.V.P.'S COMBINED.
WHICH IS THE MOST IMPRESSIVE
OFFENSIVE PLAYER?
ALL OF THEM WILL BE IN
COOPERSTOWN.
DO YOU WANT TO TACKLE THAT ONE?
RAJAI: WHICH IS THE MOST
IMPRESSIVE PLAYER FOR THE LAST
10 YEARS -- FIRST 10 YEARS?
MATT: THAT'S CORRECT.
RAJAI: IF I'M LOOKING AT THAT,
OUT OF THOSE,D I'VE GOT TO GO
WITH POOLS.
A-- I'D HAVE TO GO WITH PUJOLS.
MATT: WHO WOULD YOU LEAST WANT
TO FACE.
MARK:MARK: I FACED THE BIG HURT
TOO MANY TIMES.
FRANK SERIOUSLY PUT THE BIG HURT
ON ONE OF MY SLIDERS.
TOP FIVE ALL-TIME IN DOUBLES AND
HOME RUNS, ALBERT SITS ALONE AS
FAR AS THOSE CATEGORIES.
R.B.I.'S AND M.V.P.'S, ALBERT IS
THAT GUY.
MATT: ALBERT HIT THE GROUND
RUNNING.
FROM DAY ONE.
SUZUKI SENDS A FLARE TO RIGHT
FIELD THAT IS GOING TO DROP IN.
BASE HIT.
RAJAI: SOMETIMES WHEN YOU SWING
THAT BAT, YOU MAKE IT TO FIRST
BASE.
MARK: THAT WAS A GREAT SANDWICH.
IT CHIPPED UP, TOO.
THAT'S AN EASY GIMME PUTT.
MATT: PLEASE PREPARE YOUR
DIVOTS.
JOE MADDON HAS A SAYING AROUND
THE ANGELS.
THIS IS PHIL GOSSELIN.
THERE IS A SAYING AROUND THE
ANGELS THIS YEAR, PLAY LIKE IT'S
1985.
IT FEELS LIKE IT IS 1985 FROM
WHERE WE ARE IN THE STUDIO.
FANS ARE LOVING THE FACT THAT
THEY ARE BACK, AND EVERYBODY IS
OUT THERE LETTING IT EAT.
MARK: THEY WERE ALL BACK AT THE
BALLPARK, EVERYONE DOING THE
WAVE.
MATT: GOSSELIN SENDS A DRIVE OUT
TO CENTER FIELD.
RAJAI: AS A PLAYER, YOU LOOK FOR
THOSE THINGS.
YOU KNOW IT'S COMING.
IT'S USUALLY GOING THE SAME
DIRECTION.
THERE WAS ONE TIME THAT I SAW
THE WAVE WENT ONE WAY.
THE CROWD STOPPED AND WENT THE
OTHER.
THEY SLOWED IT DOWN, DID THE
MATRIX, SPED IT UP.
MATT: IF ANYPLACE IS CAPABLE OF
DOING THAT, IT IS MILWAUKEE.
RAJAI: THEY WERE OUT THERE
BEFORE WE GOT TO THE BALLPARK.
CAMPING OUTSIDE, HAVING A GOOD
TIME.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY BEERS THEY
HAD BEFORE GETTING TO THE
BALLPARK.
MATT: A RUNNER ABOARD WITH TWO
GONE FOR JUAN LAGARES.
IT SOUNDS LIKE A MONTREAL CROWD.
YOU KNOW HOW THEY WOULD OOH AND
AAH OVER FOUL BALLS.
IT SOUNDS LIKE A BUNCH OF FOLKS
WHO HAVEN'T BEEN TO A BASEBALL
GAME IN A LONG TIME.
MARK: ANYTIME A FAN MAKES A PLAY
ON A FOUL BALL, EVERYONE IS
READY TO GIVE THEM A STANDING
OVATION.
AS A PLAYER, IT MUST'VE BEEN SO
HOLD -- SO HARD.
SOMETIMES AS A HITTER, YOU GET
ENERGIZED.
I KNOW TROUT TALKED ABOUT IT
EARLIER.
HE SAID IT'S THE MOST DIFFICULT
THING TO PLAY, WHETHER THEY WERE
FOR YOU OR AGAINST YOU.
RAJAI: ESPECIALLY TROUT.
HE HAD FANS ALL HIS CAREER.
THEY ARE ALWAYS WATCHING.
IT KIND OF REMINDED ME OF THE
MINOR LEAGUES, BALLPARKS.
ESPECIALLY ON THOSE RAIN DELAYS,
THOSE GAMES WHERE IT WAS RAINING
, VERY FEW FANS IN THE STANDS.
WILL BE THE
NEW PITCHER ENTERING FOR OHTANI,
AS WE GO TO THE SEVENTH AND A
ONE-RUN GAME.
>> THE BIG RED HATS.
THE BIG A.
THESE MAKE ANGEL STADIUM FEEL
LIKE A BALLPARK, BUT YOU MAKE
ANGEL STADIUM FEEL MORE LIKE
HOME.
AS THE SONG GOES, "TAKE ME OUT
TO THE BALLGAME, TAKE ME OUT
WITH THE CROWD," BASEBALL IS
MEANT TO BE ENJOYED WITH A
CROWD.
AFTER A YEAR OF WAITING, WE ARE
EXCITED TO OPEN UP THE DOORS TO
FULL CAPACITY ON JUNE 17.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO BEING FULLY
TOGETHER.
WELCOME BACK.
>> BIENVENIDOS.
>> WELCOME BACK.
MATT: PUSH YOUR FAVORITE PLAYERS
TO THE TOP THE SEASON WITH A
2021 GOOGLE MLB ALL-STAR BALLOT.
HOW ABOUT THE LEADING VOTE
GETTERS IN THE AMERICAN LEAGUE
BY POSITION?
MIKE TROUT WITH OVER 700,000
VOTES, LEADING ALL OUTFIELDERS.
VLADIMIR GUERRERO JR., SHOHEI
OHTANI LEADING AT D.H.
PHIL GOSSELIN OVER AT THIRD BASE
FOR KEAN WONG.
LOOKING TO BOUNCE BACK FROM A
ROUGH OUTING.
VETERAN LEFT-HANDER TONY WATSON.
JOE MADDON, PUTTING WATSON RIGHT
BACK OUT THERE.
HE ALLOWED FIVE HITS AND WALKED
A BATTER.
MARK: THAT'S ONE THING ABOUT JOE
MADDON.
THAT'S WHY PLAYERS LOVE PLAYING
FOR HIM.
HE'S GOING TO PUT HIM BACK IN
THE GAME AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
MATT: NIKO GOODRUM,
PINCH-HITTING, AND SENDING A
BALL OFF THE WALL.
THE TIGERS HAVE THE TYING RUN
IN'S GOING POSITION.
MARK: THEY MIGHT REVIEW THAT
ONE.
UNLESS IT IS OFF THE GLOVE, I
THINK IT MIGHT'VE GONE ABOVE THE
LINE.
YOU CAN SEE HERE A BETTER ANGLE.
92 MILE AN HOUR FASTBALL.
JUST BELOW IT.
MATT: NIKO GOODRUM.
RAJAI: HE DIDN'T TRY TO PULL
THAT BALL.
DROVE IT TO RIGHT CENTER.
MATT: 0-2 SO FAR TONIGHT.
OHTANI WENT SIX, STRUCK OUT
FIVE, AND AN UNUSUAL PART OF THE
START WAS WE PUT A BOW ON IT.
HE THREW A CAREER-HIGH 32
SLIDERS TONIGHT.
MARK: HE WAS ACTIVE, THAT ONE
BUNT.
TRIED TO STEAL THE BAGS A COUPLE
TIMES WHEN HE WAS ON THE BASES,
TOO.
MAYBE JOE MADDON FELT LIKE, I
GOT THE MOST OUT OF MY GET.
MATT: MIKE MAYERS UP IN THE
BULLPEN.
JOE MADDON IS GOING TO GIVE
WATSON AN OPPORTUNITY TO GET IT
BACK TOGETHER AS HAAS BOUNCES IT
TO THE SHORTSTOP.
MARK: THAT'S A HUGE OUT.
A LOT OF TIMES WHEN YOU MAKE AN
OUT, YOU WANT A PRODUCTIVE OUT.
IT KEEPS GOODRUM AT SECOND BASE.
MATT: OHTANI WENT UNDER THE
FANDUEL POSTED STRIKEOUT.
DO YOU HAD TO HITS AGAINST
OHTANI TONIGHT.
TWO HITS FOR BADDOO.
A HOMER FOR SCOPE.
- SCHOOP.
RAJAI:RAJAI: YOU'VE GOT TO FEEL
GOOD ABOUT THAT SHOWING.
HE'S GOT AN OPPORTUNITY RIGHT
HERE.
MATT: THERE GOES THE RUNNER.
THROW DOWN TO THIRD IS NOT IN
TIME.
NIKO GOODRUM STEALS THIRD, AND
THE TYING RUN IS IN SCORING
POSITION.
90 FEET AWAY WITH ONE GONE.
HE'S GOING TO TRY TO STEAL
THIRD.
GOOD PLAY BY GOSSELIN.
YOU KNEW HE WAS GOING TO TRY TO
PEEL.
DID NOT ALLOW HIM TO ADVANCE.
YOU KNEW HE WAS GOING TO STEAL,
AND TIMED IT PERFECTLY.
HAD ONLY BEEN CAUGHT ONCE.
MARK: THAT WAS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY, -- RAJAI: THAT WAS
A GREAT OPPORTUNITY, GREAT TIME
TO STEAL.
MATT: NOW THEY'VE GOT GOODRUM
HUNG UP.
BACK TO SUZUKI.
THIS IS AWKWARD.
WALSH IS INVOLVED IN NOW.
FLETCHER.
RAJAI: HE IS TIRED.
MATT: DOES HE GET HIM?
HE DOES.
THAT WAS ABOUT FOUR TOO MANY
THROWS.
MARK: NOT TEXTBOOK.
A.J. HINCH IS GOING TO LOOK AND
MAKE SURE THEY GOT THE TAG.
MATT: CREDIT BADDOO.
THAT WAS WILD.
MARK: IDEALLY AS A PITCHER, YOU
FIELD THIS BALL, AND YOU RUN THE
BASERUNNER BACK TO THIRD AND GET
LEAD AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
THAT'S A LOW THROW, AND A LOT OF
THINGS WENT WRONG.
THE ANGELS ARE DECENT AS FAR AS
THE FUNDAMENTALS, BUT THIS WAS
STOP -- WAS NOT DONE
FUNDAMENTALLY WELL.
THAT WAS NOT TEXTBOOK AS FAR AS
MAKING SURE HE STAYS AT FIRST
BASE.
MATT: IT'S A FIELDER'S CHOICE
PLAY.
WISELY ADVANCING BETWEEN ALL OF
THE HISTRIONICS BETWEEN THIRD
AND THE PLATE, AND NOW WILLI
CASTRO.
RAJAI: IT'S A LOT OF EXCITEMENT
FOR ONE PLAY.
MATT: THAT'S ONE WAY TO PUT IT.
AS THAT WAS HAPPENING, I HEARD
THE BENNY HILL THEME SONG IN MY
HEAD.
MARK: I WILL LET YOU FIGURE OUT
HOW THAT WENT AS FAR AS 1-5-
2-3-5 FOR THE PUT UP.
MATT: I WAS HOPING YOU WOULD
TELL US.
RAJAI: I GUESS THEY WILL HAVE TO
GO TO REPLAY.
MARK: YOU KNOW I CAN ONLY COUNT
TO THREE.
MATT: A BALL AND A STRIKE, THE
COUNT TO WILLI CASTRO.
STAYS IN THERE FROM THE RIGHT
SIDE OR SWITCHES AROUND TO BAT
FROM THE RIGHT SIDE.
RAJAI: IT'S A CLOSE ONE.
MATT: WATSON CAN'T GET THE CALL.
TWO BALLS AND A STRIKE.
YOU HEARD A FAN CAT CALL.
, ON, JEREMY.
JEREMY RIGGS IS THE UMPIRE
CALLING BALLS AND STRIKES.
HE'S A TRIPLE-A CALL UP UMPIRE.
THIS IS HIS 13TH PLATE
APPEARANCE IN THE BIG LEAGUES.
HE'S BEEN PRETTY GOOD TONIGHT.
USUALLY FOR AN UMPIRE, THAT
REPRESENTS THE GREATEST OF
COMPLIMENTS.
TWO BALLS AND TWO STRIKES WITH
TWO OUT.
TYING RUN AT THIRD.
A LITTLE CHOPPER.
RENGIFO TO TIRE THE SIDE -- TO
RETIRE THE SIDE.
ORTUNITY FOR THE TIGERS
GOES AWAY -- AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE TIGERS GOES AWAY.
♪
>> AND THERE GOES ALL OF
TIGERDOM.
UPSTAIRS, 2-0, TIGERS.
3-0, DETROIT.
>> CUTS THE LINE DRIVE LEFT
CENTER FIELD, IN FOR A BASE HIT.
HEADING HOME, AND THE GAME IS
TIED 3-3.
>> ONE OUT IN THE SEVENTH.
4-3, DETROIT.
BACK GOES MARTINEZ.
IT'S GONE.
>> HE SWINGS.
IT'S A LONG DRIVE TO RIGHT.
IT IS A HOME RUN FOR GIBSON.
THE TIGERS LEAD IT 8-4 IN THE
EIGHTH INNING.
>> A FLY BALL TO LEFT.
HE'S THERE.
HE'S GOT IT.
THE TIGERS ARE THE CHAMPIONS OF
1984.
MATT: THAT IS THE 26-YEAR-OLD TO
WAY WONDER SHOHEI OHTANI TO MAKE
HIS 10TH STARTING ASSIGNMENT OF
THE YEAR.
WE ARE UNDERWAY IN ANAHEIM.
BADDOO IS ON HIS WAY TO THIRD.
YOU JUST CANNOT TAKE YOUR EYES
OFF THIS GUY.
EVERYTHING HE DOES.
STILL A ONE RUN GAME AT ANGEL
STADIUM IN ANAHEIM, CALIFORNIA.
WE WELCOME YOU BACK.
WITH MARK GUBICZA ON AND MAKING
HIS BROADCAST DEBUT, FORMER
TIGER RAJAI DAVIS, I AM MATT
VASGERSIAN.
NIKO GOODRUM STAYS IN THE
BALLGAME, AND TIME TO BREAK OUT
THE FUNK.
KYLE FUNKHOUSER ON THE MOUND FOR
THE TIGERS.
MARK: FUNKHOUSER, POWER
FASTBALL, 94, 97.
HE WILL THROW A SLIDER AND A
CHANGEUP.
MATT: FUNKHOUSER LAST PITCHED ON
MONDAY A SCORELESS TWO THIRDS OF
AN INNING AGAINST THE ROYALS.
WALKED A BATTER, STRUCK OUT
ANOTHER.
HE TOO HAS MADE A START THIS
YEAR, AND LUIS RENGIFO WILL LEAD
THINGS OFF FOR THE ANGELS,
LOOKING TO PAD THEIR ONE-RUN
LEAD.
SHARPLY HIT RIGHT BACK UP THE
MIDDLE.
MARK: HE WILL GET TO THAT BALL.
DID YOU SEE THE DIFFERENCE?
DID YOU SEE THE DIFFERENCE IN
HOW GROSSMAN ATTACKED THAT BALL?
THE RIGHT FIELDER ATTACKED THAT
BALL?
AS OPPOSED TO THE EARLY INNINGS
WHERE THE ANGELS GOT THEIR RUNS.
HE HAD GRACE OF LEG GOT TO THAT
BALL QUICK -- AGGRESSIVELY GOT
TO THAT BALL QUICK SO HE COULD
SHUT DOWN THAT RUNNER FROM GOING
TO SECOND.
THAT'S ONE THING --
MARK: HE'S A REALLY GOOD BASE
RUNNER.
MATT: HE'S GOT THAT BRIAN
GOODWIN BEARD COMING IN NICE,
TOO.
MARK: THE TIGERS SENSING A HIT
AND RUN WITH FLETCHER AT THE
PLATE.
RAJAI: I'M AMAZED AT HOW GUYS
CAN WEAR THESE BIG CHAINS.
IT SEEMS LIKE IT DOESN'T AFFECT
THEM.
I DON'T LIKE GETTING HIT IN THE
MOUTH WITH ALL OF THAT CHAIN.
[LAUGHTER]
MATT: FLETCHER IS BUNTING.
FUNKHOUSER TO SECOND, AND IT'S
MISHANDLED BY CASTRO.
OUTRAIN RENGIFO BY A STEP AND A
HALF.
-- OUTRAN RENGIFO BY A STEP
AND A HALF.
YOU HAVE TO HANG IT ON THE
INFIELDER, YEAH?
MARK: FUNKHOUSER DID A NICE JOB
GETTING TO THE BASEBALL QUICKLY,
TURNS HIS BODY.
IT WAS LIKE HE WAS THINKING,
QUICK ON THE DOUBLE PLAY AND
TRANSFER.
INSTEAD, THERE'S NO OUTS.
YOU AREN'T GOING TO TURN A
DOUBLE PLAY.
YOU JUST WANT TO MAKE THAT
DOUBLE PLAY AT SECOND.
YOU WANT TO TRY TO BE A FIRST
BASEMAN.
GET THE BAG AND GET THE FORCE
OUT.
RAJAI: THAT'S THE CHALLENGE WITH
BEING A UTILITY GUY AND NOT
REALLY HAVING A SET POSITION.
YOU ARE NOT DOING IT ALL THE
TIME.
ONE OF THE GREAT GUYS I SAW DO
THAT WELL WAS BEN ZOBRIST.
BEING ABLE TO BE AN OUTFIELDER
AND INFIELDER AND BE ABLE TO
MAKE THE PLAYS.
THAT PLAY HAS TO BE MADE RIGHT.
MATT: IT WAS NIKO GOODRUM.
MARK: YOU ARE FACING A GUY LIKE
UPTON WHO WANTS TO DO SOME
DAMAGE AGAINST A TEAM THAT
TRADED OVER TO THE ANGELS.
HAD REALLY PRODUCTIVE YEARS WITH
THE TIGERS.
NOW A CHANCE TO ADD ON RUNS LATE
FOR THE ANGELS.
MATT: ALMOST 60 HOMERS IN
UPTON'S TWO-YEAR STAY AS A
TIGER.
THE MOST RECENT OF HIS FOUR
ALL-STAR APPEARANCES.
THAT WAS NIKO GOODRUM HANDLING
THE THROW AT SECOND BASE, NOT
CASTRO.
A BIG OPPORTUNITY FOR THE ANGELS
TO ADD-ON.
JUST A ONE-RUN LEAD IN THE
SEVENTH.
TWO BALLS AND A STRIKE.
GREAT RETURNS FOR THE ANGELS
ONCE UPTON HAS BEEN INSTALLED AS
THE LEADOFF HITTER.
A CHOPPER.
GOODRUM BAREHANDS, THROWS.
IT IS NOT IN TIME.
THE BASES ARE LOADED.
MARK: JUST A REMINDER THEY ARE
DEFINITELY GOING TO TAKE A LOOK
AT THAT ONE.
I THINK THEY GOT HIM AT FIRST
BASE.
RIGHT AWAY, HE WAS SAYING HE
THOUGHT HE GOT HIM.
I THINK THEY WILL TAKE A SHOT AT
THIS ONE.
MATT: A.J. HINCH IS GOING TO
CALL FOR THE CHALLENGE.
MARK:MARK: IT'S A GREAT PLAY.
HE GOT A LOT ON THAT BAREHAND
THROW.
UPTON RUNS WELL.
WE ALWAYS TALK ABOUT HIS POWER.
THAT'S A GREAT PLAY.
MATT: THE THROW WAS THERE.
DID THE FOOT COME OFF?
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE ANOTHER
COUPLE OF LOOKS AT THIS.
RAJAI: I THINK HE MIGHT'VE
GOTTEN HIM RIGHT THERE.
MATT: REGARDLESS, JOSE IGLESIAS
IS GOING TO PINCH-HIT NEXT.
HE WILL EITHER DO SO WITH ONE
OUT OR WITH THE BASES LOADED AND
NOBODY GONE.
OH BOY.
IT'S MUCH CLOSER THAN WE
THOUGHT.
MARK: HE'S NOT ON THE BAG THERE.
LET'S SEE IF HE CAN PUT THE FOOT
DOWN.
I KNOW THE BASEBALL BEAT HIM
THERE.
FOR SOME REASON, HE DIDN'T HAVE
HIS FOOT ON THE BASE.
I THINK BECAUSE IT WAS SUCH A
GREAT PLAY AT SHORT.
MATT: THE CALL STANDS.
THE BASES ARE LOADED WITH NOBODY
OUT.
IT'S GOING TO BE INNING FIELD
SINGLE FOR JUSTIN UPTON.
RAJAI: THIS GAME SEEMS LIKE IT
IS COMING DOWN TO THOSE LITTLE
THINGS.
MAKING A DIFFERENCE, MAKING THE
PLAYS ON DEFENSE THAT YOU SHOULD
MAKE.
BOY, THIS HAS TURNED INTO A
STICKY SPOT FOR THE TIGERS AS
PITCHING COACH CHRIS FETTER IS
OUT FOR A CONVERSATION.
THEY'VE GOT DANIEL NORRIS OUT IN
THE BULLPEN.
A QUICK REMINDER.
THIS COPYRIGHTED TELECAST IS
PRESENTED BY AUTHORITY OF THE
OFFICE OF THE COMMISSIONER AND
MAY NOT BE REPRODUCED OR
RETRANSMITTED IN ANY FORM, AND
ACCOUNTS AND DESCRIPTIONS OF
THIS GAME MAY NOT BE
DISSEMINATED WITHOUT THE EXPRESS
WRITTEN CONSENT.
JOSE IGLESIAS IS THE PINCH
HITTER, A NONSTARTER.
HE PICKS ON THE FIRST PITCH AND
DRIVES IT INTO LEFT FIELD.
FLETCHER IS HELD AT THIRD, AND
IT IS 3-1, ANGELS.
MARK: IT'S NOT UNUSUAL FOR
IGLESIAS TO BE READY ON THE
FIRST PITCH, AND HE WINDS THAT
ONE WITH AN INFIELD IN.
HE HAS BEEN A VERY GOOD RUN
PRODUCER FOR JOE MADDON.
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT MOVING HIM
UP IN THE BATTING ORDER.
THIS IS WHEN HE GETS A CHANCE AT
A FASTBALL, AND HE DRIVES IT
RIGHT AWAY, ABLE TO GET IT
THROUGH.
RAJAI: READY TO HIT.
ESPECIALLY JIMENEZ AND SCORING
POSITION.
MATT: ONE ON, ONE OFF.
TAYLOR WARD WITH THE BASES
LOADED.
WARD SWINGS AND SENDS A DRIVE TO
LEFT FIELD.
THAT ONCE GOT A CHANCE.
THAT ONE IS GONE!
RAJAI: I DIDN'T REALIZE HE HIT
THE BALL THAT FAR.
IT DIDN'T LOOK LIKE IT.
MARK: HE IS BEING REWARDED FOR
PUTTING UP THAT NUMBER THREE
SPOT IN THE LINEUP.
COMING INTO THE GAME, POINT 424
SLUGGING PERCENTAGE FOR TAYLOR
WARD.
YOU CAN SEE HE IS SUPERSTRONG,
VERY AGGRESSIVE.
HE'S BEEN AGGRESSIVE, SWINGING
EARLY, AND BOY DID HE DO DAMAGE
WITH THAT ONE, A GRAND SLAM.
MATT: TAYLOR WARD'S FIRST CAREER
HIT WITH THE BASES LOADED IS A
GRAND SLAM THAT HAS BLOWN THIS
ONE WIDE OPEN.
TWO BALLS AND NO STRIKES TO
WALSH.
MARK: BOY, THAT LEVERAGE HE
CREATED, HE CRUSHED THAT
BASEBALL.
IT'S A SLIDER RIGHT OVER THE
PLATE.
HIT IT RIGHT DOWN THE MIDDLE OF
THE PLATE AT 88.
RAJAI: A GOOD PITCH TO HIT.
MARK: I HAD A CHANCE TO TALK TO
TAYLOR BEFORE THE GAME.
HE HAD AN INFIELDER'S GLOVE COME
OUTFIELDERS GLOVE.
I SAID, WHERE IS YOUR CATCHER'S
MITT?
HE PULLED IT FROM BEHIND HIS
BACK.
HE DOESN'T CARE WHERE JOE MADDON
PUT HIM DEFENSIVELY.
MATT: BOTH OF THE ANGELS GRAND
SLAMS HAVE COME AT HOME THIS
YEAR.
JUSTIN UPTON HIT ONE IN MID
APRIL AT ANGEL STADIUM AGAINST
THE TWINS.
THE DAMAGE, BY THE WAY, COMING
ON BACK-TO-BACK PITCHES.
IGLESIAS, UP THERE HACKING.
WARD, FIRST PITCH, SLAM.
RAJAI: GOING UP THERE, YOU'VE
GOT TO BE READY TO HIT AND READY
TO HIT THAT FIRST PITCH.
THEY WANT TO GET AHEAD.
THE PITCHERS WANT TO GET AHEAD
A.
PICTURES, YOU'VE GOT TO BE READY
TO HIT THAT PITCH.
MARK: JOE MAN SAYS HE WANTS TO
PLAY LIKE 1985.
EVERYONE WAS AGGRESSIVE ABOUT
NOT WORKING COUNTS IN 1985,
LOOKING FOR THAT BEST PITCH TO
HIT.
IGLESIAS LINES A SINGLE.
TAYLOR WARD DRIVES A SLIDER UP.
FIVE RUNS DRIVEN IN ON TWO
PITCHES, BEING AGGRESSIVE ON THE
FIRST PITCH.
RAJAI: THE BATTING AVERAGE ON
THOSE FIRST PITCHES ARE HIGHER,
TOO.
I KNOW THOSE ARE USUALLY HIGHER
NUMBERS.
MATT: WALSH SWINGS AND MISSES.
THAT IS THE FIRST OUT OF THE
INNING.
MARK: I WAS GOING TO ASK YOU
THAT AS A HITTER.
AS A PITCHER, I KNOW THAT FIRST
PITCH IS SO IMPORTANT TO THROW A
STRIKE.
AS A HITTER, I'D BE MORE APT TO
BE AGGRESSIVE ON THE FIRST
PITCH.
BE READY TO ATTACK IT.
RAJAI: YOU DEFINITELY HAVE TO BE
READY TO HIT THAT PITCH,
ESPECIALLY WITH MEN IN SCORING
POSITION.
WHEN YOU GO UP THERE AS A
HITTER, YOU THINK THE PITCHER IS
IN TROUBLE, NOT THE HITTER.
THE BASES ARE LOADED.
MEN ARE OUT THERE.
HE'S GOT TO COME TO THE ZONE.
YOU'VE GOT TO GO OUT THERE AS A
HITTER BEING VERY READY TO HIT.
MATT: THE MAJOR LEAGUE BATTING
AVERAGE ON THE FIRST PITCH THIS
YEAR IS .339.
WHEN THE PITCHER GETS AHEAD, IT
DROPS TO  .190.
GET UP THERE AND HACK 0-0.
WHAT ARE YOU SWINGING AT THE
FIRST PITCH FOR?
RAJAI: DID YOU NOTICE HOW HE
FOLLOWED OF THE BALL THIS TIME.
HE REALLY ATTACKED THAT BALL.
HE LEARNED HIS LESSON FROM THE
PREVIOUS INNINGS.
HE'S MAKING THE ADJUSTMENT, AND
THAT'S WHAT IT'S ABOUT.
MAYBE A COUPLE INNINGS TOO LATE,
BUT THAT IS WHAT IT IS ABOUT.
YOU HAVE THE YOUNGER OUTFIELDERS
OUT THERE.
MATT: THERE'S GOING TO BE A
PITCHING CHANGE AS FUNKHOUSER IS
REMOVED, AND THE7-1, ANGELS.
WE WILL BE RIGHT BACK.
>> MARK FIDRYCH IS THE MAN
PEOPLE HAVE COME TO SEE.
>> WE WERE CURIOUS COMING TO THE
BALLPARK.
WHO IS THIS CRAZY GUY?
>> YOU WILL SEE HIM MUMBLE A
COUPLE OF WORDS TO THE BALL.
>> WHAT PITCHER EVER TALKED TO A
BALL?
>> MOVE THAT BALL.
MOVE THAT BALL.
>> THE GUY CAN PITCH.
ALL THIS OTHER STUFF WOULDN'T
HAVE MATTERED IF HE WAS GETTING
HIS BRAINS BEAT IN.
>> ANOTHER EASY INNING FOR MARK
FIDRYCH.
>> AS THE NINTH INNING BEGAN,
FIT RICH AND THE TIGERS HAD A
5-1 LEAD.
>> THE FANS ARE STANDING FOR
FIDRYCH.
I DON'T THINK I'VE EVER SEEN A
PICTURE THIS KEYED UP.
GROUND BALL, SHOULD BE THE
BALLGAME.
IT'S OVER, AND THE TIGERS ACT
LIKE FIDRYCH JUST WON THE
SEVENTH GAME OF THE WORLD
SERIES.
>> HE HAS.
HE HAS WON SEVEN IN A ROW.
HE IS SOME KIND OF UNBELIEVABLE.
MATT: BEHIND-THE-SCENES
CONVERSATIONS WITH ALL-STARS AND
M.V.P.'S ON MLB'S NEW PLAYER TO
PLAYER PODCASTS.
SEARCH "THE BIGS" ON APPLE
PODCASTS, SPOTIFY, OR WHEREVER
YOU LISTEN.
TIGERS SINGLE-GAME TICKETS JULY
THROUGH SEPTEMBER, THEY GO ON
SALE TOMORROW AT 10:00 A.M.
GO TO TIGERS.COM/TICKETS.
THE TIGERS ARE ON THEIR SECOND
PICTURE OF THE INNING.
IT WILL BE BUCK FARMER TO WORK
WITH ONE OUT, ONE ON, AND FIVE
RUNS IN.
RAJAI: BUCK FARMER WORKING HIS
WAY BACK.
MATT: CALLED UP FROM TRIPLE-A
TOLEDO PRIOR TO SUNDAY'S SERIES
FINALE.
THIS IS HIS SECOND APPEARANCE ON
A BIG-LEAGUE ROSTER.
A GUY WITH PLENTY OF STARTERS
EXPERIENCE -- STARTER EXPERIENCE
OVER HIS TIGERS CAREER.
HE COULD FINISH OFF WHAT HAS
BEEN A TROUBLING INNING FOR
DETROIT IN THE BOTTOM OF THE
SEVENTH.
THREE COUNTS -- THREE BALLS, NO
STRIKES.
MARK: STILL PRETTY GOOD FROM
FARMER.
IT'S 92 TO 98.
BACK-TO-BACK CHANGEUPS.
MATT: 3-0.
THIS NARRATIVE TURNED.
THE TIGERS HAD THE TYING RUN AT
THIRD BASE.
NOW THEY FIND THEMSELVES DOWN BY
SIX.
SENT OUT TO RIGHT CENTER FIELD.
RAJAI: THAT SEPARATES THE TEAMS
THAT ARE WINNING.
THE DETROIT TIGERS, BEING ABLE
TO DO THOSE LITTLE THINGS, KEEP
GUYS FROM GETTING EXTRA BASES,
NOT GIVING AN EXTRA 90 FEET, AND
NOT ALLOWING TEAMS TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF MENTAL MISTAKES.
OVERTHROWING CUTOFF MAN, GETTING
EXTRA BASES.
THOSE ARE THINGS YOU CAN AVOID
AS A POSITION PLAYER, DEFENSE.
THESE THINGS CAN BE AVOIDABLE,
JUST PLAYING AND KNOWING WHAT
YOU ARE GOING TO DO WHEN THE
BASEBALL IS HIT TO YOU.
MATT: HERE IS JUAN LAGARES, THE
EIGHTH ANGEL BAT IN THE INNING.
SOME WILD GAMES GOING ON AROUND
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL AS WE
SPEAK.
THE REDS AND PADRES IN SAN DIEGO
.
THAT WAS A 2-0 LEAD FOR SAN
DIEGO.
THE RED SCORED FOUR, AND THE
PADRES SCORED TWO.
LAGARES BOUNCES IT TO GOODRUM.
THE INNING-ENDING DOUBLE PLAY.
PLENTY OF ANGELS DAMAGE,
HOWEVER, INCLUDING TAYLOR WARD'S
FIRST CAREER GRAND SLAM.
7-1, ANGELS.
I'M GOING TO TREAT YOU LIKE I
TREAT ANYBODY ELSE.
I DON'T CARE HOW BIG THE NAME.
I'M GOING TO COME AT YOU WITH MY
BEST STUFF AND IF YOU GET A HIT
I WILL TO MY CAP -- MY CAP TO
YOU.
I WILL BE COMPETITIVE.
>> SINKING FASTBALL, OUTSIDE
CORNER.
THAT IS STRIKE THREE.
THIS WHOLE BIG-LEAGUE EXPERIENCE
HAS BEEN GREAT, IT'S BEEN SUPER
FUN, A GREAT ATMOSPHERE.
THERE'S A LOT OF PARTS OF THE
GAME THAT I MISSED OUT FROM TWO
YEARS, BUT NOW I HAVE A LOT OF
VETERAN GUYS WHO HAVE TAKEN ME
IN AND HELPED ME OUT SO MUCH.
THEY TELL ME WHAT THEY SEE, THEY
TELL ME WHAT THEY LIKE AND DON'T
LIKE.
I NEED THAT, YOU NEED CRITICISM,
YOU NEED GUYS TO REALLY COME TO
YOU AND KIND OF TELL YOU WHAT
THEY THINK AND YOU BUILD OFF
THAT.
MATT: ACCESS BEHIND THE SCENES
CONTENT ON THE DETROIT TIGERS
YOUTUBE CHANNEL.
VISIT YOUTUBE.COM/TIGERS TO
FOLLOW THE TEAM TODAY.
WE'VE GOT THE RESULTS FROM OUR
MOST RECENT YOUTUBE POLE.
WHICH OF THESE HALL OF FAME
PLAYERS, IS CLOSE, BETWEEN MIGGY
AND ALBERT PUJOLS, BUT ALBERT
WINS BY A NOSE.
HOW COULD YOU GO WRONG WITH ANY
OF THOSE GUYS?
WHAT IS YOUR FAVORITE PIZZA
TOPPING, IT'S LIKE ONE OF THOSE.
MIKE MAYERS IS A NEW PITCHER ON
THE GROUND FOR THE ANGELS AND HE
INHERITS A SIX RUN LEAD.
MARK: I ALWAYS LOVE WHEN ALBERT
A THOUSAND HOME RUNS COMBINED
WINDOWS TWO WERE HAVING A
CONVERSATION.
VERY SIMILAR TOWARD THEIR
APPROACH, HITTING LINE DRIVES
THE OTHER WAY, BUT VERY
DIFFICULT OUTS, EVEN IF YOU'RE
RIGHT-HANDED PITCHER OR
LEFT-HANDED PITCHER WITH MIGUEL
CABRERA AND ALBERT PUJOLS.
MATT: 2-1 TO CAMERON IS GROUNDED
BACK UP THE MIDDLE, BASE HIT.
POWERING INTO SECOND BASE, ALL
RIGHT.
HOW MUCH OF THAT BALL THAT HE
KIND OF LOPED ON IN CENTER FIELD
WAS IN HIS BRAIN WHEN HE DECIDED
TO GO?
RAJAI: EXACTLY.
HE'S THINKING, YOU'RE GOING TO
DO THAT TO ME, I WILL GET YOU
BACK RIGHT HERE.
A LOT OF THAT WAS JUST, HE
TURNED IT ON LATE.
YOU SEE HE TURNED IT ON LATE,
TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF THEM JUST NOT
BEING ABLE TO GET TO THE BALL
FAST ENOUGH.
MATT: CAMERON IN SCORING
POSITION NOW FOR ROBBIE GROSSMAN
WHO IS HITLESS WITH A WALK
TONIGHT.
RAJAI: OF COURSE RIGHT THERE,
YOU DEFINITELY HAVE TO BE SAFE.
YOU CANNOT GET THROWN OUT RIGHT
THERE.
TRYING TO STRETCH A SINGLE INTO
A DOUBLE.
DOWN BY SIX RUNS.
MATT: GOOD POINT.
YOU'D BETTER BE RIGHT.
BOLLEN A STRIKE TO GROSSMAN.
MARK: 360 SIX WITH RUNNERS IN
SCORING POSITION.
HE'S BEEN VERY, VERY CONSISTENT.
EVEN THAT VETERAN INFLUENCE IN
THE LINEUP, BUT ALSO VERY
PRODUCTIVE ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
PLATE.
MATT: INTO CENTER FIELD, CAMERON
IS GOING TO SCORE WITHOUT A PLAY
AT THE PLATE.
ONE OF THOSE RUNS COMES RIGHT
BACK.
7-2 BALLGAME.
MARK: THE ONE GUY YOU DON'T WANT
TO FACE WITH THE RUNNER IN
SCORING POSITION.
TRYING TO GO BACKDOOR CUTTER,
AND HE STAYED RIGHT WITH IT.
THAT'S A BEAUTIFUL SWING BY
GROSSMAN, PICKING UP AN R.B.I..
RAJAI: SHOULD JUST.
YOU DON'T WANT TO RISK GIVING
THE BATTING RUNNER A CHANCE TO
GO TO SECOND BASE.
MATT: JONATHAN SCHOOP NOW, HE
HAS HOMERED TONIGHT.
THE ANGELS TO HAVE TO FIND SIX
MORE OUTS TONIGHT.
THE ANGELS BULLPEN WITH A 4.84
E.R.A., THAT'S IN THE BOTTOM
THIRD OF THE BIG LEAGUES, OF ALL
MAJOR LEAGUE TEAMS.
1-1.
JONATHAN SCHOOP'S HOMER MEANS
HE'S HAS HIT SAFELY IN 20 OF HIS
LAST 24.
AFTER THE ROUGH SCAR -- START HE
GOT OFF TO, THAT'S BEEN A GREAT
REBOUND.
THAT'S TROUBLE, THAT IS DOWN IN
FRONT OF WORK.
THREE STRAIGHT NOT YIELDED BY
MIKE MAYERS.
MARK: RIGHT AWAY, THE BULLPEN
HAS BEEN AN ISSUE, ESPECIALLY
HOLDING LATE LEADS IN THREE
AT-BATS IN A ROW, HIT THE BALL
THE OTHER WAY.
THAT'S WHAT YOU HAVE TO TRY TO
DO WHEN A PITCHER THROWS A LOT
OF CUT FASTBALLS AND SLIDERS.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THE TIGERS
HAVE DONE IN THIS INNING.
THEY ARE PUTTING PRESSURE RIGHT
AWAY ON THE BULLPEN FOR THE
ANGELS.
RAJAI: GOOD FOR SCHOOP, GETTING
ANOTHER HIT.
IN APRIL, IF YOU SAW HIS BATTING
AVERAGE, YOU WOULD NOT THINK HE
WOULD BE IN THIS POSITION RIGHT
NOW.
BUT HE HAS BATTLED, HE HAS
OBVIOUSLY FOUND HIS SWING, FOUND
HIS GROOVE.
MATT: TWO BULLPENS HERE
HEAD-TO-HEAD THAT HAVE HAD A
HARD TIME FINISHING GAMES.
RAJAI: FROM THE LOOKS OF IT, THE
TIGERS ARE NOT OUT OF THIS.
MATT: THE ANGELS SURE DON'T
THINK SO, BECAUSE THEY'VE GOT
THE CLOSER UP.
HERE'S CANDELARIO, HE'S GOT A
COUPLE OF SINGLES TONIGHT.
THAT ANSWER BACK INNING IS SUCH
AN IMPORTANT THING.
WE TALK ABOUT IT A LOT ON THE
AIR.
GIVE UP A CROOKED NUMBER, YOU
CAN CHIP AWAY AND GET SOME OF IT
BACK IMMEDIATELY.
THAT'S A BIG DEAL EMOTIONALLY,
IF NOTHING ELSE.
RAJAI: ABSOLUTELY.
THAT'S NOT BATTLING THAT, WE ARE
NOT GIVEN IN.
WE ARE NOT JUST GOING TO ROLL
OVER ON YOU, WE ARE GOING TO
FIGHT BACK AND TRY TO GET SOME
GUYS ON BASE ANYWAY.
LOOKING TO DRIVE SOMETHING.
MATT: TAKES A STRIKE ON THE
CORNER, 2-1.
MARK: I DON'T THINK JOE MADDON
IS GOING TO WAIT LONG HERE TODAY
WITH MIKE MAYERS.
RAJAI: HE CAME IN WITH THE BASES
LOADED AND NO OUTS AND WAS ABLE
TO PRESERVE OF THE TREE.
MATT: IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME
BETWEEN POSTSEASON APPEARANCES
FOR BOTH OF THESE TEAMS, AND FOR
THE ANGELS, SINCE THEIR LAST
POSTSEASON APPEARANCE IN 2015.
THERE SAVE PERCENTAGE IS ONE OF
THE WORST IN BASEBALL.
RAJAI: I THINK I WAS PART OF
THAT DETROIT TIGERS TEAM THE
LAST TIME THEY WENT TO THE
PLAYOFFS IN 2014.
A LOT OF BIG-NAME PLAYERS ON
THAT.
MATT: 3-2, MIGUEL CABRERA
WAITING ON DECK.
THEY ALL PITCH.
ALL FOUR, AND THAT LOADS THE
BASES.
-- BALL FOUR.
IT LOADS THE BASES IN FRONT OF A
FUTURE HALL OF FAMER.
WE TALKED ABOUT MIGUEL CABRERA,
THE 11 TIME ALL-STAR.
ONE THE TRIPLE CROWN IN 2012.
ONE OF HIS M.V.P. YEARS, AND
HE'S GOT A COUPLE OF MILESTONES
WITHIN HIS SITES AS WELL.
EIGHT HOMERS AWAY FROM .500.
HE'S GOING TO COME BACK AND
THINK ABOUT IT AS JOE MADDON HAS
A BIG PITCHING CHANGE HERE.
IGLESIAS IN THE EIGHTH WITH THE
BASES LOADED AND NOBODY OUT.
♪
MATT: DON'T MISS A MINUTE OF
EXCITING ANGELS ACTION.
CATCH BIG MOMENTS AND INTERVIEWS
AND MORE.
VISIT YOUTUBE.COM/ANGELS AND
SUBSCRIBE TO THE CHANNEL TODAY.
IGLESIAS WILL BE THE NEW PITCHER
FOR THE ANGELS.
INTERESTING CHOICE HERE.
LAST APPEARED ON JUNE 12 PRIVET
OVER THE WEEKEND IN ARIZONA.
PITCHED AN INNING AND ALLOWED A
RUN TO EARN HIS 11TH SAVE OF THE
YEAR.
THERE'S WHY YOU MIGHT HAVE SOME
OPTIMISM IF YOU ARE A TIGERS
FAN.
NOT ONLY ARE THE BASES LOADED
WITH NOBODY OUT, BUT IGLESIAS
HAS ALLOWED MORE HOMERS THAN
ANYBODY IN BASEBALL AFTER THE
SEVENTH INNING THIS YEAR.
RAJAI: WHAT ARE THE ODDS HE'S
THROWING A FIRST PITCH SLIDER
RIGHT HERE?
MATT: YOU TELL ME, WHAT DO YOU
THINK?
RAJAI: I THINK IT'S PRETTY GOOD.
MATT: LOOKING FOR THAT
GROUNDBALL.
BASKETBALL COMES RIGHT AFTER
CABRERA WHO STRUCK OUT ON THREE
PASSED BALLS AGAINST OHTANI BACK
IN THE FIRST.
MARK: SOME SERIOUS NUMBERS WITH
THE BASES LOADED.
IGLESIAS WILL THROW A FASTBALL
96-98.
HE HAS A GREAT CHANGEUP AND A
WIPEOUT SLIDER.
HIS MISS RATE AGAINST THE SLIDER
IS 55% THIS YEAR.
THAT'S A TOP 10 FIGURE AMONG ALL
RELIEVERS IN BASEBALL.
MATT: THIS IS A SIMILAR
SITUATION AS TO THE ONE IGLESIAS
ENTERED BACK ON JUNE 4 AGAINST
THE MARINERS.
BASES LOADED, NOBODY OUT IN THE
EIGHTH.
IGLESIAS AND THE ANGEL SURVIVED
THEN.
THAT WAS A 3-2 LEAD.
HE'S GOT A LITTLE MORE ROOM TO
WORK WITH HERE TONIGHT.
A BALL AND TWO STRIKES TO
CABRERA.
MARK: HE WENT DROP-DOWN SLIDER,
AND MIGGY WAS THINKING HE'S
DROPPING DOWN WITH THE SLIDER.
RUNS IN, CATCHES THE CORNER AT
97.
ABLE TO THROW TWO DIFFERENT
PITCHES FROM THE SAME ARM ANGLE,
AGAINST ONE OF THE GREAT
ALL-TIME HITTERS.
MARK: THAT IS EL DUQUE TYPE
STUFF RIGHT THERE.
MATT: NIKO GOODRUM STARTED WITH
THE 97 MILE AN HOUR FASTBALL.
HE DOUBLED TO OPEN THE SEVENTH.
THEN WAS CAUGHT BETWEEN HOME AND
THIRD ON A PLAY THAT WENT
1536265.
867-5309.
RAJAI: WE JUST TALKED ABOUT THAT
0-0 PITCH, YOU SEE A COUPLE OF
GUYS JUST TAKE THE FIRST TWO
PITCH, THE FIRST PITCH, THE
FIRST FASTBALL.
MARK: THAT'S A GREAT CHANGEUP
FROM IGLESIAS.
HE HAS A GOOD ARM ANGLE, GOOD
ARM ACTION WITH IT.
MATT:  TWO GOODRUM, BASSIST0-2
LOADED ONE GONE.
ROSEMAN, SCHOOP, AND CANDELARIO.
INTO RIGHT FIELD, DOWN IN FRONT
OF WARD, IS GOING TO SCORE ONE
AS GROSSMAN CROSSES THE PLATE.
7-3 ANGELS LEAD.
MARK: I ALWAYS CREDIT GROSSMAN
FOR THAT.
IGLESIAS STEPS OFF AND RUNS
TOWARD HIM.
THEN HE MAKES A MISTAKE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE PLATE.
GROSSMAN DISTRACTS HIM AND MADE
HIM PAY FOR THAT WITH AN R.B.I.
SINGLE.
CHANGEUP, MIDDLE OF THE PLATE
BUT DOWN.
SWEET SPOT FOR A LEFT-HANDED
SWING.
GOODRUM MAKING AN IMPACT
SWINGING THE BAT, TWICE IN THE
GAME.
MATT: STRIKE ONE TO ERIC HAASE.
RAJAI: THIS GUY HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO TIE THIS BALLGAME
RIGHT HERE.
HE DEFINITELY HAS THE POWER.
HE'S GOT EIGHT HOMERUNS IN ABOUT
101 AT BATS.
MATT: THE TYING RUN WITH THE
BASES LOADED.
MARK: ONE OF THE BIGGEST
PROBLEMS FOR THE ANGELS IS THE
AMOUNT OF HIT SAVE GIVEN UP.
EVEN THEIR STARTING STAFF WHEN
THEY BEEN AHEAD IN THE COUNT,
YOU NOTICE AS A HITTER, YOU LOVE
TO SEE UP IT -- IT ARE TRYING TO
GET YOU OUT AT THE PLATE.
RAJAI: ABSOLUTELY.
MATT: IGLESIAS ABLE TO GET THERE
BUT AN ADDITIONAL RUN DOES SCORE
AS SCHOOP CROSSES THE PLATE.
THE TIGERS HAVE CHIPPED AWAY FOR
THREE HERE IN THE EIGHTH.
RAJAI: ANOTHER HIT RIGHT HERE,
YOU'VE GOT A WHOLE OTHER
BALLGAME.
MARK: THAT WAS A PRETTY GOOD
PLAY, HE HAD TO MAKE SURE HE LED
HIM, AS HE GOT TOWARD THE BASES
THROUGH A LITTLE HARDER THAN HE
WANTED TO BECAUSE IT GLACIS WAS
LATE GETTING OFF THE MOUND.
A DIFFICULT ONE TO CATCH AND TAG
THE BAG.
MATT: HERE IS AKIL BADDOO
REPRESENTING THE TYING RUN.
WHAT IS GOING ON?
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME WONKY
MOMENTS HERE.
THE THROW BACK FROM SUZUKI WAS
OFF-LINE.
IGLESIAS HAD TO HOP OFF THE
MOUND TO GATHER IT IN.
THAT IS HEADS UP BY IGLESIAS.
RUNNER AT THIRD BASE, AND
KNOWING HOW AGGRESSIVE THE
BASES, HE WAS ON THAT QUICKLY.
0-1.
THE THROW BACK TO THE PITCHER
ACTUALLY HIT THE BAT OF AKIL
BADDOO.
MARK: IT'S A DEAD BALL.
MATT: WE DIDN'T SEE THAT IN REAL
TIME.
TWO BALLS AND A STRIKE.
RAJAI: BADDOO FEELING PRETTY
GOOD TODAY.
GOT A CHANCE RIGHT HERE TO HELP
THE BALLCLUB.
MATT: THAT'S FLETCHER AT SECOND
BASE WHO MAKES THAT PLAY.
THREE COME RIGHT BACK AND THE
ANGELS HAVE IN THE EIGHTH, 7-4
ANGELS.
>> IT IS A GRAND SLAM.
>> SLAM HAS ALWAYS BEEN A TIGER
FROM DAY ONE.
I NEVER HEARD A CONVERSATION
THAT EVEN MENTIONED GOING TO
ANOTHER TEAM.
THAT'S WHERE WE GREW UP, THAT'S
WHERE WE WERE GOING TO PLAY OUR
CAREER.
I'M SURE SOME OTHER TEAMS WOULD
HAVE LOVED TO HAVE HIM PLAYING
SECOND AND SHORT, BUT WE LOVE
PLAYING WITH THE DETROIT TIGER
BASEBALL ORGANIZATION.
>> HE SPENT 20 YEARS AS
DETROIT'S SHORTSTOP.
HE JOINS THE CLASS OF 2018, ALAN
TRAMMELL.
>> I'M JUST AS HAPPY AS HE IS,
TRUTHFULLY.
PLATE HARD TO DESERVE IT, AND AS
HE WOULD SAY, IT HAS FINALLY
BEEN ACCOMPLISHED.
MATT: BOTTOM OF THE EIGHTH
INNING.
GOOGLE CLOUD IS HELPING TO POWER
STATCAST TO REVEAL NEW INSIGHTS,
TAKING YOU DEEPER INTO THE GAME
THAN EVER BEFORE.
THE OFFICIAL CLOUD TECHNOLOGY OF
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL.
WE WILL USE IT TO TAKE ANOTHER
LOOK AT TAYLOR WARD'S FIRST
CAREER GRAND SLAM.
MARK: HE'S BEEN DRIVING THE
BALL, HE'S BEEN AGGRESSIVE.
A LITTLE BIT TOO PATIENT BACK IN
THE DAY WHEN HE FIRST CAME UP,
TRY TO LIFT THE BALL OUT.
BACKSPIN, ABLE TO GET THAT OVER
THE LEFT CENTER FIELD WALL.
MATT: LUIS RENGIFO STARTED WITH
A LEADOFF SINGLE IN THE SEVENTH.
THEN FLETCHER AND UPTON.
WHEN HE FELL IN FROM THE LEFT
SIDE FOR THE FIRST TIME IN THIS
GAME.
-- LUIS RENGIFO IN FROM THE LEFT
SIDE.
MARK: INCLUDING A RELAY THROW
AND TO REALLY GOOD QUALITY BATS.
A COUPLE RUN STORE -- SCORE FOR
LUIS RENGIFO TODAY.
MATT: COUNT THAT AS A
POTENTIALLY PLEASANT PROBLEM FOR
JOE MADDON, TO HAVE TOO MANY
PIECES OFFENSIVELY.
THAT HAS NOT BEEN THE STORY FOR
MUCH OF THE YEAR.
LUIS RENGIFO STRIKES OUT.
ONE GONE FOR FARMER IN THE
EIGHTH.
JOE MADDON OVER THE WEEKEND
SPEAKING WITH THE ANGELS MANAGER
, HAS PASSED DAVEY JOHNSON ON
THE ALL-TIME MANAGERIAL WINS
LIST.
THERE'S DAVID FLETCHER NOW WITH
ONE GONE.
HE'S BEEN HACKING AT THE FIRST
PITCH ALL NIGHT.
TWO AWAY.
WE ASKED JOE MADDON BECAUSE JOE
HAS BEEN AT THIS FOR SUCH A LONG
TIME.
YOU KNOW HE IS MATCHED UP WITH
MIGUEL CABRERA IN HIS CAREER.
WE ASK HIM, WHAT IS THE MOMENT,
YOU EITHER GOT BURNED BY CABRERA
ARE YOU REMEMBER SOMETHING ON
THE FIELD, AND HE RECALLED
CHAPTER AND VERSE AN EPISODE
MANAGING TAMPA BAY YEARS AGO
WHERE IN A THREE-GAME SERIES,
THREE STRAIGHT GAMES IN THE
SEVENTH INNING WITH RUNNERS AT
FIRST AND SECOND AND TWO GONE,
HE WALKED MIGUEL CABRERA TO LOAD
THE BASES.
AND ON EACH TIME, HIS RELIEVER
WAS ABLE TO GET OUT OF THE JAM.
RAJAI: THAT IS SOME RESPECT
RIGHT THERE.
MATT: THREE STRAIGHT NIGHTS HE
WALKED HIM IN THE SEVENTH INNING
EACH TIME.
RAJAI: AND HAD THE COURAGE TO
CONTINUE TO DO THAT.
MATT: A BASE HIT, MAYBE MORE,
INTO LEFT FIELD.
CREDIT BY DO FORGETTING THERE
QUICKLY AND HOLDING UPTON TO A
SINGLE.
MARK: THAT WAS A ROCKET DOWN THE
THIRD-BASE LINE.
HE'S DONE A NICE JOB IN THAT
LEADOFF SPOT.
21 RUN SCORED IN 21 GAMES FOR
JUSTIN UPTON IN THE LEADOFF
SPOT.
HE'S THE RICKEY HENDERSON
CHARACTER.
MATT: NOW WE NEED JUSTIN TO
START TALKING ABOUT HIMSELF AND
THE THIRD PERSON.
RAJAI: RICKY HAD SOME GREAT
STORIES.
MATT: WAS HE AROUND THE A'S A
LOT WHEN YOU WERE THERE?
RAJAI: DEFINITELY, ESPECIALLY
SPRING TRAINING.
HE WOULD COME DOWN FOR ABOUT TWO
WEEKS AND WE WOULD JUST LAUGH
AND LAUGH.
HE HAD SOME OF THE GREATEST
STORIES.
MATT: BASEBALL STORIES OR?
NON-BASEBALL STORIES?
RAJAI: BASEBALL STORIES.
FANS CONSTANTLY WEARING HIM OUT,
AND HIM GOING TO THE FANS LIKE,
GIVE ME A BREAK, AND THAT KIND
OF THING.
HIS STORYTELLING IS ON POINT.
MATT: A BALL AND A STRIKE THE
COUNT TO JOSE IGLESIAS.
FOUL BALL.
MARK: HIS MEMORY OF WHAT
PITCHERS TRY TO GET HIM OUT
WITH, HE KNEW EVERY SINGLE
PITCH.
HE WAS INCREDIBLY INTELLIGENT ON
THE BASEBALL FIELD.
HE KNEW EXACTLY WHAT HE NEEDED
TO DO MOST ON THE FIELD AND
ESPECIALLY ON THE BASIS.
HE DID GET ME ONE TIME.
I THROUGH FIRST PITCH FASTBALL
THINKING HE WAS GOING TO TAKE
IT, AND HE GOT ME.
HE DID HIS FREAKY HOME RUN TROT
TOO.
I WAS LIKE, NO WAY HE WILL SWING
AT THE FIRST PITCH.
HE STARTS LAUGHING AT ME AS HE
IS GOING AROUND.
HE GOT ME.
MATT: A BALL AND TWO STRIKES THE
COUNT TO JOSÉ IGLESIAS.
2-2.
WHEN THE TIGERS BAT IN THEIR
HALF OF THE NIGHT, IT WILL BE
CASTRO, JONATHAN SCHOOP HAS BEEN
THEIR BIGGEST BAT TONIGHT.
WE ARE GOING RIGHT THERE IN A
THREE RUN GAME.
FARMER STRANDS A RUNNER.
TO THE TOP OF THE NINE, LAST
CHANCE FOR THE TIGERS, TRAILING
BY THREE.
THE TIGERS HAD WON THEIR FIRST
THREE GAMES OF THE SEASON WHEN
THEIR ACE TOOK THE MOUND ON A
COLD SATURDAY AFTERNOON.
IF THERE COULD BE DRAMA JUST THE
FOURTH GAME OF THE SEASON, JACK
MORRIS PROVIDED IT.
>> ONE THING IN MIND, TO WIN THE
GAME.
>> WE'VE GOT IT GOING NOW.
JACK MORRIS HAS NOT ALLOWED TO
HIT OR SEVEN INNINGS.
>> MORRIS DIDN'T NEED A LOT OF
HELP THAT DAY, BUT WHEN HE DID,
HIS DEFENSE MAKE SURE HE GOT IT.
>> A DRIVE TO RIGHT FIELD GETS
HIM GOING BACK, ON THE TRACK, AT
THE WALL, ONE-HANDED.
NOW EVEN THE WHITE SOX FANS ARE
CHEERING FOR MORRIS.
>> EVERYONE STARTS TO BE AWARE
OF THEIR SURROUNDINGS AND
PREPARING OF WHAT MIGHT HAPPEN.
>> HE HAS HIS NO-HITTER.
>> THAT WAS SHOWING YOU AN
ADVANCE OF WHAT ARE YOUR WAS
GOING TO BE LIKE.
-- WHAT OUR YEAR WAS GOING TO BE
LIKE.
MATT: NEW TO THE MLB GAME OF THE
WEEK IS THE YOUTUBE PLAYER OF
THE GAME.
FANS WATCHING TONIGHT ON MOBILE
DEVICES, COMPUTERS, VOTE FOR
WHICH PLAYER WILL RECEIVE THE
TROPHY DURING THE POST GAME SHOW
COMING UP IN A BIT.
WHO WILL BE OUR PLAYER OF THE
GAME TONIGHT?
A COUPLE OF PRETTY STRONG
CANDIDATES.
EITHER SHOHEI OHTANI OR TAYLOR
WARD, THE GUY WHO BROKE IT OPEN
WITH THE SLAM.
VOTE NOW.
TIGERS FANS ARE PROBABLY
WATCHING, THINKING, WAIT A
MINUTE, THERE STILL THREE OUTS
LEFT FOR ONE OF OUR GUYS TO BE
PLAYER OF THE GAME, AND YOU ARE
RIGHT.
WE RESERVE THE RIGHT TO CHANGE
THE NOMINEES BASED ON THE RESULT
OF THE GAME.
CASTRO, CAMERON, AND GROSSMAN.
CASTRO HAS AN EXTRA-BASE HIT TO
LEAD THINGS OFF IN THE TOP OF
THE NIGHT.
MARK: A NICE JOB OF STAYING BACK
ON THIS ONE.
RAJAI: THAT IS GOOD HITTING
RIGHT THERE.
MARK: THIS ALLOWS IGLESIAS TO
PROVIDE THE POWER FOR HIM.
MATT: SO NOW DAZ CAMERON WHO
DOUBLED AND SCORED, ONE OF THE
3/8 INNING RUNS.
IGLESIAS, HIS SINGLE-GAME PITCH
COUNT HIGH IS 30 THIS YEAR.
17 AND COUNTING HERE AND STILL
THREE OUTS AWAY FROM CLOSING
THIS DOWN.
TWO BALLS AND NO STRIKES.
RAJAI: DO WE HAVE SOMEBODY UP IN
THE PEN?
MATT: HE'S GOT ONE OUT.
CASTRO TO THIRD.
MARK: IN YOUR MINDSET IS A
CLOSER, THAT RUN DOESN'T MATTER
AT ALL.
IS THE GUY COMING UP ON DECK,
THAT'S THE GUY YOU WORRY ABOUT.
HE'S A TOUGH HITTER NOW.
WE MENTION HOW GOOD ROBBIE
GROSSMAN IS WITH RUNNERS IN
SCORING POSITION.
THIS IS A VERY DIFFICULT OUT FOR
IGLESIAS.
JUST ONE CAREER PLATE APPEARANCE
BETWEEN THESE TWO.
IGLESIAS WITH HIS TIME AT
CINCINNATI AND GROSSMAN WITH HIS
TIME IN HOUSTON AND OAKLAND.
0-1.
MATT: GROSSMAN HAS WALKED,
STRUCK OUT, FLIED OUT AND
SINGLED IN A RUN TONIGHT.
0-2.
THIS IS A BIG HITTER HERE, TO
YOUR PREVIOUS POINT.
JONATHAN SCHOOP ON DECK, HE IS
HOT TONIGHT.
IF GROSSMAN GETS ON BASE, HE
WILL BAT AS THE TYING RUN.
MARK: GROSSMAN STILL LOOKS
COMFORTABLE, EVEN THOUGH HE HAS
TWO STRIKES, BECAUSE HE'S BEEN
SWINGING THE BAT WELL.
MATT: A VERY DIFFICULT THAT IS
RETIRED ON THREE PITCHES.
-- BAT IS RETIRED.
MARK: WHEN YOU HAVE A HITTER
TRACKING LOW, CHANGING EYE LEVEL
, YOU SEE HOW HE PULLED OFF ON
THAT ONE, THAT FOUR-SEAM
FASTBALL UPSTAIRS.
BY DESIGN AT 98, THAT WAS A
GREAT PITCH.
HE WAS GOING TO HIT IT HARD.
THAT CHANGE OF EYE LEVEL GOT HIM
OUT.
MATT: JONATHAN SCHOOP HAS
HOMERED AND SINGLED.
TAKES A FASTBALL FOR A STRIKE.
A BALL AND A STRIKE NOW.
CANDELARIO HOPING FOR A CHANCE
ON DECK.
HE REPRESENTS THE TYING RUN.
I GUESS HE CHECKED HIS SWING.
IT'S TWO BALLS AND A STRIKE.
MATT: I THINK THAT WAS SUZUKI
THAT TOOK TIME.
TWO BALLS AND A STRIKE TO SCHOOP
.
MARK: A VERY PRODUCTIVE, PATIENT
AT BAT WORKING FOR SCHOOP NOW.
MATT: JONATHAN SCHOOP'S CHASE
PERCENTAGE GOES WAY DOWN WHEN HE
IS AHEAD.
AND HE LAYS OUT THAT FASTBALL,
AND NOW THE TYING RUN WILL HAVE
A CHANCE TO DIG IN AT THE PLATE.
NO SIX OUT SAVE IS GOING TO COME
EASY, NOW PERHAPS JUST TO --
MATT WISE COMES OUT FOR A
CONVERSATION.
CANDELARIO HAS A COUPLE OF HITS
AND HAS ALSO WALKED TONIGHT.
CHRIS RODRIGUEZ IS UP IN THE
ANGELS BULLPEN.
AFTER CANDELARIO IT WOULD BE
MIGUEL CABRERA.
CREDIT THE TIGERS, THEY HAVE NOT
GONE DOWN EASILY THIS GAME.
THE BIG FIVE RUN INNING BY THE
ANGELS, A.J. HINCH, HIS GUYS
COUNTERPUNCH WITH THREE IN THE
EIGHTH, AND NOW THEY PUT THE
TYING RUN AT THE PLATE WITH TWO
OUT IN THE TOP OF THE NINTH.
0-1.
THAT ONE GETS AWAY FROM SUZUKI.
CASTRO IS ABLE TO SCORE EASILY
TO MAKE IT AN EVEN MORE
INTERESTING STORY.
A TO RUN GAME NOW WITH TWO OUT
IN THE NINTH.
MARK: SUZUKI DIDN'T GET THE BODY
OVER THERE TO BLOCK IT, TRY TO
GET IT WITH THE GLOVE, BUT IT
GETS BY HIM.
MATT: ONE HOP DOWN TO THE SHIFT
AT SECOND, LECTURES THROW IS
ABLE TO RETIRE THE SIDE AND
FINISH BUSINESS TONIGHT.
MARK: THAT WAS A TOUGH PLAY FOR
FLETCHER.
THAT BASEBALL IS IN THE DIRT, HE
STAYED WITH IT, ALONG THROW,
ABLE TO FINISH OFF THE GAME.
THAT WAS NOT AN EASY ONE.
CREDIT THE TIGERS.
JOE MADDON PICKS UP HIS 1312TH
CAREER WIN.
RAJAI: THAT BALL TOOK AN
UNNATURAL HOT.
FOR FLETCHER TO STAY WITH THAT
BALL IS PRETTY IMPRESSIVE.
MATT: THE ANGELS ABLE TO HANG
ON, A WELL-EARNED TO ONE WRITTEN
IN FRONT OF THE HOME CROWD,
NEARLY 40,000 FANS AT ANGEL
STADIUM AS THE ATTENDANCE
RESTRICTIONS ARE LIFTED, FULL
CAPACITY TONIGHT.
WHAT A FUN ONE FOR THE FANS TO
WATCH IN PERSON.
OUR YOUTUBE GAME OF THE WEEK
POSTGAME SHOW STARTS RIGHT NOW.
THE YOUTUBE GAME OF THE WEEK
POSTGAME SHOW IS PRESENTED BY
CHIME.
THE AFTERMATH OF A TO RUN WIN
FOR THE ANGELS, ONE MADE
POSSIBLE IN PART, IN LARGE PART
BY TAYLOR WARD'S OFFENSE OF
HEROICS TONIGHT, HIS FIRST
CAREER GRAND SLAM, PART OF A
FIVE-RUN SEVEN, AND TAYLOR JOINS
US ON OUR POSTGAME COVERAGE
TONIGHT.
WALK US THROUGH THE PLATE
APPEARANCE IN THE SEVENTH.
YOU WERE UP THERE SWINGING AT
THE FIRST PITCH.
>> I WAS JUST READY TO GO, JUST
TRYING TO DO WHAT I CAN EARLY
AND PUT A BALL IN THE AIR.
MATT: TELL US ABOUT THE FEELING,
FIRST CAREER GRAND SLAM COMING
IN FRONT OF A PACKED HOUSE
TONIGHT.
>> IT'S GREAT.
I'LL TAKE IT.
HAPPY TO GET BACK TO NORMAL,
HAVING EVERYBODY HERE.
IT'S GREAT.
GLAD I COULD DO IT.
MARK: I'M THINKING, ALL YOU WANT
TO DO IS SWING THE BAT, AND WITH
THE BASES LOADED.
>> I'M SUPER GLAD I COULD COME
THROUGH THEIR AND I'M SUPER
HAPPY THAT WE GOT THE WIN.
MARK: YOU MENTIONED SOMETHING
INTERESTING THERE, LOOKING FOR
SOMEBODY TO GET THE BALL BACK TO
YOU.
IT LOOKED LIKE IT HIT THE
WALKING -- THE ROCK PILE AND
THEN TOOK A WALK AND BOUNCE.
HAS THERE BEEN ANY REPORTS OF
THE BALL BEING LOCATED?
>> I'M NOT SURE.
OCCASIONALLY ARE BULLPEN GUY
GETS IT, BUT WE WILL JUST HAVE
TO SEE.
IF NOT, IT'S ALL GOOD.
MATT: WE WILL TAKE ANOTHER LOOK
AT IT, THE SLAM.
WE WILL DO OUR BEST TO TRY TO
PUT A GPS ON THIS THING AND GET
THE BALL FOR YOU.
I ALSO WANT TO ASK ABOUT BATTING
THIRD TONIGHT IN A REWORKED
LINEUP.
TALK ABOUT WHERE YOUR COMFORT
LEVEL IS.
ARE YOU GOOD ANYWHERE IN THE
LINEUP, OR DO YOU HAVE
DISCUSSIONS WITH JOE ABOUT THAT?
>> NO, I DON'T HAVE DISCUSSIONS
WITH JOE.
IT DOESN'T MOUNT -- IT DOESN'T
MATTER WHERE I AM IN THE LINEUP.
THAT'S ALL THAT MATTERS TO ME.
I LOVE BEING IN THAT SLOT.
LIKE I SAID, IT DOESN'T MATTER
TO ME.
SO IT'S GREAT.
MARK: THE EXCITEMENT WITH
EVERYBODY HERE AT THE BALLPARK
AND SHOHEI OHTANI ON THE MOUND.
HOW COOL WAS THAT FOR THE FANS
TO EXPERIENCE AND TO BE ABLE TO
PULL OFF A W AS WELL?
>> IT IS AMAZING.
IT SEEMS LIKE EVERY TIME HE
COMES OUT HE JUST DOES THE JOB.
IS FUN TO WATCH WHEN HE IS AT
THE PLATE.
RAJAI: I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THAT
FINISH ON THAT HOME RUN SWING,
AND THE BALANCE THAT YOU SHOWED
ON THAT.
THAT WAS NICE.
I LOVE WHEN GUYS CAN FINISH AND
HOLD THAT POSE.
I ENJOY WATCHING THAT.
>> I APPRECIATE IT.
I BEEN WORKING HARD TO GET TO
THAT POINT.
MATT: IS THE CATCHER'S GLOVE
STILL IN YOUR BAG, OR IS THAT
DONE?
>> OF COURSE IT IS.
AGAIN, LIKE I SAID, WHEREVER JOE
WANTS TO PUT ME IN THE LINEUP,
WHATEVER POSITION, I'M READY TO
GO.
WHATEVER THE TEAM NEEDS, I'M
HERE FOR HIM.
MATT: WE APPRECIATE YOU TAKING
SOME TIME WITH US.
THANKS AGAIN FOR THE TIME,
CONGRATS.
TAYLOR WARD WITH THE BIG DAY,
GRAND SLAM, FIRST CAREER SLAM.
LISTEN TO THE APPLAUSE HE IS
GETTING THERE.
LOOK AT THAT SCENE.
MATT: HAVING THE FANS BACK IN
THE BALLPARK, ANY FIRST IS GOING
TO BE GREAT, WHETHER THERE ARE
FANS IN THERE OR NOT.
BUT I DON'T THINK TAYLOR IS
GOING TO EVER FORGET THIS NIGHT
AND THAT MOMENT, A SLAM IN FRONT
OF 40,000 FANS.
MARK: I LOVE WHAT HE SAID, AS
LONG AS HE PENCILS ME INTO THE
BATTING ORDER, WHETHER 7, 6, OR
THIRD LIKE HE WAS HERE TONIGHT
FOR THE ANGELS, IN THERE DOING
SOME DAMAGE WITH THE GRAND SLAM.
MATT: A FUNNY THING HAPPENS ON
THE WAY TO A SHOHEI OHTANI START
WHERE THERE'S ANOTHER PLAYER
THAT DOMINATES THE HEADLINES.
THAT WAS WARD WITH THE GRAND
SLAM.
HOWEVER, OUR VIEWERS HAVE VOTED
AND SHOHEI OHTANI IS THE WINNER
OF THE PLAYER OF THE NIGHT.
MARK: HIS SLIDER WAS REALLY
EFFECTIVE.
HE THREW 78 PITCHES, 49 STRIKES.
HE GOT TO DOUBLE PLAYS TURNED
BEHIND HIM.
HE HAD ONLY HAD ONE THIS ENTIRE
SEASON BUT HE HAD THE GROUNDBALL
WORKING FOR HIM TODAY.
I LOVE TO SLIDER TODAY.
HE HAS FOR A FRAUD PITCHES TO GO
TO AND HE WENT WITH HIS SLIDER
TO GET THE BIG OUT TODAY INSTEAD
OF THE SPLITTER OR EVEN THE CUT
FASTBALL.
MATT: THE E.R.A. SETTLES IN AT
2.70.
HIS 10TH START, THERE'S NO DOUBT
IN ANYBODY'S MIND HE IS HEADING
TO DENVER AS AN ALL-STAR, COMING
UP IN LESS THAN A MONTH.
HAD YOU EVER SEEN HIM PITCH
BEFORE TONIGHT?
RAJAI: I HAD NOT SEEN HIM, NOT
LIVE, ANYWAY.
BUT IT IS FUN WATCHING HIM FROM
THE TV SCREEN.
MATT: HE HAD A CAREER-HIGH'S --
CAREER-HIGH SLIDER USE IT.
GIVE ME YOUR THOUGHTS ON OHTANI
ON THE MOUND.
RAJAI: HE WAS EFFECTIVELY
GETTING AHEAD OF HITTERS.
OBVIOUSLY IT'S HARD TO HIT HIM,
ONCE HE GETS TO STRIKE ZONE A
BATTER, THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
HAVE MUCH SUCCESS.
HE WAS ABLE TO GET AHEAD AND PUT
AWAY THE BATTERERS.
MATT: AN EXAMPLE OF A GUY WHO IS
WINNING DIFFERENTLY, ONLY FIVE,
WHICH IS A PRETTY LOW TOTAL FOR
HIM.
JUST A DIFFERENT METHOD OR PLAN
FOR HIM TONIGHT.
MARK: HE WENT WITH HIS CUT
FASTBALL AND GOT A LOT OF OUTS.
IT'S AMAZING OUT HE REINVENTS
HIMSELF.
HE FIELDED THE POSITION VERY
WELL ON THAT BUNT.
THEN SHOWING HIS DANCE MOVES
THAT FIRST BASE.
HE DID A LITTLE BIT OF
EVERYTHING.
I LOVE WHAT JOE MADDON TOLD ME A
FEW WEEKS AGO, THERE'S SOMETHING
ABOUT SHOHEI, HE WILL ADJUST AND
BE ABLE TO GO OUT AND WHATEVER
NEEDS TO GET A W, AND HE DID
THAT TODAY.
THE ANGELS SNAP THEIR
THREE-GAME LOSING STREAK.
DID WE GO TO BALBOA ISLAND AND
WE WERE NOT INVITING -- INVITED?
>> THIS PLACE WENT BERSERK.
THEY HAVE HAD SO MANY RALLY'S
THIS YEAR.
DO THEY HAVE ANOTHER ONE LEFT IN
THEM?
>> TO THE WALL, IT'S GONE.
A HOME RUN.
IT'S A TWO RUN GAME.
THE ANGELS ARE RIGHT BACK INTO
IT.
ALONG DRIVE DEEP TO RIGHT, IT IS
GONE.
IT IS A ONE RUN GAME.
THE NEVER SAY DIE ANGELS GIVING
THEIR FANS A THRILL DOWN THE
STRETCH.
IN THE GAP, HERE COMES ANDERSON.
THE ANGELS TAKE THE LEAD 6-5.
>> WE ARE ONE STRIKE AWAY FROM
GAME SEVEN.
SWUNG ON AND MISSED.
WHAT A BALLGAME.
THE ANAHEIM ANGELS ARE STILL
BREATHING.
WE ARE GOING TO GAME SEVEN,
INCREDIBLY.
MATT: ANGELS DEFEAT THE TIGERS
IN THE FIRST OF WEEKEND SERIES.
7-5 THE FINAL TONIGHT.
IN CASE YOU MISSED THE
HIGHLIGHTS, HERE IS HOW IT WENT
DOWN.
THE 26-YEAR-OLD SHOHEI OHTANI TO
MAKE HIS TENT STARTING
ASSIGNMENT OF THE YEAR, MOST
RECENTLY FRIDAY IN THE DESERT.
IT'S A SWING AND A MISS.
STRIKES OUT -- SCHOOP STRIKES
OUT.
THREE FASTBALL STRIKE OUT A GUY
KNOWN AS ONE OF THE BETTER
FASTBALL HITTERS IN BASEBALL.
ANGELS ARE HOPING TO HAVE
ANTHONY RENDON BACK TOMORROW.
THAT ONE IS INTO RIGHT FIELD.
AKIL BADDOO IS AROUND SECOND, ON
HIS WAY TO THIRD.
THE THROW IS IN TIME.
MARK: THAT'S ABOUT HIS TEXTBOOK
AS YOU CAN DO AS FAR AS GETTING
TO THE RELAY MAN.
GETS INTO THIRD BASE, YOU CANNOT
PLAY THAT ANY BETTER AS FAR AS
HEATING RELAY MAN.
MATT: MANNING MAKING HIS
MAJOR-LEAGUE DEBUT TONIGHT.
>> COMING AROUND TO SCORE, THE
THROW GETS AWAY FROM HIM.
THE ANGELS ARE THE FIRST TO
SCORE TONIGHT.
2-0 ANGELS.
MARK: SECONDARY PITCHES ARE THE
ONE THAT SET UP THE FASTBALL.
MATT: SLIPPED A HEATER RIGHT
PASS UPTON WHO WAS NOT LOOKING.
HE HAS A COUPLE MORE YEARS LEFT
ON HIS MASSIVE CONTRACT.
THAT GOT HIM IN THE HELMET.
RAJAI: THAT'S ALWAYS SCARY,
GOING UP AND IN, INTO THE
BATTER'S HAND, SHOULDER AND NECK
AREA.
THOSE ARE SCARY MOMENTS FOR
BATTERERS.
MATT: YOU ARE RIGHT, HE GOT HIM
IN THE ARM, MERCIFULLY.
ERIC HAASE WITH A BOUNCER UP
OVER THE MIDDLE.
THE ANGELS ARE IN THE PERFECT
SPOT.
FIRST AND SECOND, NOBODY OUT AND
DETROIT IS TURNED AWAY IN THE
FOURTH.
MATT: HE WILL FACE JUSTIN UPTON
FOR THE THIRD TIME.
STRUCK HIM OUT FOR THE SECOND
TIME ON A 95 MILE AN HOUR
HEATER.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENED WHEN
SHOHEI GOT TO FIRST BASE WITH
MIGUEL CABRERA.
RAJAI: THAT IS MIGUEL CABRERA
ALL THE TIME.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHO IT IS,
THAT IS HIM ALL DAY.
MATT: ALL THAT FOR NOTHING.
ONE GONE FOR JONATHAN SCHOOP,
WHO STRUCK OUT TWICE IN THE GAME
TONIGHT.
UPTON CAN ONLY WATCH, AND THAT
ONE IS GONE.
RAJAI: JONATHAN HAS BEEN ON A
TEAR LATELY.
MATT: THERE IS ONE BOUNCED TO
THE RIGHT SIDE.
DANCE MOVES.
YOU JUST CANNOT TAKE YOUR EYES
OFF THIS GUY.
EVERYTHING HE DOES IS BETTER AND
MORE FUN TO WATCH THEM WITH
ANYBODY ELSE IN THE LEAGUE.
FIVE STRIKEOUTS FOR OHTANI.
RAJAI: A GREAT OPPORTUNITY A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY IT, GREAT TIME
TO STEAL.
MATT: BACK TO SUZUKI, THIS IS
ALL WORD.
WALSH IS INVOLVED NOW.
DOES HE GET HIM?
HE DOES.
JOSÉ IGLESIAS IS THE PINCH
HITTER.
NON-STARTED GETTING US AGILE DAY
OFF HIS FEET.
FLETCHER IS HELD AT THIRD.
3-1 ANGELS.
NOW I TO RUN LEAD FOR THE
ANGELS.
TAYLOR WARD WITH THE BASES
LOADED.
0-3 TONIGHT SO FAR.
A DRIVE TO LEFT FIELD.
THAT ONE IS GONE.
TAYLOR WARD'S FIRST CAREER HIT
WITH THE BASES LOADED IS A GRAND
SLAM THAT HAS BLOWN THIS ONE
WIDE OPEN.
MATT: CREDIT THE TIGERS BECAUSE
THEY WOULD, PARDON THE PUN, CLAW
THEIR WAY BACK.
CANDELARIO WOULD WALK TO LOAD
THE BASES.
JOE MADDON HAD TO GO BACK TO THE
BULLPEN AND IGLESIAS WAS CALLED
ON TO EXECUTE A SIX OUT SAY.
CABRERA CAUGHT LOOKING.
NIKO GOODRUM WOULD FOLLOW WITH
AN R.B.I. SINGLE.
THIS MADE IT A 7-3 GAME.
ANOTHER RUN WOULD SCORE FOR
DETROIT.
7-4 ANGELS HERE.
THE ANGELS WOULD ESCAPE WITH THE
LEAD INTACT.
7-4 GAME, TOP OF THE NINTH AND
THE TIGERS KEEP FIGHTING.
BRINGS THE TYING RUN TO THE
PLATE.
A WILD PITCH WOULD MAKE IT
INTERESTING.
7-5 GAME NOW.
ON THE VERY NEXT PITCH, DAVID
FLETCHER MAKES THE PLAY.
THE BALL HIT THE CUT OUT AND
TOOK A SKID.
FLETCHER MADE A GOOD PLAY ON IT
TO PRESERVE THE VICTORY FOR THE
ANGELS.
7-5 WIN FOR THE HOME SIDE.
FIVE RUNS ON 11 HITS, TWO ERRORS
FOR THE TIGERS.
THE ANGELS THREE-GAME LOSING
STREAK IS GONE AS THE TIGERS LOU
THEIR THREE-GAME WINNING STREAK.
LET'S SEND IT OUT TO ALEX CURRY.
>> WE KNEW IT WOULD BE A FUN AND
EXCITING GAME TONIGHT.
THE FANS WERE LOUD AND THEY WERE
WILD.
YOU CAN TELL THE PLAYERS LOVED
IT, THEY WERE FEEDING OFF IT.
ESPECIALLY SHOHEI OHTANI, WHO
PUT ON A SHOW IMPROVED WHY HE IS
MUCH MUCH -- MUST WATCH TV.
EVEN SOME TIGERS PLAYERS SHARED
THAT THEY WERE SO EXCITED TO
WATCH HIM PLAY TONIGHT.
WE HEARD WE GO CABRERA HAVING A
GREAT TIME, HE WAS MESSING WITH
THEM.
SOMETHING I MENTIONED DURING THE
GAME WAS HOW GREAT IT IS TO SEE
SHOHEI OHTANI SHOW EMOTION THIS
SEASON.
YOU CAN TELL HE'S HAVING A GOOD
TIME.
HE'S IN THE MOMENT, HE'S GETTING
EXCITED FOR HIS TEAMMATES MAKING
GREAT PLACE BEHIND HIM.
IT IS A DIFFERENT OHTANI WE ARE
SEEING THIS SEASON.
THERE'S A FEW REASONS WHY.
NUMBER ONE, HE IS HEALTHY.
HE FEELS GOOD BOTH ON THE MOUND
AND AT THE PLATE, AND HE IS IS
SHOWING.
HE CAN DO IT ALL.
HE IS LAUGHING ABOUT IT, HIS
TEAMMATES ARE LAUGHING ABOUT IT.
HIS TEAM IS HAVING A GREAT TIME.
IT IS SO FUN TO SEE HIM SHOW HIS
EMOTIONS, SHOW THAT HE IS HAVING
A GREAT TIME, BOTH ON THE MOUND
AND AT THE PLATE.
I KNOW THESE FANS HERE TONIGHT
WERE IN FOR A TREAT TO SEE
SHOHEI OHTANI PUT ON THIS
PERFORMANCE TONIGHT.
MATT: A FUN FANS, FOR THE HOME .
WE ARE BACK WITH MORE ON THE
CHIME POSTGAME SHOW, RIGHT AFTER
THIS.
>> STRIKE THREE.
THAT WAS A GREAT PLAY.
>> TALKED ABOUT HIS FIELDING
SKILLS, THAT WAS REMARKABLE.
>> SOMETHING LIKE THIS IS WHAT
THEY CAME FOR.
>> YOU CAN'T BELIEVE IT.
WHAT A FINISH.
MATT: WELCOME BACK TO THE
YOUTUBE MLB POST GAME SHOW,
PRESENTED BY CHIME.
AFTER AN ANGELS VICTORY IN THE
SEASON OPENER, LET'S TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT MATT MANNING
WHO MADE HIS MAJOR-LEAGUE DEBUT,
STRUCK OUT THREE, WALKED TO.
ABOUT TWO THIRDS OF WHAT HE
THREW TONIGHT WAS A FASTBALL BUT
I DON'T THINK YOU CAN LOOK AT
THIS AS ANYTHING OTHER THAN A
SUCCESSFUL MAJOR-LEAGUE DEBUT
FOR THE YOUNG RIGHT-HANDER.
MARK: I WAS REALLY IMPRESSED,
AFTER THAT FIRST INNING,
OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE GOING TO BE A
LITTLE NERVOUS.
A GOOD RELEASE .4 HIM.
54 FASTBALLS, CURVEBALL USUALLY
ONE OF HIS BEST PITCHES IS HIS
KNUCKLE CURVEBALL.
HE RECOGNIZED THERE'S A NUMBER
OF HITTERS IN THAT LINEUP THAT
REALLY HIT BREAKING BALLS AND
OFF-SPEED PITCHES.
HE WENT WITH HIS FASTBALL AND I
THOUGHT HE THREW THE BALL WELL.
I LIKE HIS STUFF A LOT.
47 STRIKES, TWO WALKS AND THREE
STRIKEOUTS.
YOU CAN TELL HE'S A FORMER
BASKETBALL PLAYER BECAUSE HE
MADE IT LOOK EASY.
I THINK THE FUTURE FOR THIS KID,
LIKE A.J. HINCH TOLD US BEFORE
THE GAME, HE'S GOT A LOT OF
CONFIDENCE AND HE SHOWED IT HERE
TONIGHT.
MATT: YOU COULD SEE IT WITH HIM,
BIG ARM, BIG PROSPECT WE SAW
MAJOR FLASHES OF THAT TONIGHT.
RAJAI: YOU CAN SEE THAT
CONFIDENCE HE HAD ON THE MOUND.
HE WAS OUT THERE ATTACKING
HITTERS IN THE ZONE, ESPECIALLY
WHEN HE GOT BEHIND IN THE COUNT,
HE WAS STILL ATTACKING IN THE
ZONE.
JUST TO GO OUT THERE AND HAVE AN
OUTING LIKE THAT IS DEFINITELY A
PLUS FOR HIM.
YOU WANT HIM TO TAKE HIS LAST
APPEARANCE IN THE MINOR LEAGUE,
WHICH WAS A GOOD ONE, AND BRING
IT UP TO THE MAJOR LEAGUES.
THAT LOOKS LIKE WHAT HE DID.
HE WAS ABLE TO BRING THAT VIBE,
THAT FEELING OF BEING SUCCESSFUL
, OF EXECUTING.
WHAT I SAW WAS AN EXPLOSIVE
FASTBALL.
I SAW THE BALL EXPLODING OUT OF
HIS HANDS.
IT LOOKED LIKE IT STAYED ON THAT
SAME PLANE.
IT'S A LITTLE TOUGHER TO HIT
WHEN A PITCHER IS ABLE TO DO
THAT.
MATT: HE'S GOT TO SIGN THOSE
AUTOGRAPHS WITH A BALL POINT,
NOT A SHARPIE.
SHARPIES FADE OVER TIME.
THE CONTENT CREATOR SAID HIS NOW
SHE WILL BE NASTY AND A COUPLE
OF YEARS.
YOU ARE SPOT ON.
THE FUTURE IS VERY BRIGHT FROM A
PITCHING STANDPOINT IN DETROIT.
>> THIS DUDE, JACOB DEGROM, THEY
HAD AN MRI ON HIS SHOULDER THAT
CAME BACK CLEAN.
GIANTS ARE STILL ROLLING.
WHAT IS GOING ON THERE?
OAKLAND A'S HAVE WON SIX IN A
ROW, OFF TO THE REST START SINCE
1990.
THEY TOP THE PACK IN THE AL
WEST.
SOME OF YOUR OLD UNIFORMS
HANGING UP IN THE HOUSE.
OAKLAND A'S OFF TO A GREAT
START.
RAJAI: A LOT OF THE GUYS THAT
ARE THERE NOW ARE REALLY YOUNG.
YOU SEE THEIR TALENT AND YOU
KNOW THESE GUYS ARE GOING TO BE
GOOD A COUPLE OF YEARS FROM NOW.
NOW TO SEE THEM JUST COMING INTO
THEIR OWN, YOU HAVE FIRST
BASEMAN OLSON, THESE GUYS ARE
COMING INTO THEIR OWN.
THEY'VE ALWAYS BEEN GOOD.
NOW THEY ARE REALLY STARTING TO
GET COMFORTABLE.
MATT: I WANT TO GO TO YOU ON THE
DEGROM STORY.
WE TALKED ABOUT KEVIN GAUSMAN,
YU DARVISH HAS HAD A NICE YEAR.
WE ARE ONLY IN MID JUNE.
MARK: HE HAS MORE R.B.I.'S THAN
HE HAS ALLOWED RUNS THIS YEAR ON
THE MOUND.
HE IS AMAZING.
AND YOU KNOW AS A HITTER YOU
WILL GET A CHANCE TO GO OUT
THERE AND TRY TO MAKE CONTACT
WITH THE FASTBALL.
HE HAS THE ILLUSION IF IT IS
RISING UP IN THE STRIKE ZONE,
HE'S GOT THOSE GOOD SECONDARY
PITCHES.
I LOVE WHAT FREDDIE FREEMAN
SAID.
THE R.B.I.'S, SWINGING THE BATS
ARE OK.
STAY ON THE MOUND, THAT'S WHAT
EVERYONE WANTS TO SEE.
MATT: OUR FINAL HIGHLIGHT ON THE
GAME OF THE WEEK POSTGAME SHOW
HAS TO COME FROM A BYGONE ERA.
LET'S TAKE YOU BACK TO 2016.
A THREE RUN SHOT AGAINST
CHAPMAN.
I THOUGHT RAJAI DAVIS WAS GOING
TO BE M.V.P. OF THE WORLD
SERIES, THE TRIBE WOULD COME
BACK AND WIN.
WE ASKED JOE MADDON ABOUT THAT
TODAY ON OUR CALL, AND YOUR
CONNECTION DIED IN MY CAR.
RAJAI: I HAD NO CONNECTION AND
NO SERVICE, I'M WONDERING, WHAT
IS GOING ON HERE?
WHAT COULD I DO?
MATT: WE ASK YOU THE SAME THING,
LIKE YOU GUYS HAD NEVER SPOKEN
SINCE THAT, A DRAMATIC MOMENT.
THE SERIES HAPPENED SO FAST,
BIGGER THINGS TO TALK ABOUT.
NICE SWING AGAINST MY CLOSER
YESTERDAY, HE WASN'T ABOUT TO DO
THAT, BUT HE DID SAY THIS, WHICH
I THOUGHT WAS FASCINATING.
HE WAS WONDERING WHY YOU DIDN'T
STEAL A BAG.
RAJAI: I WAS KIND OF WONDERING
WHY COULDN'T STEAL A BAG.
THAT WAS ONE OF THOSE INSTANCES
LIKE, I'M READY TO GO.
MATT: THAT WAS IN THE TENT AFTER
THE RAIN DELAY?
RAJAI: RIGHT.
I JUST HAD GOT AN R.B.I. SINGLE,
SO I'M READY TO GO.
MIKE MARTINEZ UP, I'M READY TO
GO, BUT I WAS TOLD TO STAND DOWN
, SO I HAD TO LISTEN AT THAT
TIME.
I WAS A LITTLE NERVOUS.
MATT: IT COULD HAVE BEEN
DIFFERENT HISTORY, IF THEY HAD
LET OUR GUY GO.
THE INDIANS WOULD HAVE WON THE
SERIES.
MARK: YOU BETTER JUST HOLD THE
BALL FOR A LONG TIME, OTHERWISE
HE'S GOING TO BE AT SECOND AND
THIRD BASE.
YOU ARE A GREAT BASE STEALER.
YOU GOT MORE FASTBALLS FOR THAT
HITTER AT THE PLATE BECAUSE THAT
WAS THEIR ONLY CHANCE, IF THEY
GOT A GOOD FASTBALL, BECAUSE YOU
WERE A REALLY GOOD BASE STEALER.
RAJAI: THAT'S ONE THING I ALWAYS
TRY TO REALLY FOCUS ON, TO BREAK
THE PITCHER'S ATTENTION AND HIS
FOCUS.
OBVIOUSLY HE'S NOT GOING TO
THROW PITCHES THE SAME, HE'S
GOING TO MAKE MORE MISTAKES.
IF HE IS FOCUSED ON ME, TRYING
TO GET ME OUT AT FIRST, DON'T
TRY THAT.
PLEASE DON'T TRY THAT.
THAT'S WHAT I WANT YOU TO DO.
MATT: LET'S LOOK AT THE UPCOMING
SCHEDULE OF GAMES, A'S AND
RANGERS ON TUESDAY THE 22ND,
MELODY NEWMAN, THE VOICE OF THE
BALTIMORE ORIOLES WILL BE
CALLING THE PLAY-BY-PLAY ON THAT
ONE COMING UP ON TUESDAY THE
22ND.
SEATTLE AND TORONTO THE
FOLLOWING WEEK, THEN THE REDS
AND BREWERS ON FRIDAY, JULY 9.
IT HAS BEEN A PLEASURE,
GENTLEMEN.
THANKS FOR BEING WITH US TONIGHT
ON A GLOBAL AUDIENCE ON YOUTUBE.
THE ANGELS WIN THE SERIES
OPENER.
THANKS FOR WATCHING.
SEE YOU NEXT WEEK.